[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to round three of this
tata steel chess tournament 2022.
my name is fiona stalantony and i'm
delighted to be joined once again by
grandmaster robert house robert how are
you today
i'm doing great another round from
vikanze how could i not be great there's
been fighting chess galore so we're in
store for another great one i think yes
and well let's have a look first of all
at the results we had yesterday for
those of you who might have missed the
action
the big game of the day of course was
magnus carlsen victory over anish giri
actually the first time that magnus beat
anish here in vikenzi
thus finally levelling the score anish
famously beat him here all the way back
in 2011 and ever since magnus was
chasing that first classical vikings a
win against anish he got it yesterday
robert
yeah that was a huge victory and it was
a resounding one because it would
involve an exchange sacrifice beautiful
tactics anish wasn't up for the task and
we can't forget about that game between
rapport and von forest it was a long
battle on 4g for jordan the reigning
champion he was not able to withstand
the pressure he made a mistake nearing
the time patrol
yes and if you've missed that game you
can check out our rapid recap on our
youtube channel where we go through the
main points of that game the other
decisive result was a richard report
overcoming jordan van ferece after
jordan blundered late into the the end
game so those were the two decisive
results and out of the draws i think uh
robert mamedyarov against panko had to
stand out
yeah mama jerome has been playing such
electric chest thus far his two draws
don't speak to the exciting chess he's
been playing we'll see how he fares in
round three today
absolutely so let's look at the
standings after two rounds uh we have
three uh players in the joint lead world
champion magnus carlsen young christian
of duda and
vidit gudrati and robert i suggest we go
straight to today's pairings because i
think there's one game that allies are
gonna be on
oh for sure because we have seven great
pairings every single day but i think i
know which one you're talking about
except for this one between yes panko
and karjakin right
the all-russian clash of course or could
it be anish against mohamed yarov no the
game that i was talking about here it is
young gustav duda against world champion
magnus carlson not only at two of the
co-leaders of the tournament but also
the leading world champion against the
winner of last year's world cup and of
course ian gershof duda has qualified to
the candidates
where he will try and become magnus's
next challenger
and we know that magnus likes a new feat
and he lost to young chisholm duda in
the world cup revenge is undoubtedly on
his mind here in vik but magnus does
have the black pieces so when you're
looking for a certain result but you
have the second move in the game i'm not
sure if that's comfortable territory for
magnus carlsen
yeah i think a very interesting matchup
here today i'm very excited to see what
happens of course a lot of other great
clashes at the american clash between
fabiano carrana and sam shankland also
we'll see how does anish bounce back
against marmodyarov who had two exciting
draws so plenty of action to look
forward to
and you too at home can get involved
robert how do they do it
well they shouldn't forget to vote
voting is a right it's a you know duty
some might say and you can get involved
by voting on the results of these games
here go to chess.com slash events
navigate to the tournament select a game
click vote and select your winner you
could win a piece of the one thousand
dollar prize best voters or free diamond
memberships voting ends after the 10th
move of each game so don't miss out and
remember to vote on all the games
fiona
i mean i think we can go vote as well
and then we'll be back and ready for the
round right absolutely don't go anywhere
we'll be back in just a few minutes and
we'll see all the players coming the
start of the game plenty to look forward
to stay tuned
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back we're just two minutes away
from the start of round three here at
the tata steel chest tournament and here
we see
the two russian players andreya sepenko
and karyakin ready to do battle also
jordan van ferweis has just arrived for
his clash
against pragnanda
and well duda robert we're not surprised
magnus is very often the last to arrive
in the playing hall
he is indeed they say save the best for
last and he's the best chess player in
the world so he has every right to come
in last but here we see all the players
there's the challenger section as well
so there should be 28 players filling up
these seats
absolutely and
this one is another game i'm very
looking forward to anish giri who i last
year went undefeated
during the chatter still chess
tournament
a tough loss against magnus and shakira
he has shown that he is not shying away
from any craziness and they're
the the all too familiar image in these
pandemic times
of rapport arriving and the players
wanting to go for a handshake and
changing it to a fist bump at the last
second
i think they're just playing rock paper
scissors fiona they they want us to
think it's about the handshake no no no
they're just playing rosham bull having
a little bit of fun and we see mom and
joe getting ready to start the club
a funny image i mean it's not even two
o'clock yet but uh
clearly raring to go
yeah he seems quite eager and if his
play has been any indication he's having
himself a good old time g4 on move three
yesterday the clocks have been pressed
anish gets to make the first move but
we'll see what surprises mama jarv has
for us today and uh while the clocks
have been started we see that duda um is
actually waiting for magnus
i think there was a video right
from the world rapid and blitz wasn't it
magnus himself who waited was it for
dude there was someone else but
uh we'll see and there is magnus we just
see him walking onto the stage we get a
proper handshake
and uh magnus starting the clock and
we'll see what opening does do did that
go for it's one e4
and you are correct it was duda versus
magnus at the world's uh blitz where he
waited for him which was very polite i
mean it could have been the rapid but
either way
it was these two players so a ton of
mutual respect between the two
dude against the white pieces in this
game he starts with e4 will we see one
of these rossolimo sicilians from magnus
he of course plays e4 e5 as black he
used that against yonda pamashi so i'm
wondering if there are just these phases
that magnus goes through how he decides
on his first turn but he is so versatile
as a player that i wouldn't be surprised
by any first move at least one that's
reasonable i would be surprised by one
opening move and that's one c6 the
carrot can because that's exactly the
opening that magnus used in his game
against duda which was the streak
though no loss streak ending game from
uh norway chess a couple of years ago
yeah so unhappy memories but sometimes
you need to fight through it right if
you fall off your bike you're trying to
learn you got to get right back on it so
we could see all pawns no hope in a
carol gun
and no magnus says we'll
take it more solidly one e5 we haven't
seen so much uh e4 e5 action so far in
the tournament robert
no we haven't really it's actually
interesting we've seen a lot of off-beat
openings we've seen some catalans but
yeah e4 e5 the traditional spanish
that's not something that we have had
thus far but today's a new day
a new opening may be the theme of the
day and of course we're still early here
in vikanze i don't mean to rhyme i'm not
dr seuss but it just so happened that it
worked out i think maybe we had only one
right in the grand delious the first
round gwendillius jordan or was it the
other way jordan with the with the white
places
but yeah very few very low passes
um so far and well we'll see
which line
um magnus goes for
i think you know of course i never want
to go away from magnus against judah but
i want to bring our attention to another
game very quickly because it's not an
opening we see every day so speaking of
how often things happen i'm going to
click on this game between von forrest
and pragma nanda because fiona look at
this opening here bishop c4 on move
three in the sicilian right it's like
once shopping one move short of
expectations but it's not a tactic
because usually the bishop lands on b5
and threatens to take the knight we've
seen this many times including the 2018
world chess championship instead the
bishop's on c4 is that really what
jordan did is it a surprise against his
young opponent
i think uh yes clearly jordan wanting to
to take uh his
uh young opponent onto
not novel territory because i'm sure
pregnant has seen the movie before but
rarer territory shall we say bishop c4
is not a move that we see often at all
uh on the highest level but jordan he's
shown us last year already always came
very well prepared with some fresh
interesting
opening ideas and so much so that even
world champion magnus carlson
his attention was drawn and he recruited
jordan on to his world championship
team yeah he is a great player
of course but also amazing in
preparation he used it to his advantage
last year but there are some pluses of
making a bit of an atypical move because
the
most logical reply in my opinion is a
move like e6 shutting down the bishop on
the diagonal but if you don't play
sicilians with the move e6 say you're
used to playing dragon type of positions
fee encountering the bishop then e6
takes you out of your element so i do
like it from the perspective that now
pragnanda has to think what does this
guy want from me there are many moves d6
makes sense e6 makes sense even g6 right
but now you have to make a choice and
then figure out what is jordan planning
so i do like this from psychological
perspective fiona absolutely agreed and
i think it's always interesting to see
games that uh leave the beaten
path quite soon and we get to see some
fresh ideas and fresh positions
robert shall we go to the bird's eye
view and get some kind of idea of what
is happening on all the other all the
other birds in these early stages
you know this has quickly become my
favorite scene to look at so we have
seven games a bunch of options to choose
from and the top left we have duda
against carlson it might you know you
could replace dude his name with
napomnishi because that opening looks
very familiar from their world
championship bout no surprise that duda
would have studied those games next to
that dubov and vidit we're in the talon
game still early stages karwana shanklin
oh that's in a berlin is maxine bashar
lagrav here no he's not the world blitz
champion is not here but his influence
and the influence of many of the great
predecessors in the berlin that's uh on
the board and actually let me ask you
fiona while we stay in this view so when
you see the berlin and you see shanklin
maybe testing carwana in these queenless
lines what do you think his mentality is
because fabiano he's had two draws
pretty solid start not exactly what he
wanted but on shanklin's end he lost the
game and then couldn't convert an
advantage yesterday so what do you think
he's looking for from the black side of
this berlin yeah i'm curious i think it
means that shankland is very confident
in his analysis i have to say the berlin
opening one of the ones that i'm
probably least familiar with in the
entire chess world i've never played
them on either side i had i never had
any interest in an early queen swap
never looked at this end game even once
but
i would say
a brave decision to to challenge fabiano
here i mean he is so
well versed but yes i'm showing
confidence and i think
what he wants is to keep it solid
and we will see what what is your uh
impression of the opening choice what do
you make of it
yeah sam is extremely well prepared but
so is fabiano and he has a lot of
experience and he decided to go into the
end game in the berlin the queens are
off so actually i'll bring that board up
so we can talk a little bit about it
because the first critical moment in
this game comes right here
after knight f6 because the anti berlin
with move the move d3 here that's
becoming increasingly popular as these
top-level players seek to avoid
preparation or at least the really deep
lines because then there's no queen
trade your pawn is defended but as we
see in the main line coming up here d4
you don't want to take on d4 that opens
up the e file your king is still in the
center so the knight retreats we see a
swap and then a capture on e5 off go the
queens and fiona you know even if you
don't play the berlin yourself of course
you're a very experienced commentator
we've seen this opening like seven
million times even if this opening has
only been played you know three million
times we have seen it way too much of it
uh for most of our likings but it is a
fascinating end game and shanklin starts
with the move king to e8 in this
position here there are many options
king 8 being the most popular moves like
bishop to d7 you could push your h pawn
uh the move bishop
d7 may say i might move my king towards
the queen side instead of back towards
the center but king e8 does make perfect
sense it protects f7 in advance it
allows black to continue playing here on
the king side and bishop f4
we see bishop e7
rook ad1 bishop e6 and b3 so we're we're
not in new territory both players have
seen this before they're playing quickly
and there have been many games in this
line and i would say the the big
principles in this position black has
the bishop pair but the compromise pawn
structure so i think people tend to
struggle with this dynamic with like
well i don't like my pawn structure
we're in an end game but fiona how does
the bishop pair compensate for
the
double pawns here
well the bishop pair
i guess black is often looking for the
position to open up for those bishops to
get even more scope
we already see the bishop on e6 looking
down at the words h3 we see that the
pawn has been pushed
to h5 so very often black will be
looking to open up the position to use
the maximum power
of the bishop here
that's true and black can do that on
both sides right there's some times
where black shirts play a5 a4 but i
think fabiano chose a y setup against
this bishop on e6 because the last thing
bishops want is to be staring into a
pawn chain like this and the b3 pawn
limits the scope so shanklin is thinking
here i believe b3 is a bit of a rare
move there's moves like knight to g5 and
after knight to g5
if we go down theoretical lines here
there's this funny move rook h6 and i've
played the berlin from black's
perspective mainly and rook h6 if you're
not familiar with this opening you're
not playing that move because you're
walking into discoveries but a move like
rook h6 once the knight captures on e6
the rook takes back and that rook is
actually quite nice there because the
bishop
is well placed on e7
the knight on f5 is looking good and
this e5 pawn can be seen as a strength
because it limits black's mobility but
the same time in certain end games it's
a pawn that's gone too far it's over
extended and can be attacked so instead
of these kind of funkier variations we
saw b3 played and now shanklin the one
taken out of his preparation uh perhaps
because if we see him on screen fiona
does that look like a thrill chess
player
it doesn't but then you very rarely i
feel like sam you see him looking
thrilled more after victory
well yesterday we saw him of course
being quite disappointed
after the game against niels grandelius
he was clearly the one in control he was
he had a big advantage at some point
but today
i don't know robert i think you're never
gonna be too thrilled if you're playing
the berlin against faviano it's never
gonna be a fun day at the office uh but
i think yes i'm mostly just looking to
stay solid here robert i've got an
interesting question uh in the chat i
saw that tanei
saw that i was asking is it common to go
for quick draws against compatriots
i think unfortunately we see that
sometimes
but
speaking about this game here i
absolutely do not think we will see a
quick draw just because they are both
from the us fabiano is of course looking
to win the tournament here in tata steel
he is playing with the white pieces sam
is one of the the lower rated players of
the field so i think uh we will
absolutely not see an early draw here
what do you think
yeah i think those draws are typically
reserved for good friends no matter what
country they are from we see that
karjakin and mamijarov historically have
often made relatively quick draws now
fabiano and shanklin i'm sure have a ton
of mutual respect but from what i know
of they're not like best friends they
don't work together that's always an
awkward scenario when sec a second plays
the person that they help prepare so
when we see dubov against carlson
because they've helped that player come
up with their openings and fine-tune
them so it's not a comfortable
experience but just being from the same
country i don't think that's
particularly meaningful uh for the most
part they're professionals they have to
score victories and important moments
and if you're just saying hey i'm
playing my friend but wait i also need
that victory that's not a good scenario
to be in so these players uh they're
very accustomed to playing people over
and over again even if they are friends
even if they are compatriots so no i do
not think we will see anything except
the battle in this game even if the
results is eventually a draw it will be
a fight and sam shanklin he's looking
like he's having an internal battle
right now because he doesn't know what
to do and that's the beauty of taking
someone out of their preparation not
with an exciting move b3 is just a move
but then you have to ask what has
changed in the position uh of course i
said in knight g5 there was rook h6
where kc is not possible now but in the
future will nigerie 5 be played by white
and then will rook h6 still be the
correct move you may ask what has
changed it looks like nothing but you
need to figure that out and sam plays
rook to d8 putting a rook to the open
file rather than
playing with like h4 which is one that i
was going to suggest or even a5 on the
opposite flank rook d8 of course
fighting for the open file you can't
really complain about that choice yeah i
think this here will be a big prep very
often this is what we see in the the
berlin end game because
as you said as it has been played so so
many times the players are so
well-versed and very often it comes down
to these tiny nuances uh where is the
new move the new idea coming from
uh so we'll see i think we'll come back
here robert i hope you don't mind taking
me taking you away from this exciting
berlin end game and maybe we can quickly
again go to the bird's eye view for one
second but we were just talking about
duboff and i was thinking maybe we could
go there because i think one of the
reasons that we have been seeing
less berlin end games is because
the italian game the joco piano has
come more into fashion in the last
couple of years and that's what we have
in this duboff vidit game
yeah it's a great transition to make so
we will look at the opening stage here
because as fiona pointed out we see
bishop c4 the italian game and after
knight f6 d3 so we were talking about
how d3 can protect the e4 pawn in these
anti-berlin positions but this is the
start of the italian bishop c5 c3
there's a flexible choice by white
perhaps there's a b4 there's a d4 in the
future challenging the bishop on c5 but
black continues with d6 opening up the
light square bishop and now fiona this
choice of bishop g5 h6 bishop h4 we see
this quite often in these italians and
the big question that is asked is
will black play g5 a very committal
choice making it more dangerous to
castle kingside even though black still
can in many positions but will vidit say
i'm ready for this i'm gonna play g5 or
does he think i'm playing daniel dubov
that guy is as creative as they get he's
clearly looking for something in this
opening maybe i should refrain from
these kind of pawn pushes
yeah i'm very curious i i'm not sure
maybe you will know this uh robert if uh
duboff often plays the italian game or
if the the relopus is more his preferred
choice because i think the question is
often
did it expect this if he expected it
it's much
much more pleasant of course to face
this decision if you have looked at it
with your computer with your second
before the game if you haven't looked at
it in a while it's more difficult to
make the decision over the board about
whether you want to go g5 or not
yeah and it's because actually after the
move d6 bishop g5 is far from the most
common move so already he has caught
vidi in an unfamiliar position because
at this point in time castling is what
most players play they say i'm just
going to get my king
over to the king side safe and sound
there are the move knight to d2 because
the knight often reroutes d2 f1 and then
either g or e3 so if you start with
knight d2 you can play knight f1 before
castling and then having to play rookie
one as well so there are plenty of
options here b4 is another so bishop g5
not the most common move but played here
in this game and after h6 bishop h4 he
plays the move a5 so on the other side
of the board stopping any sort of b4
pushes but leaving this pin alive i
think that's a good practical choice
against duboff you asked about dubob's
openings generally speaking the answer
is he plays what he wants that's what
i've learned from duboff he does play
the italian from the white side but he
is so
look i mean look at this look at that
move knight eight
i mean
i understand it right the knight is
developing it's probably just trying to
drop back to c2 or it can hop into b5
because there's no a6 move so in a way
knight a3 takes advantage of the fact
that black just pushed this pawn because
there's a not an outpost but it takes
time for black to move the knight and
then play c6 to kick it and from b5 then
you can play the move sorry i'm drawing
errors and taking them away then you can
make the move d4 and it's all protected
from
both knights and the queen so what a
opening so far yeah and it's certainly a
slightly uncomfortable spot to find
yourself in when you're visited here
because we look at the clock the players
start with an hour 40 on the clock so
daniel duboff
after it moves he's up three minutes so
he's played every move uh instantly
yesterday in his game against kariak and
dubove actually finished with more time
on the clock than he started with
so duboff you already mentioned it most
chess fans we know is so creative um
so well prepared well prepared as well
so
always a tough spot to find yourself on
the receiving end of your opponent
playing some um
not so common moves and blitzing them
out like that
knight a3 more common here is the move
pawn to a4 for white and these positions
usually go something like a4
um i think g5 first makes sense that way
there's no sacrifices bishop g3 castles
castles king g7 they have seen this type
of position with yon duda playing
a number of times these maybe it's not
this exact position but it is similar to
this white brings the knight into d2 and
so on and playing a4 stops black from
doing it but duda uh next to not due to
do ball dude plays this position dubov
is playing in the game here and knight
a3 is the choice and i think most of our
viewers would say i was literally just
gonna ask you that
right like bishop takes a3 obviously is
the move and after pawn takes a3 we see
a compromise pawn structure here from
white's perspective now there is a bit
of good news this pawn is up on a5 which
means the b5 square is kind of white's
for the taking as it was um in some of
the other positions we're looking at and
the b file being open could be
beneficial for white and there is the
two bishops advantage so that's what i
think white is looking to really use
it's not a clear position i think that
who has really benefited it's both sides
have benefited in their own ways once a
piece goes to the b file black can play
b6 shut it all down so it's not like
you're going to actually get pressure
along the semi-open line but still
having the bishop pair is nice if you
want to break this pin and make this
move g5 that's always weakening on your
king side and white will try to make d4
happen at some point in the near future
yeah and we see a bit
deep in front it's actually
i mean the memes like i know you're not
the biggest fan of all the chat memes
robert but it's so funny to me how
witted one of vinnette's thinking
default thinking process is that the not
like this um emote and yeah um he has a
lot to figure out here i think we'll
come back to this game
uh in a little bit
and i don't know if you want to jump
elsewhere if you want to have a look at
the bird's eye view first i'll let you
choose robert
uh yeah i love the bird's eye view so we
can stay here for a second the jordan
von forest game against pragnanda that
looks like it's at the local club and
you have no idea what the player's
ratings are uh because that's not an
opening you see every day black is up a
pawn and white moved that bishop twice
we see the bishop on b5 and a black pawn
on e4 that's the top right hand side of
your screen everybody and we saw bishop
c4 on the third move so we can actually
maybe bring that game up just before we
go there robert i also wanted to point
out the game between nils gwandalius and
richard report uh in a while we can go
there as well because we see a pawn
already on g4
um so that's also an interesting game
which uh which is catching my eye from
the bird's eye view
now that's a good catch by you because i
was so focused on this pin in the top
right i didn't look the bottom right and
that's going to be a sharp battle
between two very adventurous players
niels grandilius and uh rehard report so
i think we'll start top right just
because we're only looking at it for a
second then we'll go right to grand
delia's report and of course we will get
to duda carlson don't you worry we know
that's going to be a very important game
for the standings but i just want to
bring up three moves ago
white played the move bishop c4 here
that's what jordan did e6 a principal
reply shutting down the bishop's
diagonal with this pawn chain and then
playing for d5 so castles d5 and most
players would immediately capture on d5
jordan von forrest is not most players
he says i'm going to play bishop to b5
so i'll move that same minor piece twice
and i allowed you to take control in the
center and after d takes e4 knight to e5
fiona we see the point there is a pinned
knight on c6 uh attack twice you can
ruin black's pawn structure
but what is obscure opening line and i
guess my question for you is do you like
what jordan has done do you think he's
playing tricky chess or is he just
trying to catch his young less
experienced opponent off guard and
try to take this one
i think in general
um i'm a fan of of the players going for
these more offbeat lines i think as a
jazz fan
as a chess commentator
we commentate on on so many berlins and
these positional joko pianos with
tiny nuances so i think it's always a
brush
a brush
a breath of fresh air um to see
uh to see players like jordan players
like rapport players like duboff coming
up with new ideas even as early you know
as move three and four
uh it makes our job harder of course as
commentators when we have so many new
people
watching us in the chat
and every day we've been in this spot
you know because
we will tell you and your coaches will
tell you
develop your pieces get your king into
safety control the center so it's it's
hard from that point of view to explain
what the players are doing uh but from
the fan perspective i really like seeing
these kind of offbeat openings
yeah i love it and it does make our job
harder because normally we can be like
oh well
magnus played this against
five different opponents and we can cite
all this research and just from our
prior knowledge of the game this is new
territory and it's new territory for us
it's definitely new territory for prague
but the one person it's not new
territory for is jordan von forrest he
has worked on this at home and you may
wonder why is program under thinking at
this moment a knight was captured of
course he's going to capture the knight
back
but let's wait a second let's take our
time bishop d7 is sometimes a way to
meet this night capture we will pin the
knight to the bishop he did capture back
on c6 quickly show you why bishop d7
isn't ideal knight takes a7 a wonderful
move protecting the bishop and if black
takes on a7 white will then trade
bishops and say i have evened up the
material now your pawn structure is
worse than mine and your rook is weirdly
on a7 so that was not an option for
black i'm sorry sorry robert i just have
to laugh that the bishop is back on c4
again
it went back to c4 and it's just moving
the same piece way too many times but
we'll get into why it makes sense just
after quickly this a6 knight d4 check to
me makes sense after a b5 knight b5
again now we have
material equality and black has this e4
palm that sticks out there's a knight
coming to c3 that e4 pawn will quickly
be attacked not that easy to defend so
that is why
pragmata
decided to take back on c6 which makes
perfect sense we see bishop c4 and
that's why you had a good laugh here
because that bishop went c4 b5 back to
c4 and black is up a pawn but the thing
about this position is double isolated
pawns double pawns in the center and so
white will make moves like knight c3
bring a piece of the e file like queen
to e2 and go after the pawn and if you
were going to try to save that pawn you
need to make the move f5 which is so
weakening
for example bishop d6 pawn h3 i don't
want to lose my pawn with check you play
knight to f6 let's say i play knight c3
and then queen e2 and i simply win the
pawn by force you can't defend it so if
you really want to save that pawn you
have to make a move at some point f5 but
that weakens your pawn on e6 and i will
play d3 b upon down open up the e file
and try to just you know crash through
so there's going to be risky decisions
that have to be made by pragananda in
this line and jordan is the one who's
prepared here this actually is really
dangerous for prague yeah i think
actually today both our indian
participants in the the masters group
pragnanda and vidit both being put to
the test straight out of the opening
opening by two members of team
magnus and i think both of them will
have to go deep into the tank
because this is a position where it's
not about coming up with your next move
it is about how do i want to set up long
term
do i want to to try and hold on to my
pawn on on e4 will i give it back if i
give it back what's the best way to do
so
so a very interesting battle ahead here
and we see the close-up of pregnant and
that they're deep and thoughts with the
eyes sort of darting around the board
and he's way down on the clock already
so jordan in his prep he has put
pragmata to the test here and the
youngster he'll need to come up with
something pretty quickly because only
move eight the position will remain
sharp for quite a deal of time and look
at jordan arms crossed he's feeling good
about how this opening has gone thus far
and robert actually very interesting
insight from one of my dear twitch
viewers who's in the chat shout out to
frisky frog who said and maybe we have
to double check it but he's usually
quite reliable he's saying he uh jack
leaches and apparently max swarmadam had
this position
in the blitz game max marmadam who is
jordan's second
form last year so some very interesting
insights there
does that make max magnus's grand second
like you know
if he's the second to magnus's second is
that a grand second how does that work
in chess i'm just gonna take us back to
the bird's eye view and pretend i never
said that because asking questions that
nobody wants the answer to
so back the words right here
back to the bird's eye view
and what's going on in the carlson game
i think they are going down a path that
both of them are quite familiar with we
will get to that in a second do you want
to start with that should we have a
quick look at glendale is first which
way do you want to go
i did say we'd go to the grendelius game
so why don't we go there i made a
promise i'd like to keep it it does look
like a very interesting battle yes a
panko decided to strike in the center
with d4 so that might heat up at some
point but let's go to nils and uh rehard
here because that's a sicilian that
promises to be a good game and we are on
move eight and report is thinking so the
last move play let's go let me just go
through from the beginning
see how we got here in the sicilian uh
d4
the knight came to c6 knight c3 and
queen c7 so this move is very popular
uh from black's perspective it's quite
flexible
oftentimes we think of the ceiling we
need to play a6 but a knight coming to
b5 will be kicked by a6 in the near
future so it's not too big of a concern
a g4 played by niels and what can we say
fiona everybody is inspired by chakra
mama jarv right
absolutely
maybe alpha zero and
those those guys had a thing or two
with it uh as well we know we see that
players in general in the last few years
have been taking a lot more liberties
with their g pawns with their h-pawns
um
and yeah here
g4 well immediately neil's wanting to
play
on the king side maybe robert maybe you
can try and explain what's the idea
behind a move like g4 which right now it
doesn't attack anything it doesn't seem
to be doing uh to have any concrete
threads so maybe you can explain what
are the ideas
yeah g4 looks like a bad move but it's
not it just looks that way because what
in the world is it doing you're throwing
your pawn up there um just to show
everybody what's more typical bishop e3
or bishop to e2
played tens and tens of thousands of
times it's a very common uh position
here but instead the move g4 is played
and that does prevent knight f6 because
if you played knight f6 i quickly played
g5 and guess what your knight is going
what i assume back to g8 but i guess not
maybe there's some kind of knight takes
d4 that allows the knight to go forward
i i thought g5 i mean that looks
reasonable to me maybe knight b5 first
makes more sense and then we can play a
move like g5 that way there's no nitrate
because the point is the queen covers
these squares so that knight is not
exactly happy on f6 because it has to
drop back to g8 so that's the correct
move order but the point still stands
the g5
forces the knight back and that is the
issue for black so instead of playing
knight f6
h6 was played that way black can go
knight f6 but we call this pawn a hook
and it's a hook because when white tries
to play g5 it will open up lines because
it attacks a pawn so in the game we said
bishop e3
and f6 and f3 and if black dares to
castle kingside g5 will happen and lines
are opening up whether black likes it or
not so fiona i really like the direction
this game is going uh it's going to be
difficult for black to decide what to do
with the king because there's that pawn
h6 so you played h6 to allow the night
out but then you kind of regret playing
it because you can't really cast a king
side with ease yeah i think it's always
an interesting question in these
positions where we see early
kingside
pushes
of where does the king go you're talking
about the black king do you think the
white king will go queenside
i think that yes the white king is gonna
queen d2 castle queen side adventure
over there and at some point black has
to make the move a6 because you don't
want to allow knight b5 when you're not
looking carefully because that's going
to be a big problem uh hitting the queen
and the dark squares we see that this
pawn structure d7
e6 f7 that leaves the dark squares
vulnerable because pawns right they
capture it diagonally and they
protect the same color that they're on
so the d6 square could be a problem for
black to deal with and that's why a6 is
the way to play and maybe even b5 to
follow up so
i just find these positions a bit easier
to play from white's point of view the
ideas
register a little more clearly to me
that said rapport is such an experienced
player and he loves tactical battles but
i do prefer niels position at this early
stage yeah certainly an exciting battle
ahead here between two very creative
players we see richard has just made
another move so a6 trying to stop any
knights coming
to b5 which makes a lot of sense
robert i suggest we take our first quick
break of the day and when we come back
we'll look at the magnus carson uh
versus duda well do that versus magnus
carlsen clash so don't go anywhere and
we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
fantastic
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the third round of the
status deal
chess tournament and robert we're back
with
the bird's eye view maybe a quick
overlook before we finally dive into
this uh dudak carlson game
yeah honestly we have some great starts
to the games here we saw dubois against
vidit that knight a3 move which seemed
to be a novelty and was captured by
vidit we have a berlin end game between
caruana and shankland von forest has
surprised us all by moving his bishop
three times in the early stages and look
at that he didn't even play h3 he put
his king on h1
giving up the h2 pawn to try to trap the
bishop but what a game so far between
those two players von forest and
pragananda i mean we haven't even looked
at giri mamanjaro but that looks like
it's shaping up for a fun one as well
and then yesapanko against cardiac and
the countryman
d4 has been played but no reaction
really by karjakin seems like a solid
affair in that one and we'd like the
sicilian between grandillus and reports
so i think
fiona were in store for a great day
we've already had five decisive games in
the first 14
match ups and the two rounds so i think
we'll have more today too yeah and
actually although i know you don't like
predictions for it so i'm not gonna
torture you on every game but i like our
little prediction of how many decisive
games which is a quick and painless one
yesterday i was way off the mark i
predicted for you predicted three close
but no cigar how many today
oh great question i'm looking at the
games i will go with
i think two
i think we'll get two okay i want to
i'll do you again so i'll go with with
three
okay it's funny because i was going to
say three initially and then i was like
if i say three fiona won't say three so
i hear let me reserve that number so
considerate robbery
[Laughter]
uh well i do think that we have um the
types of games that are likely to end
decisively so i just very combative
spirits for the players at least in the
early move so let's uh go to the game
between duda and carlson we promised
everybody the world chess
[ __ ] with the black pieces against the
world cup champion with the white pieces
we have to remember that duda knocked
out carlson from the world cup that was
pretty uh amazing a grand achievement
from the polish number one and in this
game fiona i don't know if you want to
should we go back to the start you think
or should we i think it might be
interesting uh especially since you were
one of the main commentators at the
for the world championship match between
nepomniashi and carlson maybe you can
tell us a little bit about the
similarities and maybe we can find where
did we deviated if at all
okay well we had e4 e5 throughout the
match between nepo and carlson um
janupamishi he chose e4 a bunch and
magnus did not play the sicilian he did
in 2018 against five on a caruana so we
had a spanish and knight f6 castles all
of this is mainline stuff bishop e7
rookie one and this b5 rook b8 business
that happens here uh the rook needs to
slide off the a file because with the
rook on a1 a takes b5 was a huge threat
just to turn a go you give white a free
move you lose a pawn now in this
position black can choose bishop to b7
or b4 both of which are more popular
than the rook b8 move but now in my head
i think i have recency bias like rook
beat is the move even though these other
two moves are more popular it's kind of
funny how that works fiona where like
magnus plays something so we just kind
of assume that's what should be done
even if other moves have been played for
a long long time and i really think
theory is also so heavily influenced by
world championship
matches so i think there is the recent
element you mentioned and then
these moves that are played by the top
players in the world backed by top
computer and
analyzers backed by top teams and they
pick up in fashion uh so quickly and get
rapidly replicated uh a lot in no time
exactly so i mean in the early game of
the match between um yan and magnus at
this point in time
a4 was not played in fact h3 was the
choice and then magnus made this move
knight to a5 so it was a very
interesting try it got a bit sharp but
magnus was able to
actually quite easily make a draw it
seemed after a little while so in this
game and as jan switched to in the match
a4 is the choice now as we mentioned a4
attacks the b5 pawn and
magnus decides on rook to b8 getting his
rook off of the open or the opening a
file so this move
um it does make sense uh one of the
times magnus
played bishop d7 as well so
he he chooses what he wants to do on a
given day he is kind of unpredictable
maybe that's the jordan von forrest
influence right
yeah absolutely and we're reminded it
reminds me always of that
video that was published after the match
of magnus's team of seconds i believe
they had a camp in spain or somewhere
before
before the match where magnus himself
introduces every member
of the team you know peter heiner
nielsen is the adult in the room
and then jan he's the marshall guy i
look up the video i don't want to
get things wrong but then jordan was
introduced as the new guy where they
still would have to to check if his
ideas were actually any good
i i think they are quite good but yeah
that video is really funny i like the
team spirit involves clear chemistry
between the various seconds and well h3
d6 the seconds for max carlson should
not be surprised to see this anymore it
was played in the world chess
championship and after c3
uh b4 we're still following game five
from the world championship d3 pawns
takes c3 takes and here h6 that is uh
different from what magnus did in game
five he chose to move pawn to d5 and
pawn d5 loosens your protection of the
e5 pawn because you have this chain here
and that makes this pawn safe and sound
so i played d5 you're striking in the
center trying to open the board up a bit
uh but it is a logical move though he
got himself in some trouble in that game
where in this uh position here his
bishop was kind of awkward on d6 and
later there was a moment where jan could
have pressed forward by trying to push
his pawn up the board so it's a bit
passive from black's perspective so here
in this game today we saw h6 a sort of
waiting move bishop e3 developing rook
e8
knight d2 and bishop f8 so i would say
that this maneuver fiona of rookie
bishop f8 is probably kind of
awkward to
many in the audience what are you are
you really improving your pieces like
your bishop's going back to its starting
square but this is such a common spanish
decision to put the bishop on at fate
and try to go g6
so do you think uh now that we've seen
this maneuver it means black is straying
from the plan of going for d5 he's not
gonna be looking to strike in the center
anymore but rather bring the bishop to
g7
yeah i think he's just going to refrain
from doing that he knows that's the type
of game that duda wants he can play
bishop e6 at some point to trade off
those
light square bishops and what's
happening here
is that white has a bit more mobility in
terms of the pawn pushes we talked about
d5 but when you make this move d5 you
hurt your own pawn structure as black
whereas the move d4 simply improves
white's position
as long as you make sure that your e4
pawn is defended so uh black sits a
little bit more passively but it's
nothing really to speak up to complain
about uh white is going to attempt d4
and black has to be comfortable with a
more cramped position and we know that
magnus has said during the world
championship in those interviews he's
like yeah it's a little bit worse for
black you just have to be okay with that
and it seems like he is and you talk
about
white wanting to to probably push d4 in
the center how soon maybe this is an
interesting question when do we know as
white
that we are ready for that push denied
from d2 for example do we want that to
stay there do we want to maneuver it
elsewhere maybe via f1 and g3 when do we
know we're ready for the d4 push
such a good question that i honestly
don't have a complete answer to but i
will try my best
a large part of it is the e4 pawn and
here there's a rook on e8 and a knight
on f6 so you have to be very careful
which is why i'd probably lead with the
move queen to c2 just to make sure that
my pawn is defended so when i do push d4
i don't have to worry about dropping a
pawn that said
i don't think you can actually capture
on e4 if you play d4 right away because
after pawn takes pawn takes this is very
common knight e4
takes rookie four you see the evaluation
bar go up because bishop d5
is a move with a dual threat hitting
your rook and your knight and you can't
defend both white simply scoops up
material so it is possible to play d4
but the downside of playing d4 is that
it is
committal and we know chess players
they're they worry about commitment um
but uh i mean and i mean that is
anything you want to to talk about
no no i i don't think we need to dive
too deep into this conversation
but from a chess perspective not from a
life perspective
uh the issue is that now there's this
permanent tension and while we like to
maintain the tension in chess very often
that leaves black with the opportunity
at some point to take on d4 and even
taking immediately on d4 without
following up with knight takes e4
because that's a bad move but the fact
that you then have to go and protect
this pawn is going to be annoying for
example if black plays knight to b4 now
i am threatening to take your pawn on e4
because there's no bishop d5 funny
business let's remind everybody quickly
that
94 wasn't possible because bishop d5
forked the two pieces
and with the knight on b4 there's no
knight to attack and the d5 square is
covered so in this variation after
knight b4 this is why chess players are
afraid of commitment because how do you
defend this e4 pawn there's no queen c2
you'd lose your queen and if you play
move like queen b1 you're walking into
another pin that doesn't look very
comfortable and
this is what i mean by
you know trying to wait until the right
moment
well we'll see i'm sure do that
he seems like a man who handles his
commitments well
we'll come back to this one and maybe go
back to the maybe you can go back to the
bird's eye view for a second i saw a
comment
in the chat that with it we see the
position we can't see the clock times
but apparently with it already under an
hour clearly caught by surprise by
duboff
yeah i mean great choice by duboff even
if it's not so much of an objective
advantage it is a practical one because
players fear duvall's preparation they
know how creative he is they know how
sharp the lines that he produces are and
when magnus carlsen puts his full trust
in you to work with him and come up with
catalan lines including yesterday's game
we don't know
with a hundred percent certainty that
that was a duboff concoction but magnus
he was like that may have been leftover
preparation and that's why he played so
quickly for the first dozen or so moves
and yeah i think vidit you know he
should be nervous he's not in the not
like this pose anymore so is that a good
thing or a bad thing if you're reading
this expression
well it's a bad a bad thing for chad for
sure
less meaning
and he does look a little less concerned
to me but
who knows what that means we see him
there just dropping the knight back we
can go to that in a second but i think
there's two games robert if i'm not
mistaken that we haven't looked at
in-depth yet that's kirima medyarov and
yasi panko karjakin
yeah we're never gonna look at those
games i know people are gonna be very
upset with us but we refuse
uh we are boycotting those games now we
can of course go to um those games why
don't we start with i'm not sure which
one would you wanna let's start with
giri mamedyarov giri is the local hero
after all i think it's always
interesting to see how do these players
bounce back after a loss
of course a tough game we've talked
about it plenty
so unleashed today with the white pieces
and especially interesting uh with
sharia you know having played the way
he's played the last two days you never
know
uh what to expect and the position
certainly looks interesting at first
sight
yeah the black king is still in the
center which means there may be some
hope for g5 no not actually it's just a
joke because mama jar played g4 on move
three yesterday i don't really like his
position right now uh we can go back and
see how we got here but if we just take
stock of the current situation black
often is trying to play the move c5 and
if you can make c5 work without any sort
of
issue without it backfiring then you
often have a decent position
but something about this position as it
currently sits
it feels a little awkward to me and when
black tries to castle kingside you have
to watch out for the move e5 which opens
up this bishop to the h7 pawn so if
you're not careful white can launch a
very quick attack so c5 is the move you
want i think that it may be in the cards
for black
though if you do it before you castle so
let's say i go just
kind of a throwaway move queen e2 c5 and
try tape with this knight you do have to
be really careful because your king is
still in the center so when i play this
bishop b5 check uh your king now
probably has to go to f8 because if you
block with bishop to c6 there it is yeah
i was waiting for that to happen takes
and queen to
uh b5 is devastating now your rook is
pinned in comes the knight to e5 and you
are losing material so you need c5 to
fully equalize in many of these
positions but you can't rush that move
yeah and i think once again we just see
the importance if you're watching this
uh
in a lot of games the principles are
being kicked a little bit we see a lot
of games we've seen a lot of games that
are hard to understand but i think this
is a great example of why it is so
important in general
to get your king into safety
as soon as possible and robert maybe can
we go back to the start here because
we had a semi-slab another opening i'm
not too familiar with but i was thinking
uh didn't uh sapiko who we are greeting
if she's watching us uh didn't stop
because she created some content on
this lab here
see this is dangerous territory because
now we have to ask the question does
anish listen to his wife's chest advice
so
i don't know if you want to take that
one or if we should just pass on that
yeah it may be better better to pass on
it
um but i believe you are correct and um
you know these kind of lines they're
they're so fascinating and uh you know
first of all hi sopiko uh you know
we want to say hi i'm i'm sure she is
following anisha's game whether she's
watching a live commentary you're
probably better off not watching i get
it uh but uh would definitely hi to
sophie i hope you're doing well and you
know these these lines are fascinating
because you look at the initial setup we
have the pawn triangle here uh for black
which means that you're super solid and
defended but your bishop on c8 isn't
very happy and your pawns block your
pieces the knight of course can't go to
c6 there's a pawn there so white plays
bishop d3 and castles very quickly and
only after
a few turns in black decided to take on
c4 and then lash out with b5 because
your bishop has no future on this
diagonal here you can't make the move e5
white has that covered so you play b5
and bishop b7
which looks kind of funky as you move
your b pawn all at the board you have a
backwards c pawn but you are playing for
this move c5
and the question is so after e4 and rook
c8 we've already talked about the
dangers of um
of keeping the king
in the center so my question is how does
white fight now that he still has a
little bit of time while the king is on
eight how do we fight as white against
the c5 push
i really like the starting mcqueen e2
and i played it kind of on a whim but
now that i realize it works out
that move looks quite nice because the
bishop on d3 is perfectly placed aiming
towards the black king side so if you
play queen e2 and black's like i'm
getting that king out of the center
immediately
then i believe e5
hitting the knight knight goes to d5
that's the downside of playing e5 as you
hand that knight a nice central square
and i'm looking for ways to go after
this king and if this bishop were not
here i might already have the bishop
takes h7 check knight g5 and going for
like a checkmating attack immediately so
queen e4
naturally threatens checkmate black can
stop it with g6 maybe it's not the best
that white can do in this position but
at least your bishop gets in you have
your pieces staring at black's king
another option because i just said i
want the g5 square i'm wondering like i
can make a move like knight c5 and hope
that you take it twice with your bishop
i doubt you will but essentially i'm
hoping that you
go like this and there it is right the
evaluation goes up
here
and knight g5 check very straightforward
a brute force method of going for a
checkmate your king is
well it's done
and the famous i believe the greek gift
tactic which is very um useful to
uh to be familiar with for your own
games if you haven't seen this kind of
motive before look it up uh it happens
quite often uh in your games and always
something that that black has to look be
on the lookout for
and yeah actually it's funny because
knight c5 was just a move to distract
you but now that i'm looking at it it
might just be a good idea for white like
your fisherman b7 is terrible because
you can't play c5 we just said and
showed why you can't take on c5 with
your bishop and so what do you actually
do here um
yeah i mean i i really it's funny that
you you showed this move quite randomly
to to demonstrate the dangers in black's
position and suddenly we turns out well
this might actually be a very very good
move also look at the power of that
white bishop here with the bishop
looking down
at h7 the other bishop ready to join the
action
any move like h6 would always be very
dangerous we could even imagine some
potential sacrifices
um yeah with that you talked about it
earlier h6 is a hook here it's uh
looking quite precarious
for uh for black so yeah not so clear
how does black proceed and i love that
you highlighted this bishop on b7 which
is currently completely dead
if i were black of course i would like
to to put some pressure on on c5
try and get to that pawn somehow i don't
know if
queen
[Music]
a5 is an option or if i'm already in
trouble on the on the king side yeah
it's one of those things where you know
you need to get that pawn but if you
move your queen away from the king's uh
safety your danger levels are very high
that i
i don't know i feel like this move is
risking a ton but i don't see an
immediate knockout i i you know i see
the eval bar saying white's doing great
it's one thing to know that white's
better it's nothing to prove it so i
think that queen a5
it's not easy to refute
yeah not easy to refute but at the same
time not really a move i want to make to
remove
the most powerful piece uh from
contributing to the defense of the the
king side so yeah i think there's still
some questions here for mamedyarov
to answer and i'm curious to see if
anish
goes for for queenie two or what he's
going to go for
it's all about figuring out the
assessment of those positions we're just
looking at right now because
look at her knees what do you think this
pose it looks like he's not even really
looking at the chessboard but rather
it looks like he's completely in his own
mind and very often this is a sign that
players are trying
to remember things and going deep into
the the memory fault
yeah i think he's trying to calculate
deeply and you know he's we closed his
eyes because he sees the board in his
head he can visualize it and he's
looking for all sorts of tactical
sequences because he probably feels that
his position should be
at least slightly better right now but
as we've been discussing as soon as
black plays c5 safely not with the king
in the center then black's problems are
a thing of the past and he's trying to
figure out okay at this moment i know
it's the time to maximize the potential
my position how do i do that i do like
to move queen to e2 i was kind of
throwing moves at random and they just
so happen to work out but anish doesn't
have that luxury because when our moves
don't work out we just take them back
and find something better if his moves
don't work out well then his advantage
is gone and now he's kind of wasted the
first move advantage
well we'll see what he comes up with we
will leave these guys for now shakira
once again looking very relaxed there um
but let's go to to the russian clash
between sergey koryakin um
and
i always get the colors wrong somehow
between ese panko and karjakin
which is the last game we haven't seen
and it's another italian game so a
couple of them today
yeah the position right now not
super duper exciting but we can see how
we got here it was an italian as you
pointed out and c3 d3 looks like the
game between do above and vivid and
instead of bishop g5 which was the rarer
choice that dubois went with we see than
the typical castle and h6 played so that
no piece can get to g5 and one of the
mistakes that players can make is well
my opponent played h6 taking away g5 i'm
gonna play h3 taking away g4 and there's
one really important thing here is that
black has not castled and i'm not
suggesting that right now it's
necessarily the move that g5 that should
be played but there are positions like
this where black plays g5 g4 uses this
pawn as a hook and then just crushes
white and in fact uh vladimir krumnick
did something to that effect against
levon aronian in the 20 2018 candidates
yeah i think it was the 2018 kansas
where he like put his rook on g8 played
g5 and just immediately went for an
attack and won an extremely nice game so
don't just play h3 with your hand you
need to think before you make certain
moves instead in this game we saw rookie
one
castles and then h3 timing is everything
you need to make sure that your
opponent's not going to benefit from
your move and that's why
yeah andre played it now
a6 a4 no b5 for you and then a5 that's a
funny move fiona right a6
and then a5 how do we explain that
decision by karjakin like so many other
moves we really we struggle to explain i
think in general
i find that the italian game there has
been so many
developments
lately
that i've i'm really struggling to to
keep
up
and and remember the different because
the italian game is something that i've
played with both colors mostly from the
black side um but obviously my opening
preparation was nowhere near that of
those players and with theory moving so
fast i think that these days the italian
opening is so so so complex there is so
many tiny nuances when
do you put the pawn to a6 when do you
put it to a5
when do you go d5 when do you not when
do you bring the bishop back from c5 to
a7 and the same from the white side so
um
i always struggle to to understand and
also how much of it is prep how much do
the players come with come up with over
the world i guess in this particular
case here i guess a5
uh is to stop b4 robert
yeah but it's just so weird because you
could have played a5 immediately yeah to
stop b4 so there must be something about
inducing the move a4 which is why
karjakin
played a slow a5
so yeah let's let's continue from where
we see that jesse panko now decides to
strike in the center with
d4 the bishop is dropped back
and
the white does the same very often that
bishop we're going to see it on the next
move doesn't stay on this diagonal but
rather reroutes to c2 to support the
center
yeah i tend to like these positions at
least slightly from the white side which
is kind of funny because i always have
them from the black side
where white has more space the e4 pawn
is well defended e5 similarly is well
defended but it just feels like white
has a bit more flexibility this knight
on b1 goes to d2 where it can either go
to c4 or to f1 now in this particular
position you need to be careful about
your d4 pawn hanging because there are
one two three pieces attacking and if
you move the knight to d2 you block one
of your defenders so knight a3 to c4
becomes an option you can lead with
bishop to e3 because bishop e3
protects d4 but then you have to watch
out did i blunder my e4 pawn after e
takes d4
can i take back with anything but the
bishop i'm not sure you can because
after c takes d4 here not only can you
consider knight e4 but this knight b4
move again is really annoying where you
attack this bishop and really just try
to go straight for this e4 pawn so we
love playing d4 in the italian but we
when we commit to it we have to note our
e4 pawn becomes vulnerable and this is a
clear example of that absolutely a very
maneuvering game here between
the two russian players which is yet to
spring to life we'll come back here and
to all the other games of round three
after a short break during which our
producer bigfoot is going to check in
with the challengers and show some
highlights from yesterday so
you don't want to miss that and we will
see you in just a few
[Music]
yes welcome everybody this is the
checkup with the challengers every day
we're gonna look in in the challenger
section see if there are some
interesting games ongoing because we all
know that the winner of the challenger
section will be competing in the master
section the year after so every day
we're gonna have a quick look and today
we have aryan aragaski versus max
varbardon they both have half a point in
their first match this is the second
round we're going to see what they did
they actually have an interesting
position this is still theory
after knight to d7 you might think that
after the move a5 right here this knight
is kind of a bit trapped there's no way
to go to a4 c4 d5 or go back so this
looked like a fantastic move and we had
to move bishop to a6
hitting that rook getting this rook to
c8 hitting this bishop of the bishop the
queen on c2 and being very much of a
nuisance this is still theory and after
taking on b6
rook the c8 the theory is actually you
go queen to d1 because after queen of d1
is actually a very interesting position
a very interesting variation we're going
to have a look at really one
we're going to take on f1 we're going to
throw in it quick to b7
pawn to b7 hitting that rook making sure
that this pawn is a little bit of a
nuisance
rook to c7
and after we take this bishop back we
actually have a very enticing
this is really cool
bishop takes on c2 now you cannot take
here with the queen
because then you will lose this bishop
and black is actually up material
so you have to take with the king and
now
the the killer move right here
knight to e5
it doesn't look like we're doing
anything it looks like we're you know
being being chill putting up a knight in
the in the center so what does it
threaten after let's say a weird move
let's say h3 we take here on c1 queen
takes
and bada bing bada boom your queen is
mine with a nice fork there so there's
actually only one move
that we have right here it's going back
to your little cave king to g1 and after
a trade on c1
knight to
d3 this queen is looking at d4 these
pieces aren't developed at all this
one's stuck behind their own
pieces
and after
let's say we get a queen
between the d4 check
king the h1
knight to f2 and we have
a
repetition we can also go in from time
to time you can go to h3 doesn't really
matter i'm following the engine line
right now but this
is
a repetition so this is the way black
will go on there have been games i've
been going this way but
max was thinking he was thinking and
ultimately he decided to play the move
rook takes h6
he actually spent an hour on this move
obviously he saw this threat he was
calculating about it he has very deep
thoughts
but after bishop takes f2
we'll just go for the game
king takes c2 rook takes c2
you lose your queen on c2 but you get a
very nice pass bomb this is what he was
calculating but after knight b6 the move
that he probably missed
is after uh queen c8 rook takes b6
queen c5 check
and we are winning that rook back and
unfortunately max had to resign not a
few moves later because this pawn also
fell and these moves aren't
uh developed yet so
very nice gamer arin he knew his theory
max spent an hour on that move rook
takes a6 but unfortunately it wasn't the
case uh didn't plan on that he actually
tweeted about it he says sometimes the
brain doesn't function or the head
doesn't function i don't know someone
didn't function
about him today but we hope he pounces
back he's a dutch player i'm a dutch guy
so you gotta root for your own country
but aryan with a point and a half out of
two he joins the leaders if i'm correct
and we'll be back soon tomorrow to see
which challenger
we're gonna check in
[Music]
you so much our producer big for the
insights into the challenges group and
and max warmer than indeed with a day
off yesterday but um
hopefully he will bounce back and robert
we are going to focus of course on our
master's group and we can just bring
back uh the bird's eye view which uh we
both love so much and gives us a good
overview of um
what's happening throughout the playing
hall
yeah it's fantastic we get to see from
board to board i mean the dubov game it
looks like a pawn has been gambling in
the center i see vida just what knight
takes e4 so we'll definitely have to
dive into that but before we do i see
gary played with a3 so he played on the
flank rather than in the center we were
talking about queen e2 instead he
chooses a3 a fascinating decision by him
uh fiona the game between kneels and
report we promised that it would be
exciting it's sicilian but they're just
not moving
which is not such a bad thing because it
means we are more likely to get more
action as the hours um
go by so
for now
where do you want to start robert
such a difficult question answer look at
von forrest against prognonda it's a new
pawn that jordan is down he has no f
pawn but he's trying to go for some kind
of attack
let us go
uh which one do we choose fiona should
we
should we go to the video game maybe i
think that yeah i was that was gonna be
my pick so i'm glad i'm glad we agree
um let's start with duboff um with it
and then we can maybe go to jordan which
i really also looking very interesting
so shall we go back a few moves and
first things first let's look at the
clock situation fitted almost down an
hour already on the clock
yeah he has been caught by surprise but
he is such a strong player that of
course he can figure things out over the
board it was this decision first by
dubov to play bishop g5 a rare choice
vidit follows it up with h6 and doesn't
play g5 plays in the other wing and then
knight a3 so that it takes his time he
captures doubles and isolates white's
pawns and then fiona we see this move
knight b8 by vidit he does not like the
look of this pin and he says i'm going
to reroute my knight to d7 via b8 we see
this in some spanish positions what do
you make of this choice by did it facing
preparation over the board and then
choosing this move knight b8
i mean it's
surprising to me and it's even more
surprising because after the whole
maneuver of um defending the knight on
f6 with the other knight he then chooses
to go g5 which
uh i'm a bit confused as to why didn't
he go g5 why did he want to first bring
the knight to d7
uh rather than going g5 immediately
i guess dubois provoked him he said i
just have to when he when duba went d4
here that
loosens up the e4 pawn and we've talked
about in several games today but e4 pawn
is under attack can't be captured with
that knight being pinned and for some
reason g5 not the move that he wants to
play and there might be a sacrifice on
g5 or just the simple bishop g3 and now
the e5 pawn is under attack so by
putting the knight on d7 he's protecting
the 996 but also protecting that e5 pawn
in the event that the bishop retreats to
g3 and that's what we're seeing in the
game knight d7
rook b1
which honestly fiona invites knight
takes e4 even more because now there's a
fork on c3 in addition to attacking the
bishop on g3
i mean duboff he really loves giving up
material
um and he really as you said has
invited actively invited with it into
playing all these moves going g5 taking
the pawn on e4 and i'm curious now to
see uh what is his follow-up because i i
think you have to do something about
that pawn on c3 not that you can't
afford to to lose another pawn which
very often dubrov is not afraid of but
here there is of course a big fork
threatened
i think what's going to happen is this
the f file is going to open up so queen
c2 attacks the knight and defends the c3
pawn and if vidit takes on g3
f takes g3 is played you don't like the
look of this bishop this rook staring at
the f7 pawn sacrifices are going to be
everywhere you can't castle because
queen g6
check pawn is pinned win h6 with check
win g5 win the game it's just a forcing
sequence that leads to checkmate so
this is really dangerous stuff here for
vidit and we see that the evaluation bar
is still hovering around the middle
which honestly is not a great sign for
black because it while that indicates
you can find accurate choices that
holds everything together
you don't have much time and you're
playing someone who is ambitious who
loves sacrificing material and just
looks so much scarier for black that
pawn
to me
it's not irrelevant but i would much
rather have the attack
let me ask you a question about a move
which i think is going to to hurt
your soul it hurts mine as well but
how bad is uh f5 trying to hold on
to that knight in the center but of
course i'm aware that i'm opening up my
own king even further
the brave choice so i commend you for
suggesting it because that's the best
thing that commentators can do suggest
moves even when it hurts them because
that's the thought process we have to go
through if we eliminate all moves that
look bad we'll often overlook the right
choice and f5 it's really not out of the
question it protects the knight on e4
which can't be kicked by a pawn and you
eliminate your right to castle kingside
but you probably didn't want to go there
anyway so i'm i'm honestly getting
behind this move a little bit more
though i think white can just take on e5
and if the pawn takes back i'm already
looking at just a simple rookie one type
of move waiting for your knight to move
or to sacrifice my rook for your knight
just to open up the board later the move
rook b5 can even be played going after
this e5 pawn and this knight on d7 can't
move
because there are two pieces attacking
e5 i think it's a really dangerous
scenario here for vivid
king stuck in the center absolutely and
i i seen that chad poga is asking so is
castle queenside the only way for black
or would it be better walking into a
fortress i think it's a great question i
was thinking
i mean even on the even if i could
cancel queenside which i'm still quite
far
removed from it doesn't look that like
the king would be very safe on on c8
either because
um remember
out in the opening that it took the
knight on a3 which opened the b file for
white so
i wouldn't feel safe with the king on c8
with the white queen being able to come
into b3 to a4
um so
yeah queen side so
that's the reason actually i think it's
a great question because that's the
reason why i'm worried for vidit because
i am wondering what is he gonna do with
his king especially now that lines are
going to open uh in the center
and taking that question and putting it
on the board i mean knight b6 seems like
a good starting point because you're
defending f7 by putting pressure on one
of white's pieces if rook takes b6 works
then black is just
in
such a difficult situation
i don't think it quite works just
because your attack isn't blistering
down the f-file and rook takes b6 pawn
takes b6 and you're a little slow to get
to the f7 pawn you can't sacrifice all
your pieces then you have nothing to
checkmate with although that the evolve
bar is like a yo-yo it's going up and
down trying to figure things out and if
you you know you don't sacrifice
material and you try to continue playing
for the initial maybe in bishop b5 check
because the pawn can't push the knight
would be loose there i still prefer
white's position but as the question
asks and indicates if that king can get
to c8 black will be feeling at least
quite a bit better about his chances
yes so we'll see if uh vidit aims for
that for now it is
daniel to play we see him there at the
board one of the we haven't seen him
yesterday we didn't see him thinking at
all i think he more or less made the
draw out of his uh preparation
but today i think uh daniel will be more
excited yesterday it was just
uh sort of for another first ride of the
opening but quite an uneventful game the
game against jacques if anything was too
eventful maybe his sacrifices there
weren't quite as sound
but today i think daniel
for the first time can be quite happy
with what he got out of the opening
i definitely agree with you i look at
this position i look at the time it's
his style to play like this and he is
thinking and that's a good thing to do
at this moment because i'm just saying
queen c2 it attacks the knight it
protects the pawn avoids the fork but
maybe there is a better move that makes
black's life more difficult you don't
want to take
rookie one out of the question i don't
love that move because i liked my rook
on the f file awaiting knight takes g3 f
takes g3 but rookie one could give up an
exchange to break open the center and go
for the king if these types of moves do
exist they are possible and
i wouldn't be totally surprised if a
move like that were indeed good but it's
many options here i think we'll see
duval go
quite a long time before moving and he's
already spent
some time considering his options and
it's going to be a wild game as this one
continues to heat up
very considerate of duboff to take some
time giving us the opportunity to return
to the bird's eye view and see what
updates we've had
i am particularly curious about this
event for race game against pragnanda
which has changed a lot and we see a
very funny pawn center
for black with the doubled isolated
pawns on the c and e files so maybe
we'll go
there next but what else is catching ui
robert
well now that you mentioned i can't look
at anything except for those double
isolated pawns and two sets of them c6
c5 e6 e5 that bishop on d6 is terrible
oh gosh of course it's not a winning
position for jordan but when you think
about the opening he played this is the
type of scenario he wanted where
i mean
oh gosh my stomach hurts
yeah it feels like if we have this pawn
center we would like in return to be up
more than just
one pawn because in the long run i think
at the very least jordan is always going
to be able to pick up one of these pawns
because i think they're just simply
too weak but i don't think that's
probably what's on jordan's mind right
now i think he'll probably be looking
for more
that pawn structure really is something
and
is there a name for this pawn structure
i hope not because peop that means
people are getting it right like if
there's a name for it it means it
happens regularly i feel like there
should be a name like the same way i
don't know i feel like the bathtub
construction that's quite a recent one
right you don't read about the bathtub
in the history books
you don't uh but the bathtub that's cozy
i like that formation it's a bit of a
phalanx there here
how could anybody like this look at
those pawns
i'm trying to come up with a name while
i'm talking it's difficult to think
about
you know these
parallel pawns that are
doubled and isolated and
i don't know
yeah it's really
it's a tough one i see that sam sam
copeland is in the chat with us he's
suggesting the space invader's pawn
structure
yeah it's
it's it's bad
it's not good however the position isn't
that bad for black even if the pawn
structure is not pleasant to look at and
the reason why is it's not easy to
win any of those pawns and with those
pawns sitting where they are they block
some of white's pieces particularly
along the e file you play rookie one
you're not actually threatening this
pawn the bishop covers it and black will
play the move knight to d5
if you
keep your queen on f3 and even if you
don't keep your queen on f3 knight d5
looks like a very reasonable choice so
really it pains me this position i'm
gonna continue to be honest with people
but it's objectively not that terrible
for black even if practically it's
incredibly uncomfortable and white is
objectively slightly better
and i like the gold posts uh pons oh
that's good that's a good one and
someone was asking is it not the irish
porn center no the irish the irish ponds
uh they are also painful to look at
that's when we have triple isolated
ponds i believe that's the the irish
pond center
but this one we'll we'll go with the
goal pose for now
um and we see
jordan there thinking jordan who i'm
sure will be very eager after
yesterday's last two bounce back with
the white pieces against the bottom seat
of the tournament but pragnanda he's had
a great
start to his event
he has he's been very tough he's shown
good
kind of
metal at the board he's just been calm
and able to even in some slightly
uncomfortable positions deal with the
pressure i think if i were jordan as i
try to actually consider moves rather
than the structure i'd probably move my
queen off the f file i'm not sure it's
entirely necessary but i don't see the
harm just like retreating my queen to e2
this knight d5 move i know is going to
happen anyway and i'll just move my
knight to e4 so i'm not afraid of knight
to d5 because i love the e4 square
knights should be in front of isolated
pawns and in particular in front of
double isolated pawns and something
that's really important that even if it
undoubles pawns i don't know if i would
take on f4 because you don't have to but
something like this is still going to be
pleasant for white because you have this
knight on e4 and it's a dark square
bishop so you have an outpost and that
knight can never be attacked
i would prefer to have that trade a
bishop for night if i didn't undouble
those pawns there uh so you know maybe
start with just a queen g4 or something
a little
calmer but the point remains that a
knight on e4 is just a really beautiful
piece absolutely and
um well one thing with it and the prank
having come today both of them are uh
getting very low on time but if we
switch the camera up again i don't know
if prague is still there another thing
they had in common is and they were both
sort of dancing behind the board
although now prague is standing still
but just a second ago we could see him
like fitted a few days ago against sam
shankland if you haven't seen it uh head
to the jazz.com i think it's on the
clips youtube and the the two players
bobbing away and prague is back
back in movement waiting for yuri to
make his next move
and jurgen actually decides to take on
f6
wow um if i am
prague i'm taking back with the pawn
because i don't like this poncho i don't
know if you know this fiona but i don't
like this pawn structure oh i i hadn't i
hadn't quite understood that i don't
think you made that clear enough robert
i i think g takes f6 even if it exposes
the king a little bit it makes perfect
sense because the rook defends the pawn
you can bring your bishop back to e7 if
it needs another defender white will
maintain an increased pressure uh but at
the very least it gives black some hope
because rook takes f6 it's one of these
moves you play it and you're like i'm
going to have a miserable defensive task
you just bring the queen back you put
the knight on e4 you can trade rooks and
the knight is obviously much better than
the bishop even though white would be
down a pawn if you go to an end game
with just knight against bishop
white is the one pressing for a win and
black is just hoping to survive so
that would not be desirable and that's
why g takes f6 was played
and at least we leave the porn formation
a little bit better than when we came
here um so we'll we'll come back to this
one
in a short while but for now let's go
back one more time to the bird's eye
view
and see what is happening elsewhere
well finally duda played d4 we've been
anticipating a move like that for a
while
dubov has not moved so i don't know if
that's a very bad sign for him because
he gave up a pawn in the center of the
board and now he's thinking after the
sacrifice when you sacrifice material i
tend to think it's you want to follow it
up quickly because it was an intentional
sacrifice so what do you make of that at
least generally speaking that dubai's
the one spending time now
yeah it's uh it's surprising but didn't
he say in his interview
something about he didn't maybe we said
it but something about uh yeah just
sacrificed upon and spring think later i
think what he said what duboff said is
just give up some fun and and then start
playing for tricks but
hopefully for him he has something more
than just tricks in mind it's har i
think robert it's an impossible task uh
to ask me what's going on in in daniel
do bob's mind when he makes his move his
decisions
and so i'm going to take us away from
there i'm going to uh quickly talk about
the nils grand alias game because we had
talked about that early g4 push
and that pawn has just simply gone has
just been snapped off
well we love a good sicilian and
a lost pawn means an open file let's be
optimistic let's think about the bright
side of things there's no g pawn
which means that soon i wouldn't play it
right now but soon the rook is coming to
g1 and putting pressure on black's
position and i actually really like the
way this looks for whites let's go back
to see how we got here f3 was met by a6
queen d2 and then knight to e5 so the
knight comes to e5 and knight c4 is a
typical idea forking the queen and the
dark square bishop in which case white
can capture on c4 which is what happened
in the game f4
knight went to
c4
so why is the
i don't think knight takes g4
looks that appealing in fact it will
just it looks kind of like the game
so what is it here that
black is it this
like i'm helped because i have the
evaluation bar it's not a move that i
would have thought about i would have
just looked at knight takes g4 but i see
the
bar hovering and it's a sacrifice but i
don't even know if after knight takes e4
and white gets three minor pieces for
the queen what's going on there that's a
lot to calculate and maybe we can
quickly show that because it's not a
material imbalance we see every day so
we could have gotten something like this
where white would have the two knights
and a bishop for the queen
yeah the e5 falls that's
another pawn and bishop to d3 something
like this i mean black is better at
least at the moment and
i don't like the long-term prospects
though for black these are some really
good minor pieces that white has and in
our minds when we calculate a position
like this i wouldn't know how to assess
it and even with the evaluation bar off
to the side i'm still not sure that i
would take black despite what it says i
also think that bishop b4 is such a
difficult move to to find in a spot like
this if we go back to the moment where
niels played
f4 i think knight c4
is a natural move it is the reason you
came to e5 in the first place and your
knight is being attacked so i think that
knight c4 is just very often a move you
make pretty much
instantly and you don't think about oh
let me just make another move which
completely ignores that my my knight is
attacked
and it's one of the reasons you know the
time limit exists is players don't have
forever to consider their options and we
do need to fight our instincts sometimes
in chess we have these instincts that
are essentially shortcuts to help us
make decisions more quickly but at the
same time
our instincts prevent us from even
thinking about moves like bishop b4
sometimes because our knight's under
attack we played 95 to go knight c4
bishop before it didn't even look that
appealing because i don't really want to
take the knight and give up all the dark
squares but here bishop b4 with this
crazy position and even if the queen
moves let's say to d3 knight takes c3
this type of position you think is a3
working here
what's the deal in this dynamic but the
whole point for everyone wondering is
that this rook on a1 is lost so after
the check
you lose the rook and you just are down
too much material so yeah i would not
have found bishop before i'm completely
gonna be honest like bishop before
didn't cross my mind until i saw the
evaluation bar
tank downwards and knight c4 is logical
knight takes g4
is a move that
steals a pawn but it actually just kind
of transposes similar position to the
game where after takes queen takes
you're going to play knight g4 anyway
most likely and then his queen comes to
g3 and
white has a ton of activity for the
sacrifice pawn and if we see in the game
because that's where we are
um it's actually quite similar in nature
where
blacks knight
likely will take this bishop once white
castle's queen side but we get this
dynamic fiona where
way ahead in development for white
clear initiative but black has the pawn
you've said you like pawns extra pawns
extra material you like bishop pairs
but i have a sense
that you're going to take white in this
position
you know me too well robert too well by
now because i also do love um i don't
know some attacking chess i love pushing
my f pawn
i see a king that's still in the center
i would love to maybe play some f5 soon
if i get the opportunity just try and
open up
the black king as much as i can and it's
it's not so obvious to me what's black
going to do first of all that bishop on
c8 right now
i guess let's have
that is going to have to move at some
point i don't know if black is gonna
want to touch that d-pawn because if the
d-pawn goes to d6 or d5 either way we
can always take on d6 either straight
away or on passer and then the line i
really don't want that e file opening in
front of my king i don't think so i
wonder is black going to play b5
which makes sense anyway because the
white king is on c1 so we can hope to
get
some counter play against that and also
maybe we can look to to develop the
bishop on b7
all
correct and all unclear i mean once you
play bishop b7 or preemptively i'll put
my rook on g1 and go for the semi-open
line but black is up a pawn so if the
attack doesn't come swiftly or black is
able to make a move like d6 because
bishops need and love open space
then that would be good for black but
for the time being we see a rook on a
semi-open file near where the king of
the center is this knight can hop into
e4 the knight on d4 is well placed as
you said f5 is an option bringing the
rook to the g file so white has a ton of
different potential moves here and black
is solid for now but underdeveloped and
that could be an issue
for black going forward yeah i'm really
curious to see how this game develops
for now i saw a couple of requests in
the chat uh asking us to check in with
duda and carlson which i think is our
main clash of the day we see from the
bird's eye view and you mentioned it
already that duda has finally gone for
the central uh push with d4 so maybe we
can take a closer look there
for sure we left off when bishop f8 was
played dude did choose the move queen c2
to remind everybody the problem with d4
too early is that in this situation the
move knight to b4 just one more reminder
that knight takes e4 is a blunder
because of bishop d5 this is an
important tactic in the spanish for
everyone to learn that bishop d5 you
lose upon e4 but you attack two pieces
at the same time instead of taking on e4
knight to b4 is the good decision
because the e4 pawn is now under attack
and that's why you saw the arrow of
queen b1 as a way to defend it you don't
really want to play the move e5 because
while it is an advancing move heading
towards the black king you allow black
to play move like knight to d5 and now
these knights are hopping into the game
uh the bishop is blocked it would love
to put more pressure on f7 but these
knights are protecting one another the
e3 bishop doesn't exactly look great and
then this light square bishop for black
can join the party so
it's overly committal we had jokes about
it earlier instead
queen c2 was played and only after the
bishops were traded did white play d4
and watch out because that d5 square is
where that pawn wants to go
yes so what do we do here uh as black to
to stop e5 also in general i think uh
one of the questions when i stream or
when i commentate that i i get a lot is
i think
people find it very hard to decide how
to deal with tensions
in the center at which point do we want
to to exchange at which point do we want
to to keep the tension and what what
would you say
such a good question because oftentimes
in these spanish the roy lopez openings
you don't really want to take on d4
because if you just look at this
optically you have given white control
of the center but you see the bar to the
left hand side of the board going down
which means that it actually has helped
black's cause and the reason why is that
when there's a pawn
three squares away from a knight we talk
about this very often i know i talk
about it all the time people are sick of
hearing it a pawn three squares away
from knight dominates that knight and it
takes away the b4 square and the d4
square from this knight's axis so by
taking on d4 in this type of position
then the knight can hop into b4 where it
attacks the queen it means that the
queen is going to have trouble keeping
this pawn e4 defended there are no
tactics with a bishop on the light
squares anymore and if you play queen b1
you've walked into discoveries because
there's a rook on b8 so a move like
knight d5 now or in the future is going
to be quite a nuisance to deal with so i
actually would
in at this point
be open to
the move pawn takes d4 but look at this
while i want two pawns in the center
it's advantageous to have pawns in the
center when there are many pieces on the
board because pawns restrict pieces
for the moment i'll take with my knight
because i am forcing the action here
both your pieces are under attack the
only way to save them is by taking and
now i can take with my pawn not allowing
you to pester my queen i have exactly
what i've wanted two pawns in the center
black only has one white is more
advanced has more space and with more
space means that the enemies
pieces are limited in scope particularly
this bishop on f8 fiona this would be
like the ideal position from the white
side in this game yes so we'll see what
magnus decides to do we will come back
to this game and all the others all
seven games are still on the way we're
almost two hours into the round we'll
take a short break but we'll be back
with all the action very soon
[Music]
welcome again in vikrante shrek stanford
for bending for
[Music]
[Music]
lift
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
some interesting insights from
shankland he has had a shave i love
robert what he's saying about chess
would be boring if the best ones always
won we saw it here last year with a big
underdog victory uh by jordan van
furiste and well sam he's here to fight
it out to fight for first place as well
and robert today a tough test with the
black pieces against uh fabiano carrana
and i have to give sam franklin credit
he's always like up there with the best
interviewees he's so
i mean he's so enthused he's always
willing to answer the question so i have
to give him credit for that and in this
game uh well he's got to let his moves
do the talking and he has a bit of a
tough position i mean fabiano carwana is
obviously such a strong player but the
way i look at this position with those
double berlin pawns on the queen side it
means that black isn't going to get a
pass pawn on that so the board despite
having a four on three advantages cut
the board in half white has four king
side pawns black has three so that's
where white's advantage is and blacks
doesn't have the same advantage because
those pawns are doubled it's hard to
create a pass pawn and there's a king in
the center the rook on g8 is kind of
awkwardly placed so i think at least the
moment this position is better for white
what really will tell the tale of this
game is will white be able to push those
pawns on the king side will there be a
g4 push at some point even now i mean if
we see a trade of pawns here white will
follow up with f3 and we start to like
the look of all of white's pieces
concentrated on the king side that said
it's a long ways away from i have a
question big advantage if in this
position if i put my knight
i know it doesn't like to be on the rim
but if i jump into
h4
yeah
and i
[Music]
okay
i was hoping you wouldn't hit me
immediately
um
sorry go ahead no you go ahead
i was gonna say i think actually what
you're doing is completely reasonable
because if the knight went back it would
still go to g6 so like you're going in
the same direction no matter what and i
think that i have to as white play f3
because the g4 pawn is uh under attack
so we're getting back to familiar or
expected territory i should say
and then well
you are more familiar you said you
played berlin uh as black as well how
how is black do you try and uh
fight against the pawn majority on the
on the king side
i wish i had the answer i wish i could
solve the berlin i mean we see maxine
vasherlegrov play these positions time
and time and time again uh from the
white side he believes in the berlin and
it's because of this three on two
now for previous four on three advantage
of the king side and trying to get those
pawns mobilized and black does have some
play here this knight needs to find
better footing maybe we'll go
f8 to e6 at some point i just i prefer
to have the white side of these
positions
and uh robert actually
well right just when we came back from
the break and we watched the same video
i saw a lot of positive comments in the
chat about how great sam was and his
voice and i thought oh i'm surprised
turns out uh that was all sarcasm
because we played the interview muted uh
blame bigfoot but we'll watch it we'll
watch it again right now and after that
we'll come back to the bird lie overview
i remember coming here uh first time was
2015 i was playing the b section i had a
fantastic result i made plus five but
wei you was an absolute terminator
i played him with white in round one and
it was a draw and it was just i never
had a chance again if i had known that
he was going to go nuts maybe i would
have pushed a little harder
i remember at first it was chorus chess
before it was thought to steal and i
always remembered this was like the the
most important tournament of the year
the biggest best one
tata still chess room and you know they
call it the wimbledon of trust and i
think they've earned that name uh it's
just the best term in the world
obviously you know with magnus in the
field and i'm in the bottom half
the odds are against me but you know if
the best player always won chess will be
a very boring game i'm just gonna play
my best and if the points come that way
they will
so i use technology for opening
preparation for sure but that's more or
less the only thing i use it for i think
i'm more scared in terms of the future
of trust of computers just processing
faster and then if they've become a
little bit stronger i worry that one day
chess can be weakly solved
luckily i still think that day is very
very far away and i think it will be
after i'm retired many many years in the
future
it was a very memorable tournament for
me both with positive and negative
attributes last time but i'm really
looking forward to playing again this
year
so good to hear from sam shankland again
and if you want to find those portrait
videos they get uploaded throughout the
tournament you can find them
on the official
youtube
channel of the tata steel chess
tournament and robert we are back in the
bird's eye view we were saying during
the break today is really a hugely uh
exciting game where does ui go first
i just note that fabiano was smart and
he played f3 he's trying to time his g4
break perfectly but let's stay away from
that game we were just looking at it it
will probably get interesting in the
next few moves do bob against vidit we
see the center opening up the f5 move
that you suggested fiona was played by
vidit so that one is definitely exciting
i mean all across these games the
grandelias report game the b5 move just
happened anish geary i think that's a
game we could probably take a good look
at because we haven't tuned in a while
and it seems like he's up a pawn and he
has a promising position at this point
with mama jarvis king still in the
center
yes so let's go there and after that we
can check in with duboff and vidit so we
left this off not too long ago but the
position has really exploded into life
yeah i mean a3 was the choice and that
move caught me off guard uh i wonder
after b takes a3 was he simply going to
take back or was he no i don't think
that works let's say b4 because if you
take there's some pressure down the b
file but when you do take black has a5
to follow it up with i don't think that
black has solved all of the problems but
i was going for tactics that don't
actually work out so i'm going to uh
take the move back so
mama jarv was afraid of something and
went c5 but we talked about why c5 is a
dangerous move to play with your king in
the center after knight takes c5 knight
takes c5 pawn takes e5
bishop takes a takes b4
go ahead take that pawn on b4 there are
tactics here and black is going to be
very unhappy about them
yes so shaq wisely decided not to take
the pawn on before but instead instead
dropped a bishop back at 2
b6 and
well
aneesh uh has
picked up the pawn and the black king is
still
in the center do you think this is
trouble for shahid medieva
it really looks like it and black is one
move away from castling the extra pawn
is doubled so
we see that the b pawns there are two of
them and that's where the extra pawn is
but it's not that powerful so i do think
that anish needs to work relatively
quickly i like the look of the move e5
just attacking this knight and opening
up this light square bishop if the
knight jumps into d5 which is exactly
where it wants to go attacking this pawn
on b4 i'm already looking at knight g5
let's go let's try to checkmate our
opponent bring our queen out somewhere
we still have checks along the a4 to e8
diagonal so i'm all in on the initiative
here knight can come to e4 into d6 as
well fiona this looks really scary for
uh chakriar
i mean i would be terrified here i i
don't see how shakhya is gonna be able
castling uh
going to be able to castle kingside
in the near future but if we look at the
camera right now it's on give you it was
on my media a second ago he still looks
like nice and relaxed but
maybe those appearances are deceiving
because i think anish clearly in the
driver's seat we see the two players
there
and i also anish from his body language
you can tell i think that he senses
today is my chance to get my first win
here
it is there's a king in the center he
knows that he needs to push forward and
he should be confident and mama jarov
he does look very calm which is
surprising to me
maybe he doesn't
think that his position is that bad he
is used to having crazy positions with
immense complications but i'm not liking
the look of that king in the center i
think foundationally black's position is
quite solid everything is defended so if
you can trade queens for example black
is not just fine black will be better
but why would a niche trade queens
there's a king in the center there's an
attack brewing and so i do think we'll
see an e5 knight g5 type of jump from
aneesh yeah and i think shakira would
love to be playing this from the white
side instead there is a question in the
chat from rink i never know if it's
ringed or rink ed but uh if we go back
to the to the position we had on the
board that you showed after knight g5
he's wondering does the crazy move
knight e3 work
cutting off the bishop from this knight
so it's a great idea it's a nice tactic
of
interposing on the diagonal the problem
is
while you're attacking my queen i will
get rid of your knight first you will
take back because now my bishop defends
the knight and you're thinking all right
if white takes on e3 then i take on g5
but white isn't obligated to take on e3
just yet i will throw in bishop b5 check
i will trade queens and then and only
then will i take your bishop and i will
end up a piece ahead so a really nice
tactical idea unfortunately from the
perspective of mama jarv it doesn't work
out in this position because i'm
removing the piece that's attacking my
knight on g5 just to finish off the
variation let's trade bishops let's
trade queens and then well i have a fork
on f7 but i'll just take your bishop and
be up a full piece and once again we see
that the reason this a nice tactical
idea didn't work is again because the
king is still in the center and exposed
to all these different checks
and tactics so really um a lot of
problems to solve here for shakira
mamedyarov um
oh and meanwhile anish has actually has
gotten bitter b5 check
wow he's
i think forcing the king to make a move
because bishop c6 doesn't seem that
appealing uh from my perspective as
there's oh i think there's a
just a pin and then knight e5 we talked
about this earlier and yeah that's not
going to be good for black the king in
the center that's the
if mama jar was castled he'd be okay in
almost all of these lines and he's not
castle so he has to pay the price for
that
yeah so bishop c6 is just simply not an
option
uh which means that uh shahid mahmoud
looks like he's going to have to move
that king
f8 i mean you don't want to go to e7
that's walking into danger on this
diagonal here so king f8 and then if i'm
a niche whoa
that bar is freaking out i mean
but
could 97 be a move
yeah 97 unfortunately like 95.
everything is
a problem here's a king of fate
so at first it somehow really likes
white's position and then it comes back
down to earth like not so fast the more
depth i get the more i see that black is
doing okay here but even like queen e2
now that the king is stuck in the center
maybe
i mean this pawn e4 is a problem though
fiona that's the thing it's like you
have to be willing as white to probably
give up this pawn because the look of e4
i don't believe in the queen trade i
think that black is totally fine if the
queens come off the board so i i'm
guessing anish is ready to sacrifice
that pawn well the good news is you are
a pawn up even if it is a doubled double
b pawn
so yeah i think i need
in good shape here but we're only on
move 16
uh anish down to under 40 minutes so
at some point white will have to speed
up but yeah i believe anish and
definitely here in charge
shall we go robert uh to the game
between duboff and vidit
okay well we have a view of all seven
and i will focus our attention on the
game between dubai f5 was played your
suggestion i don't think that vita could
hear you but he still listened
i think if he could hear me he probably
wouldn't have gotten it
no i it's interesting i i honestly think
that the move f5 it complicates matters
in a way that makes it easier for black
to play because it's harder for white to
play that sounds convoluted i know but
the thing is if you allow one side to
have all these easy moves and you're
thinking five minutes with every turn
we're on move 15. vidin has 32 minutes
he has 25 moves to make and 32 minutes
that's not a lot of time and this is
really complex it i think is much better
for white but the very least he's caused
duboff to go into his time and start
thinking every single move
yeah so if we go back to that moment
where f5 was played i think was one of
the first moments when duboff really
started
going into the tank duboff one of the
fastest players i think in this
tournament
and he decided to take on e5 which i
guess makes sense because we talked
about this in different games today when
the opponent's king is in the center we
want to open
as many lines as possible against the
enemy king
exactly just that and after d5 rookie
one watch out rook takes e4 might be
white's next move if black passed the
turn wouldn't be surprised to see that
so how do you avoid that knight takes g3
but in this position after h takes we
talked about f takes when the rook was
on f1 barreling down the file now we
want to take towards the center and
shield our king more there's a problem
f5 is hanging you can't move your knight
because e5
is hanging in e4 doesn't actually
threaten anything because your queen and
your king here makes means that pawn is
pinned something like g4 and let's rip
open everything
it's an exciting position but more
exciting for duval than it is for a
vidit for sure um yeah i think do and do
both putting on the pressure here
and not easy uh for for vidit if we go
back to the position uh we have on the
board after work e1
that we don't really want to take
on g3 but
do we have uh do we have any
alternatives
we can't move the knight from d7 because
then we drop e5
um
[Music]
there has to be another move somewhere
here i'm just struggling to see it fiona
and i like this
that's what i was gonna say yeah i'm
getting into the twitch lingo you know
i'm trying to every day we break you
down a little more robert that's right
my life is getting worse for it but at
least people can enjoy hearing me say
not like this
um but yeah i mean we we are joking uh
but but forbid it and this is a very
serious um
a very serious moment here
because it's also we already on that
territory where every
uh slight misstep it doesn't have to be
a big mistake but a slight misstep here
can uh immediately be game over
i mean he looks really unhappy
is like trying to dig deep
into his calculations and find something
that allows him at least
some comfort and it's not going to be
easy as kings in the center he hasn't
castled he's lacking in development and
i do think one line is we just went down
this path but one thing that maybe just
maybe can keep vidit in this game is
that making this move knight c5
you protect e4
another time you protect f5 with your
bishop
i don't like the look of this position
it still is
great for duboff here but the very least
you make white's follow-ups more
difficult uh if you take on f5 the
bishop recaptures and you can actually
see the evaluation bar saying
black is
holding his own right now because e4 is
so well defended by all these pieces and
the knight on c5 actually looks quite
nice here defended by the queen so
there's much more harmony in black's
position if those trades were to occur
yeah so maybe some hope here for duboff
but
for vidit but once again it's the
situation it's a very very thin line uh
to walk and as the time takes down a few
people in the chat were asking what move
are we on
we're only on move 16 which means that
vidit still has to make 25 moves
reminder about the time control it is
one of the longest time controls there
is on the circuit well the longest i
believe 100 minutes for the first 40
moves then an extra 50 minutes for the
next 20 and finally an extra 15
minutes after move 60 with a 30 second
increment from move one and uh robert
here quick look into the standings after
two rounds
yes we have uh three players in the
joint lead magnus carlsen the world
champion jontrosov dude the world's cup
champion and nvidia gujarati the
champion of the people's hearts so one
half of the two was the top of the
leaderboard that can all change in a
moment duda is playing against carlson
and vinit as we've been showing is in a
tough spot against duboff who would like
to leapfrog him in the standings
yeah and uh well we're back in the
bird's eye
view
things have changed a little bit
actually in the game between two of our
leaders duda and carlson should we go
there and and update that briefly
let's do it
there well things are happening all
across the boards they're nearing that
point
they're not quite in
you know near the time patrol yet but
they're like i don't want to have two
minutes left to make 10 moves so the
action is speeding up a bit here we see
that there's some clarity in the
position there's a backward pawn on c7
the queen on c2 is happy to be where it
is there's a rook on a4 queen knight all
defending this one pawn on e4 but that's
because
magnus put his pieces in a formation to
put maximum pressure there and fiona i
have to say this bishop on f8 looks
excellent the best piece on the board
for sure attacking a lot really has so
much room to work with but besides that
piece there really are no issues with
white's positions assuming with black's
position so i
i can see some of the merits in magnus's
choices
well talking about that bishop where
uh would you like that bishop if you
could put it anywhere on the board where
would you like it to be
oh great question right here
b4 i want to get rid of this knight
unfortunately robert bad news that isn't
going to happen
okay well uh my second choice for that
bishop is can i put it here
on h7 change the color move like a
knight for one turn and that way i can
put pressure on the diagonal but
obviously we're just joking around but
it goes to show that improving a single
piece can make all the difference in
chess and white is slightly better here
but it's a nagging advantage you see
magnus's face he's not happy and i'm
sure you know if he does do an interview
after the game just like we heard in the
world championships like well i didn't
really like my position it felt
uncomfortable but it wasn't that bad
objectively so that's the
thing about magnus he's the best player
in the world but one of the things he
does so well is even when he's feeling
this emotional discomfort he can ground
himself in the reality of the board the
objectivity and say i know i'm worse but
realistically it can't be that terrible
for me so let's find the good moves yeah
and i love the close-up we're seeing
here of
magnus carlsen who will have
some work to do and i agree with you
that magnus is so good in defending
these positions but i think
also duda lately has really really
impressed me uh
with how he deals with the small
advantages and duda always so calm
so yeah i think a very interesting
battle here will duda be able to pile up
more and more pressure against magnus
who is clearly not looking as
comfortable as we see him looking
sometimes you're right and you asked
what i would do with that bishop on f8
let's talk about some of white's pieces
this knight on d2 i would love to get to
c6 and not just because of the fork i'm
not trying to win material but that's a
square that white has under his control
so if i could bring my knight to f3 to
d4 to c6 that would be ideal but that's
what magnus's last couple moves were
about we left off after d4
the trade happened knight takes d4 very
important to trade off the knight so
then i could go to b4 after the pawn
takes and then he went queen e8
immediate pressure on the e4 pawn after
d5 the rook dropped back to e7 and then
he brought his rook to a4 which is why
he went d5 we're justifying that move by
bringing the rook to the fourth rank
where it now protects the pawn if the
pawn was in d4 it would not defend so
we understand the last few moves that
have been played here and now it's about
going forward one thing i would like to
see from magnus is can he make this move
c6 at some point because that's his real
weakness in the position if d5 and c6
are traded off you no longer have a
backwards pawn you're trading off
white's great pawn on d5 that's
restricting black's pieces and then i
think that there's no issue whatsoever
for magnus however if c6 doesn't work
and he's unable to get it in then he's
going to be left with this problem this
eyesore on c7 and that's no fun yeah and
practicing the chat is right magnus
actually reached out it looked like he
was about to make a move and then sunk
back
uh into deep uh fought and i i think
you're absolutely right uh i think
magnus has been investing some time here
because he is trying to figure out can
he make c6 work here um well we'll have
to come back to to find out we will
leave him to it for now it looks like
he's not gonna make a move
right now anyway so we're back in the
bird's eye view and really today's such
an exciting game you're the inventor
race against pragnanda
they are down to just the heavy pieces
uh robert and do you think that the the
goal post pawns are still a big problem
for prague
some might say the goal posts have
shifted and
he is covering all of his bases the rook
on f5 covers the e pawn the rook on b4
trying to trade off for that rook on e4
so i really like how the teenager from
india is playing this game pragnanda is
an excellent player but he's
inexperienced relative to the rest of
the field so i i think he's doing a
great job right now jordan has
everything he could have asked for it's
why he played the way he did but i think
that prague is really playing some
excellent chess he's impressing me quite
a lot in the first three games i mean i
i have to
contextualize that i know we know how
great he is how much talent he possesses
but oftentimes people think oh that
person is the future and i like to say
like why not now i mean pragnando is
really really strong he can be anybody
in this field and his rating may be only
in
quotes 2612 and that's much lower than
his colleagues his competitors here but
i mean he is so strong
and
i'm really glad to see him performing
well at the start of this event i
completely agree and we talked about it
yesterday pregnant and only 16 years old
which means that when the pandemic
started hitting he was only
14 so he has been deprived for a couple
of years of getting invites to to a lot
of
tournaments and playing as much as he
would have liked then i wouldn't be
surprised to see him make a big rating
jump if not here than in the near future
but playing here making his debut in the
masters is such a great opportunity for
him and maybe just a very quick look
actually at the actual position on the
board craig's last move was rook f5
defending uh the pawn on e5 and uh
robert how do you think that jordan can
continue
to pile up some pressure here or to ask
some fresh some questions of prague
well you've heard as has everyone how
much i dislike the isolated pawns
particularly double isolated pawns
however they're very well defended
because you can't triple on the e file
and just win the e5 pawn as black will
exchange rooks but then i started
thinking what's the consequence of the
exchange let's say queen e2 happens it's
clear i have three pieces attacking your
pawn you don't want me to win that pawn
and so you'll take on e4 but what if i
take with my pawn rather than my queen
and by doing that i
try to put a rook on d1 and take
advantage of the only fully open file in
rook endings and here's a queen and rook
position i don't want to call it quite
an ending because the king is not that
safe on g8 but in this type of position
controlling the open file is often more
important than having
equal material so having a pawn deficit
but let's say this rook got one goes to
f7 and i play rook d1 and you move your
queen to e7 and i have the open file and
now i can start poking and prodding all
over the place if your queen leaves in
comes my rook to d6 so maybe i play
queen h5 and i just start attacking you
from all directions not a checkmating
attack but trying to collapse your weak
pawns so that is what i might go for if
i'm jordan i'm sure there's something
that prague can do to deal with it but
this is the type of position where
jordan has
the ability to transfer his advantage he
can go from these terrible pawns for
black to shutting down his attack of
those pawns immediately by putting his
own pawn on e4 in order to take
advantage of an open file i think this
could be a really big moment for jordan
yes and we see jordan there on the
camera
considering his options
i think i completely agree with you he
is going to continue
he has a little bit of pressure he will
look for ways to increase that and also
for pregnant and he'll have to watch out
on the clock only 19 minutes left
still 18 moves to go so that's one of
the intriguing games we have going on
but all the others are also still
underway we will come back to them after
just a short break so don't go anywhere
and we'll see you in a moment
[Music]
at tata seal we place artificial
intelligence into the center of our
innovation program so we can innovate
faster than ever before
advanced data analyzing techniques are
not only fun to work with but it really
helps me to work on sustainability for
example reducing dust emissions this is
a really important topic for me
we have developed the digital tools to
accurately predict the performance of
our products in the processes of our
customers
quantifying the performance of our
products is key in making our customers
and us successful
we achieve world-class processability by
using ai to forecast and control the
outcomes of over 2 000 simultaneous
reactions
we use cameras instead of eyes and
computers instead of human brains so in
the near future our factories can make
their own decisions
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
welcome back it is round three out of
tata steel chess tournament and we are
going to dive straight back into the
game of fabiano karana against sam
shankland uh robert sam is down to
only 17 minutes but that's maybe not his
only problem
yeah this position here is an issue for
black um trying to verify in the clock
situation i'm not sure if uh oh sorry no
no no that's uh what we see on screen
here but uh it looks like he might have
more time i'm not sure but either way he
has a problem on the board i would say
because there's a king on e8 and a rook
that's happy to see it there so when you
have positions like this a rook in line
with a king you want to think what
happens if the pieces clear out and
knight f6 check would be checkmate if
not for this pawn on g7 that pawn will
capture that knight by force and e e
takes f6
all of a sudden there's an issue down
the line the knight is pinned to the
king and all the blacks pieces are kind
of awkwardly placed here so this looks
like an opportunity for fabiano i'm not
sure if it leads to a huge advantage
but it does look like it shatters
black's pawn structure and gives fabiano
an opportunity to alter the position in
a way that should be favorable for him
and i think if we look at fabiano on the
camera he senses the opportunity he has
of course seen
knight f6 and now it's a matter of doing
uh the the hard the calculating
uh work
so let's um
shall we have a look at it one more time
knight f6 g takes is first
and he takes back with the pin
and
once again i guess we we don't really
have any options rather other than to to
step out of the e-file
yeah you don't want to remain in that
pin
and now that i'm actually thinking about
this a little more
the engine the evaluation bar can be a
bit misleading because it's not like the
evaluation is that high for white to
begin with but one of the things that
could happen is if this bishop trades
for this knight white will be better
that is a hundred percent the case but
opposite colored bishops even when one
side is down upon or has this much more
structure those types of positions can
be held it's going to be a tough
defensive task
but opposite colored bishops hold many
drawing possibilities so i'm wondering
if this
maximizes 500's winning chances but in
some way clarifies the position that
allows sam to feel a little more
comfortable trying to rely on this
bishop takes g5 in the future
yes so
another
point of consideration for fabiano when
looking into
knight f6 how much of an edge do i have
here how much how many winning chances
will the opposite color bishops um
how many drawing chances will the
opposite color bishops give
sam so i think we'll leave fabiano to it
but a very interesting uh moment here
and this character of this position
might change
very shortly for now let's quickly have
another look at the bird's eye view see
what's happening
elsewhere and we see robert actually
almost all the games are
jumping into life
i really like what we're seeing from
this round some
fighting chess all across the board we
were just talking about in fabiano
caruana's position with the rook on e1
the king on e8 the same dynamic exists
in that duba vidic game we were looking
at that earlier uh it seems like they're
going down variations we predicted vidit
i doubt he's comfortable but at least
he's playing moves that make perfect
sense and jordan von forrest he did
allow the rook trade on e4 but he took
with the rook rather than with the pawn
so i i'm not positive if his decision
um is any worse in fact it might just be
better than taking with the pawn e4 he
will try to press this
advantage into a win and of course yes a
pangu karjak and the russian derby that
one's still locked up nothing has
altered too much there and then geary
that game no longer has queens on the
board fiona so i don't even know what
game to look at as much i know
also very interesting is grand alias
against rapport where both players have
now castled uh queenside but we see the
white king looking rather more safe than
the black one that's sort of out in the
open
on c8
but
yeah i don't even know where to start i
will let you choose robert
uh all right i'll go to the anish game
against mama jarv just because we
see him on screen and because there are
no longer queens in this game so if we
go back a couple moves because bishop b5
check the king went to f8 and
anish decided to trade and play bishop
e3 so this is the day of double pawns
because black could have captured on e3
but mama jarv is too strong just to
buy into how the position looks he is
calculating bishop e3 pawn takes e3
looks so bad
for white at first glance and then you
remember whites have a pawn and then you
see oops a7 is hanging and then f7 is a
problem and the rook has an open file
and black's position is really bad so
it's not just about the pawn structures
about the activity of the pieces and
that is why mama jarov decided to take
on e4 allowing an exchange of bishops
but that actually protects that a pawn
in the process by turning into a b-bomb
how much of a problem is it for
for mamadiara of robert that his king is
on f8 and that rook on h8 at the moment
isn't playing at all
and
you brought it to my attention now that
i think about it you can actually make
it even worse for black by stopping one
square short of expectations let's play
favorite tactics it's been a theme
throughout the tournament
it is i love these types of moves
because when someone picks up the bishop
you think as their opponent they're
gonna trade and then go bishop c5 check
and you're like oh um wait i don't want
to take because that gives white a pass
pawn while undoubling the pawns but i
don't want to play king g8 because then
look at this uncastled king that rook
should be somewhere on c8 you ask how to
where i want my pieces i would like that
rook on see it i can't get that and so
this is not a setup you want when white
is so active so if you trade on c5 now
we have this problem on a7 this pawn on
c5 is excellent and white is definitely
for choice so i think bishop c5 check
fiona you led me to find a good move
yeah bishop c5 certainly uh looks like
an interesting
option it feels like anise anish has a
few a few moves here
he can consider but it's an interesting
one where uh if we go back a few moves
uh i didn't expect anish to uh exchange
queens but i think it's a great example
of showing how with the active piece
play
you don't have to try and keep the
queens on the board you can keep your
initiative
even after the queens have left
and it also shows why connecting your
rooks is so important even though
there's no checkmating attack uh there
could be if um mamijarov had taken on e3
rather than on e4 we talked about a rook
on the seventh rank and then lining up
to the f7 pawn that's very dangerous for
that black king and in the game
continuation if we do see bishop c5
check there's such a problem for this
king and thus this rook and you don't
want to take on c5 but you might have to
because
king ji looks
so bad but anish hasn't stopped one
short one square short he has instead
traded on b6
and after a takes the knight has jumped
forward to e5
probably also good for white i just
liked that tactic
uh it would have changed the nature of
the position a bit but look at this
we're coming to a7 still f7 is weak rook
d5
looks like a nice move with a fork of
the pieces but you know what that does
it leaves the back rank and so a rook
will come over to a8 with check and that
would be a problem for the king and that
rook in the corner so 95 is also a good
looking idea robert do i have time to
get my king
out of this uh h rank and try and
connect the rook do i have time for a
move like
g6 or there is
rook a7 2 pressing a threat
yeah rook a7 is a threat but
don't stop one square short i know
stopping one square short is what i've
been talking about but g5 because after
rook a7 now you slide the bishop back to
g6 and defend this pawn here
i still like white's position um the
extra pawn
for black like if we think about the
splitting the board in half black has a
four on three pawn majority on
the e for the h file white has a two on
one
on the queen side but they're double
pawns which is not great
however
white is far more active the b6 pawn is
likely to fall and so
that does give white some promise of an
outer
pass pawn not a
flank pawn it's not on the a file on a
rook pass pawn but as an outside pass
pawn that can be used to distract
black's pieces yeah so anish still
in great shape here pressing against my
mobiarof let's come back here a bit
later
maybe we can check in uh
cd overview make sure we don't miss
anything exploding into life because it
feels like we're already at that point
in the game where something dramatic
could be happening uh somewhere
do you want to go to duboff
and visit
let's first check out von forrest
against pragmata just because
things have changed a little bit there
and we did see mama jar play g5 by the
way but here in the game between von
forrest and pragnando there is a missing
g pawn for white but it's also a missing
f pawn so after the sequence of moves
queen e2 rook takes e4 great lesson for
everybody just because someone takes
your piece doesn't mean you have to
recapture queen g4 was check the king
slid to the corner and then rook takes
e4 played he didn't go with pawn takes
to get the rook to defile he said let's
keep your pawns weak and under attack
and here pragnando and f3 which the
engine
really doesn't like
honestly fiona i understand it because
when your position the foundation of it
is really poor you want to create
threats activity for your pieces but as
we see what happened in the game after
gf queen f8 queen g3 was played by
jordan this pawn on e5 apparently more
important than this pawn in f3
yeah so uh let's have a look if black
were to capture on f3
the problem is we take on e5 with jack
i think black cannot play king g8
because rook g4 check would be a problem
so uh queen
f6 or queen g7 i guess queen f6
yeah but these
even if we trade queens this is a losing
endgame material is even but this is why
we hate double and particularly double
isolated pawns they're just so easy to
attack and you have to use your more
powerful forces to defend what you would
like to do is put this pawn on b6 right
and then your pawns are safe and sound
but as soon as i go rook c4 i defend my
pawn and attack yours and you'll have to
use your rook to defend so i think white
has all the time in the world can start
with king g2 bring your king close to
the center and there's no way that black
is able to keep all these pawns they're
all isolated and weak and exposed and
this is a winning
technically winning position for white
so prague cannot take
on f3 so instead
what
what are the options the pawn on e5 is
uh hit can we try and defend it
i
i guess i mean queen f6 is an idea to
defend but the problem is now you're not
threatening f3 because you don't want to
trade queens as we were talking about so
queen f6 uh there might even be
a good way to move or just an aggressive
let's go checkmate your king while i'm
at it then i get by king g2
and this pawn structure we oh gosh
oh gosh just the theme of the day
and uh
we see prague actually
i think this is the unhappiest i've seen
him in this event as so far he has a
little bit that look and just as we zoom
in on the camera at the face
goes down i think um
something we've we've all been there
robert um
i think prague is realizing now that his
position is really
very difficult and um
his decision to open up the position
with f3 maybe not the best idea
and it's something we're praising magnus
carlson for is his ability to show
restraint he when he doesn't like his
position he's cramped he still is able
to just sit and wait sergei karjakin
we've been talking about his ability to
that too in previous rounds so i think
with age and with experience you get
used to being in positions that aren't
very cozy which you're just worse and
you know that you're defending for a
long time but this moment here with f3 i
completely understand why he did that
it's the type of move that i would want
to play myself but as we see after the
capture and then queen to g3 he's not
happy because his pawns are weaker and
he can't take the pawn he's going after
and
yeah unfortunately for him this is a
position where jordan has just all the
time in the world to start
attacking the pawns in increasing his
advantage improving the location of his
pieces and i i think that probably not
is going down in this game and jordan
looks like he is going to make that
interesting opening choice
pay off and bounce straight back after
his loss yesterday to report
so i think back to the bird's eye view
all seven games still in progress we're
into the third hour here
i am still
terribly concerned
for vidit i have to say i see that white
rook only won and we have our first
result of the day
with anish geary and mermaid yarov but
not sure what happened robert
i'm guessing there was a draw offer
breathe
deep breaths deep breaths
i'm gonna breathe don't worry everyone
i'll be all right i i'm guessing there
was a draw offer and a draw accepted and
the players split the point so
well do we have moves let's see
because we left it after g5
did i need to offer a draft are you okay
seven
those kings look like they're in front
of one another right
he offered a draw
okay robert let's move on swiftly
i mean i have the position in front of
us it actually is a position where i
think the worst is far behind black and
anish is actually going to be quite
annoyed with himself and it's not about
the result itself it's about
when you get good positions
against such strong opposition you want
to make them suffer not that anish is a
mean guy it's just that you want to sort
of make your opponent gravel to try to
make him work
to level up the game it didn't seem like
mama drove had to do that he actually
had quite a lot of time when the game
ended and he was able to find g5 bishop
g6 and that was that so i i think that
anish is going to be quite disappointed
with how he played and i'm going to be
disappointed the draw offers are still
loud so whenever the next tournament
happens and organizers are getting
together
i don't need to say it so my time do i
ban the draw
offer please and thank you
i'm sure they will hear you eventually
robert
um okay for now well we're gonna move on
uh from here
but yeah certainly a slight
disappointment for anish let's go to
to do buff and
it
where vivid is trying to hold things uh
together the king is still dangerously
uh in the center of the board robert
let's quickly catch up with uh with what
we missed here okay well the bishop was
captured on g3
pawn takes back e4 so we actually had
looked at this exact position
and here instead of taking on f5 dubois
decides to put his knight on d4 and the
reason he does this had vidit taken on
g4 he did not do this you see that
there's a problem with his e4 pawn being
loose here so
and the evaluation part going up and for
good reason a move like bishop d5 just
trying to win this pawn the king is in
the center the queen's in front of it d7
is under attack you don't want any part
of that position so vidit smartly played
the move rook f8 and now if your g takes
f5 he will for sure take back with his
bishop here
fiona for the moment he's holding
everything together
for the moment being the key the key
word uh i
i still think the position looks
terrifying vidit has taken with the
bishop of course to keep an eye on the
pawn on e4 but we need to solve that
problem with the king on the eight i
think it brings us back to what we were
talking about very early on in the game
there was the question in the chat kind
of like king castle
uh queen side i think that question will
become relevant again very soon how how
safe is the king on c8 my feeling is it
doesn't look super safe but i'd rather
be pretty much anywhere then on the
eight right now
yeah no you don't want to stay in the
center and i'm looking at tactics right
now i'm not sure if they work um
i'm getting excited okay it's not my
game not my pieces but there's one
tactic i feel like we absolutely have to
dive into and it's the move rook takes
b7
so there was no queen side castling here
and it works it works the the evaluation
bar is okay okay it's come back down a
little bit but the point of this
sacrifice is that if you take on b7
your king is still in the center here
and very unhappy i am going not to take
on f5 because if i take on f5 and go
rook takes e4 you block the pin with
rookie 5 and now i'm just down a rook
and i'm the one who's unhappy instead i
will toss in this move bishop b5 check
if you go king to d8 i have knight c6
with a nasty fork if you bring your
bishop back then i take on e4 and you're
pinned down the center here right bishop
b7 rook takes e4 thank you very much you
lose your queen and your king is being
hunted so that leaves you with the one
move king f7 and after king f7 your rook
no longer protects the bishop thank you
for your peace i'm happy to be down in
exchange if king will never be saved h6
under attack e4 falling the bishop on
the light squares i think you know how i
feel about this position fiona and i
really like it for white
absolutely yeah so vetted uh in big
danger here
um and rook b7 i mean dupoff uh dupa is
thinking
right now
and
do you think he will
he will capture on b7
as dubois is staring into our souls on
the camera
duval for sure is going to see rotates
b7 he is a tactical wizard he plays
these openings where he sacrifices
material he has no issue giving up big
pieces for tiny pawns but where there's
a will there's a way and he is going to
try and break down with his defenses and
rook takes b7 is just the start is
dupoff currently at the board i'd be
very curious to see
uh what he is looking like
can we see if he's smelling blood is he
at the board let's find out with the
photographer leonard oates in the
playing hall they're trying to capture
some of the best moments of
today
and yeah dupoff
rook b7
could put vitid into really big trouble
especially with 12 minutes uh on the
clock
there he is robert what do you make of
the visuals we get on the kneel
no he's gonna play rook takes b7 because
castling queen side is what vidic wants
it's the only way he'll feel remotely
safe and if you take that pawn away
there's no chance for that king to
castle and it's not the end of the game
like vidit will fight on that will just
turn the material back to being balanced
but it just looks so fun to play for
white and so miserable to play from
vidi's perspective i mean you just are
going to be attacked and attacked and
attacked and if you can defend perfectly
there's a reason why video is a super
grand grandmaster one of the best best
players in the world but even the best
players in the world they fall victim to
pressure to attacks like this so rook
takes b7 i think would be just
kind of a knockout yeah and robert i
think we're gonna go on a very short
break but maybe we can keep a dupe off
as well as the small board on on screen
so we don't miss
that moment and then we'll be back
with all the action here as we approach
the first time control so i will see you
very soon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
welcome back and robert rook takes b7
has just appeared on the board
um i
don't want to say i told you so but i
told everybody that rook takes b7 and
dubov he is going to find that move i'm
more curious about how did it will react
because he hasn't played
a move yet and he's quite in time
trouble
i'm very worried about him as kings in
the center it's only move 21.
this looks like
it's going dubai's way it's not viz day
yeah i
i mean although we see the bar only
saying plus 0.6
i think
to defend this you need to play
absolutely
flawless defensive moves
you need to find every single best move
uh in the position and
that's gonna be tough for any human
being but to do it with seven minutes
for 20 moves i think is very close to
mission impossible i don't even know
what move black should play here we have
the evaluation bar of the side of screen
i don't know what move even looks
acceptable knight takes b7 we were
looking at and we know how good that is
for white the black king is going to be
in big trouble
you can legally castle queenside i don't
think you should do that but just to
point out that you can still castle this
way you'll just see the eval bar go
yep exactly do you agree with me robert
that i think it is one of the rules in
chess that most player people are
confused about i've seen some quite
strong players
not being certain if they can castle
queen side if the b file
is
is attacked
they only know it when they see those
tactics where the solution is the castle
queen side with a rook on b7 or on b2 so
yeah i think that it is you know it's so
uncommon for it to happen but you can
still castle queenside which
shouldn't happen right now but is
important to keep in mind maybe there is
a position where vidit can hold off
dubab's attack for a little bit and then
castle queen side but i mean this looks
tragic for the king honey and you look
at vivid's expression here fiona from a
practical point of view i i think he
believes he's just dead lost
yeah it's uh always tough to to have the
camera on the players also pragnanda
early it looks actually today that it's
going to be
a tough day for the two indian players
in the field yesterday we started to
dutch participants lose i think today um
both with it and pragnanda in
in big trouble and yeah i think one of
the problems here is as you pointed out
it's so hard to come up with a move at
all that keeps you in the game
and these are the moments where it feels
like suddenly time is passing twice as
fast as it usually does you only have
five minutes and the minutes just i take
down at the speed of light
that's right and i mean honestly no
matter how much time did it has
i don't really care i'm looking in this
position and i'm seeing that his king's
in the center he doesn't look very happy
so uh you know
he just
is facing a really strong opponent who
is particularly creative on this day
yeah and i saw a comment in the chat
that duboff is creating another symphony
i mean he is really a player you never
know what you're gonna get the first day
he was very lucky to get away with the
draw
after getting a little bit maybe too
creative against my mediarov
but today again some some unusual
moves starting with bishop g5 which is
quite rare in the italian opening and
then this move knight a3 which vidid
decided to capture and then daniel got
exactly what he wanted uh some attacking
possibilities
and he never let vidit off the hook
yeah this is uh
i want to know what move that it will
play in this position
if he takes we're talking about those
lines earlier bishop b5 checks such a
powerful move with the bishop under
attack e4 pawn the pin along the e file
this is
yeah this is really really bad
i'm seeing in the chat a few people are
writing that rook f6 is the only
uh move here
so maybe we can take another uh look at
that and we see the close-up of vidit's
clock
but he doesn't actually have
no he's 20-something minutes so it was
20 minutes removed from his clock
so
um
yeah that's not good no
okay so with it that's some good news at
least for all the witted fans as we
mentioned it's still a very difficult uh
situation but having 21 minutes rather
than three is at least something
yep so thank you for informing us that
if it does have time to calculate i
still don't know
if he has enough because you could give
an hour to a player and white's position
looks so promising but we'll see what
happens from here since maybe a few
player a few viewers have joined us
since the break i see there is the
question what happens if
it captures the rook so maybe we can
just show those lines uh one more time
okay let's do that so vortex b7 was the
last move played there was a pawn there
and the point of this tactic is the king
is in the center and in trouble so if
you take the rook on b7 bishop b5 check
the king can move only has two legal
squares king d8 runs into a knight c6
forking a king on d8 and the queen on e7
the king coming to f7
won't fall victim to a knight fork but
it will allow white to capture this
bishop on f5 because the king is in the
rook's path so white goes down and
you're not really down anything but
sacrifice is an exchange a rook for a
minor piece the king is in trouble uh
bishop c4 check will be an option this
pawn on h6 is hanging if you play a move
like queen e6 trying to guard everything
the knight simply moves back now the
queen's under attack i'm trying to open
up this diagonal e4 is falling
i think you get by my tone that black's
position is no fun
absolutely so taking is not an option
we'll see what fit it comes up with for
now let's go back to the bird's eye view
and see what's been happening elsewhere
sounds good well we have all
six remaining games on screen here
the prague not in the game
i mean jordan is now in an end game
those really
unappealing let's put it that way pawns
for pragnanda or on the board so this
should be
jordan's game a nice bounce-back game
for him and all the other games it looks
like are about
level
well the dude above game i don't care
what the engine says it's anything but
level uh and then the grendelia scheme
that looks like it's starting to turn in
reports favor maybe we can go there we
haven't uh checked in with randalia and
report in quite a while and
a very exciting position on the board
sure let's do that so we have
this position here where
um
black's queen is on a4 which is not a
square you see it on every day but
white's pieces are a little bit stuck i
mean there's pressure on e4 here there's
a great rook on c8 going down to the c2
square
and
[Music]
this doesn't look very comfortable for
niels i think his hopes of an attack
i don't think they're coming to fruition
fiona shouldn't we
i know we've missed quite a few moves do
you want to go back to where we left off
or just back a few moves
let's do it so we saw uh here rook g1
was played to attack the knight the
knight swaps for the bishop b5 you
suggested the idea and it was a
necessity from black's perspective and
here king b1 was played it's the
kind of move you play because you don't
like your king close to the center and
you protect this pawn but i'm starting
to wonder if this is where neil's lost
thread because he needs an initiative he
can't just make quiet moves because then
black's extra pawn will make itself felt
and by playing king b1 we saw that
report castled and now knight to e4 but
that looks like the culprit so i see the
bar going down so at this moment there
was a better option for
nils which is strange because knight e4
looks
so attractive a move at first sight
jumping the knight into that outpost and
trying to control some of the
the dark squares but let's see what
could be
um
what could be a better a better idea for
white here
well the dark squares and i mean 94
looks so good
maybe
this night move to open up these dark
squares and then open up
the default threatening to jump into a5
trying to get rid of that strong bishop
on b7 and as well opening the d-file as
you just out
even a move like that like i feel like
it makes sense um but you mentioned how
black at some point wants to make a
d-pawn move if you can get away with it
i'm wondering if you can in this
position because if i play say d5 and
you take on poisson then i'm able to
take with my bishop in there you see the
eval bar is saying okay i'm feeling this
a little bit more for black my bishop is
out i'm happy about that so i could see
why
niels would not want to play this move
knight to b3 because you are retreating
and then you allow d5 but for some
reason white is able to press from here
but queen a7
it looks nice but this black queen can
always drop back to c7
yeah so let's have a look what went
wrong after knight e4 which looks like
such a natural move richard played king
b8 which is always a move i think you
want to make as black get the king out
of trouble and also prepare for the rook
to join the game via c8 which it does
and now
niels activating the rook which wasn't
doing much any longer on the g file
uh
doubling on the d file putting some
pressure already on that pawn
on d7
another finally developing the last
piece bishop e7 played by the richard
report
and that's the drawback fiona of rook to
d1 is that the rook on g1 kept the
bishop at bay because g7 would fall and
so i think this move we see that's
really where the evaluation bar goes in
black's favor because after this move
rook c3 the queen went to a4
and now there's a rook trade being
offered trades help the side that's a
head material generally speaking and
black is up a pawn and so niels went
rook back to d3 so black's pieces have
improved while white's pieces have just
shuffled
yeah so the last few moves have really
not uh gone niels grandilius's way
and now the question is uh we see the
bar is dropping into the the white camp
so
what is the continuation
for black
i always wonder as well black has the
bishop pair white has the night pair is
there ever any case in which you want to
to give up at any concrete reasons if
you take on e4 then suddenly uh white
has to recapture with the queen and that
queen is pinned to the knight can we can
we take advantage of that that pin in
any way
uh you spotted it and i love how you
hand it to me on a silver platter the
knight is pinned so you can just play
rook takes c2 and unfortunately for
white b3 it disconnects the queen from
the rook but it also connects it in a
different way with queen takes a2
checkmate so rook takes c2 would be a
free pawn there and that's you can't
afford to give up that pawn if you're
white your king is now in grave danger
and black would just be
crushing
but this is the first line right
black can currently take on e4
i think he will which
which looks crushing and it looks like
richard report is well on on the way to
get a second
uh win here so we'll keep an eye on it
he still has plenty of time on the clock
but uh bishop takes the e4 followed by
rook c2
is a first line and well we'll we'll see
if witcher goes for it but it looks like
this might just be winning for now
let's check back in with the bird's eye
view maybe it's time to to take another
quick look at our world champion magnus
carlson who was fighting in a slightly
inferior position against duda last time
we checked in there
sure um it looks like things have
changed quite a lot in this game between
duda and magnus so
pawns have been traded it's a
new state of affairs here where white's
d5 pawn is potentially vulnerable it's
isolated but white black's king isn't
exactly thrilled where it is because you
gave up one of your most important pawns
the golden pawn we call that f pawn so
as we
go back a few moves to see how we got
here
it was this choice by magnus rook b2 the
queen is needed to defend the rook here
because the black queen's attacking so
he went brookby to a distraction tactic
and this trade fiona while you know it's
a rook for a rook we could see that
white's pieces are the ones that
benefited most from that trade
yeah
absolutely and we're still i mean one of
the first thing i'm
seeing when when i look at this position
is the bishop on f8 which we talked
about last time we came here that bishop
still not doing anything and still
standing passively on f8 and i i think
the question is is this passive defense
going to hold
for magnus we see um
jan kristoff trying to take now the c
file and f5 a very committal decision by
the world champion
i i
i like it i like the spirit of it he
says if i just sit and do nothing i'm
going to be worse forever and we're
talking about when to show restraint and
when to lash out i don't think this is a
bad moment to do so pawn takes f5 would
be a huge blunder because knight f4 and
the knight e2 is a monster fork of all
of
white's pieces that would not be good
somehow it's not completely losing but
it's obviously bad for white
but that's why
uh yes exactly so that's why
g3 was uh played and after pawn takes
knight takes queen back to e8 which is
extremely important defending this
knight on g6 because there were
discoveries knight f6 check in
particular to
open up the diagonal and get this knight
so queen eight played attacking the
knight on e4 protect the knight on g6
and honestly the bishop on f8 isn't the
happiest piece but it's getting the job
done defending black's king c7 is a
weakness but the rook on e7 covers it
while being aggressive on the e-file so
maybe this looks promising for white but
in reality black is just doing okay yeah
and i really like that liberating shot
by magnus f5 which is a move i don't
know if duda had
anticipated it i think it's a move
that's very easy to miss when you're
white here you don't expect black to
move one of the pawns
in front of his king especially not one
that opens up that diagonal upon that's
at first sight undefended so a nice shot
i think by by magnus carlsen
just the shot that he needed it would
seem and then we get to this position
where duda is back on the clock but i
think magnus is probably feeling much
more comfortable with the current
position than he was before now that he
was able to break that pawn chain down
yeah so still
maybe a small edge for duda but
plenty more work but a game where i
think uh duda will still continue to
price magnus is not completely safe
just yet and we see the polish the
polish fighter there on the on the
camera let's come back here in a short
while
go back see maybe if vidit has made a
move let's have a quick look at the the
bird's eye view and with actually found
rook uh rook f6 so kudos to him
wow
i mean that
i mean rook takes b7 was
very impressive by dubai and just the
way he's been playing has been great but
rook f6 i mean that is
what a move and it
might be the only move and it's just
such a hard thing to do is play a rook
lift
you still need your rook to protect this
bishop
but something about this rook being on
f6 it does help out because now knight
takes b7 as a threat remember the
problem everyone was that after knight
b7 check on b5 king f7 the rook doesn't
defend the bishop but if that rook had
been on f6 to start with this tactic
never works out the king could have even
slid to f8 but has the f7 score with the
rook protecting so rook f6 is a
brilliant move by vidit protecting the
bishop and now really attacking the rook
and of course in
typical dubai he says please have my
rook my queen will venture into the to
the game over here your king is still
unsafe this has been an awesome battle
between two fantastic players
what a game robert if it were you
would you there taking the rook on b7
so part of this question is how much i
trust dubov and it's important when
you're sitting at the board not to be
gushing over how strong your opponent is
you need to be skeptical every single
turn that while it may look like a good
move it may not be so let's put in our
calculation caps and i'll try to do this
a bit in our head i know it's going to
be difficult for our viewers but this is
what vidiq is doing right now so knight
takes b7
that is taking a rook and for a knight
so the first question is should
duboff take back on b7 right away or
should he throw in the move knight takes
f5 because that hits the queen on e7 the
knight on b7 will still be
under attack and i can take it next move
so these are the things the players are
thinking about
or is the queen just gonna take on b7
hitting the rook in the corner still
putting pressure on this e4 pawn
there is a lot to take in here and
that's why both players have been
spending some time but fiona
duvall continues to play more quickly
and even more so than the position on
the board his time advantage could play
the role of being the winning idea yes
and we see that the clocks have now been
updated i think we're looking at the
correct clock times we can see the 12 on
with its clock and the two in front
of duboff's time at 12 minutes to go
we're only on move 22 so reddit still
has to make 19
moves 19 moves robert in this position
is a hell of a lot of moves
only after that will he get an extra 50
minutes but that's not where his focus
is right now i think the focus is to
survive this position uh until move 40
and it is just so scary i mean
of course you kind of feel like you have
to consider taking the rook and maybe it
is the best move but it's
so scary there's so many things to
consider if you don't take the rook then
what else do you do
no you have to i think you have to and
you're the point you're making fiona
black has to
be brave
take a deep breath in and take that rook
take the work think later
yeah and and i think the lines will
actually transpose to one another so if
knight takes b7 i i know i'm making
people do this and it's a bit difficult
i'll put on the board in a second and
once we
trade here and the queen lands on b7
the rook will have to come to d8 because
it's under attack and this pawn is
falling but because the rook is on f5 at
that moment it will come to e5 so i'll
put that all on the board now that i
drew a bunch of arrows we get this
situation where the rook is under attack
let's move it here rook takes e4 it's
important to note the king has luffed so
there's no checkmate on the back rank
and after rook e5 like oh
rookie 5 apparently somehow doesn't work
because queen c6 check and this king is
in trouble all these pawns are hanging
so if you don't have
brook here i
oh my gosh do you throw in this check
not just because you like giving checks
but because it frees up the d8 square
for the king
madness
like this check here and now king d8 so
there's no captures on h6
like
that's the thing right with the
evaluation bar when you know you're okay
and then what we make a draw after queen
a8
what's the story
maybe queen eight i mean i'm looking at
bishop b5
threatening checkmate look this is
so oh
okay look at this i just saw this in my
head bishop b5
you're threatening checkmate right
if queen d6
queen e8 followed by rook takes e8 would
be checkmate but after queen e8 rook
takes e8 is checked to the king of h2
because rook takes e8 is checkmate
thanks to the bishop on b5 but that you
can't do it it's not letting me because
the king is in check
that is how games are saved
this is an unbelievable position
absolutely incredible stuff
and provided has 10 minutes on the clock
to figure out he has taken the rook on
b7 as so maybe we'll see some of these
lines unfold that's absolutely
unbelievable i saw someone in the chat
tell me which the ten minutes he's going
to get with it well he will still get 10
10 additional minutes for minutes from
the increment that is absolutely true
but that means that vidit has 20 minutes
on the clock basically for the remaining
19 moves robert that's an average of one
minute per move which isn't a lot for
this position
i'm just in disbelief i mean if we just
go down that very
this variation one more time and it's
not forced right it's not like knight
takes f5 has to be played but from a
distance it's so difficult to see that
rook d1 check is the saving idea but it
makes perfect sense and because as we
saw queen c6 check you can't block with
the queen this rook is gone if you go
rook to d7 here queen g6 check still is
the problem and if a king d8 queen g8
check look at this issue queen e8 would
force a trade of queens but if you take
on e8 the rook comes back you're safe
but the queen is protected not there
there on g8 the bishop protector let me
take your rook first your queen can't
take because there's a pin so white
would end up a piece ahead oh this is
such a beautiful beautiful game full of
rich tactics fiona it may end in a draw
but this is why i say draws aren't the
problem i don't care about the result i
love the way this game is being played
if vidit holds he's a hero if this game
is a draw it still was a brilliant fight
but between two brilliant players
i mean i think this has to be
the most exciting game we've seen so far
i know yesterday we had some early g4
but the lines we have seen here
sometimes and i think a lot of people
who just gloss over the game
afterwards they miss all of these
beautiful
tactical lines i think this discovery
check has got to be one of my favorites
and
yeah just simply stunning stuff here in
this game
i think we have to show it again knight
takes f5 rook takes f5 rook takes e4
rook do you want check needed to clear
the square for the king king goes out
rookie five only decision to be made
because there's a pin you don't want to
lose your queen it's a rookie five queen
is there another check queen aa check
you will not play rook d8 i don't think
because then your king doesn't have an
escape so after queen aa check the king
has to go to d7 and then you're fielding
checks like bishop b5 check the king is
still
running up the board king e6 i think is
king d6 there's queen to c6 check mate
so the king runs to e6 and after a move
like rookie five the king steps in the
center you win king of the hill i don't
really know why this position is just
equal it still is completely wild to me
even queen c a check here where's that
king going is it going back this way is
it going here no i don't think king f6
queen h8 check look oh my gosh i mean i
guess it's still equal because king f5
because of course this position is equal
right fiona this is a dead draw no
questions asked oh my goodness
oh my god i mean this game it's the gift
that keeps on giving it's never we think
we're getting to the end of some crazy
lines and there's
always more and the players have so
little time to figure everything out i
mean once again we are seeing these
lines here we are seeing the zero zeros
but the players
imagine having to figure out all these
lines in your head over the board you're
not allowed to put them on the board and
figure it out that way
i would you know what i don't think this
game is gonna drunk end in a draw what
do you think robert
i could see everyone blundering like i
mean it's not even a blunder at this
point it's just such a complex position
and if a mistake happens it's not like
oh wait your queen was under attack you
left it there come on do better this is
so difficult to calculate even with the
eval bar off to the side right the
engine says zeros it's an equal position
but it's not equal in terms of just
being rook and pawn against rook and
pawn let's make a draw shake hands this
is so difficult to see all through these
variations and duval is he's looking he
doesn't look pleased he has to just
glance at did it and that was probably a
glance of did it well done i don't see a
way to break down your defenses here i
was just gonna say absolutely i mean
kudos to to vid it and maybe i'm gonna
retract what my what i just said a
second ago i do actually think that
it has great chances of saving this game
the way he's defended so far has been
really impressive you get hit by rook
takes b7 you have to collect yourself
maybe you saw it coming maybe you didn't
you realize you cannot take the rook
then you have to find what according to
a chat was the only move rook f6
ignoring the rook on b7 but trying to
defend against all the different threats
that white has
then white goes rook b1 says
take my rook if anyway if you don't take
it i'm going to crush you so with it
goes ahead takes on b7 then finds rook
d8 and now well robert are we going
actually to go down these crazy lines
i think we are and i think perhaps dubov
when he saw this position in his head
when he went queen to b1 he thought that
this position might be winning and now
he's looking like oh wait a second
there's this rook d1 check and that's
not to be critical of duval's
calculation ability it is extremely
difficult and let's go back a few moves
and to show exactly why this is so
difficult there is a knight on d4 so
even if your rook gets to d8
there's a piece in the way there's a
queen on b1 there's a rook on e1 so
seeing that the saving move is rook to
d1 with check like think about that that
seems ridiculous and these players are
superstars they can work through all of
the most complex positions but it just
there's something there's a block there
you don't see it coming and now that we
get here we have rook takes e4 on the
board the only move available is rook d1
check so that part will be easy for
vivid to see because he's gotten this
far rook d1 check if you need to vacate
the d8 square for the king the king may
still go on a journey it will be a wild
ride but rook d1 is a necessity right
here right now
what a game and what a defense
uh by visited really incredible stuff we
see world champion magnus carlsen
his attention has also been caused by
the game standing there kivitzing from
behind vivid shoulder before returning
to his own
game so yeah rook d1 is the only move
here but i agree with you robert i think
with it he's found everything until here
and he will figure out he needs to free
up that square for them
for his king
and did it thinking here and i'm
doubting that he's thinking about this
move so much as the follow-up sequence
because rook do you want check that move
will be played i mean and there it is
you know rook d1 check but i actually
when i was quickly initially going
through the moves i was like oh rookie
five and then we saw the engine go up
and the players they're not just making
moves off-handedly they need to think
and so rook d1 check is just step one
of the crazy positions we're about to
see king h2 is forced rook e5 is forced
if the queen goes to a check king d7 is
forced after bishop b5 check king e6 is
forced you get the picture i'm just so
excited by this game because we don't
get to see this kind of tactical melee
all the time sometimes positions are
locked up we get berlin end games but
these players are holding nothing back
and again if this game ends in a draw i
am okay with it i know people think at
this point that i'm against the draw i'm
against the draw offer in positions that
have life in them this game is
i mean one of my favorite games i've
ever come to though
i mean it's so so exciting i think maybe
a draw would even be the fair result
of this game with daniel playing such
flamboyant attacking chance but vidit
defending perfectly
until now uh there's a question actually
um from our producer he's asking what
about bishop f1 here
well i don't like taking my pieces out
of the attack but not that this is
necessarily a bad move but you're
retreating so rook e5 now my king can
escape to the f7 square because your
bishop is no longer covering the
diagonal so i do think that this still
holds some serious attacking chances uh
from white's perspective but i don't
think black is so concerned about
getting checkmated so it you can tell by
the eva bart's not that bad for white uh
black is slightly better but i just
don't like walking into a pin if i don't
need to and duboff came to the same
conclusion went king h2
vivid played rook e5
and now well
duboff has a few options here
most of them will chase out the black
king that will go on a run
but it looks like uh it looks like the
black king is always going to find a
safe square according to the engines
robert what we are going to do we are
going to go on the final quick break
before the first time control will leave
this board for you guys to follow it
during the break and we'll be back in
just a few minutes just a few minutes to
calm down gather our thoughts and we'll
be back with the stunner of the game
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to an explosive
third round here at the tata steel chess
tournament robert we are looking at the
bird's eye view and
although some pieces have come off we
still have some absolutely fascinating
games left
we most certainly do and i've been
scolded by our producer that i can't
just stay and talk about do buffers
visit forever even though i want to it
has been a fantastic struggle between
two great players but we haven't given
much attention to yes apenko versus
karjakin and that position actually is
very very interesting to me where
black's queen that's karjakin's queen is
all the way on the rim over there and
white has this extra pawn if we cut the
board in half from the e to the h file
so i think that white's position is
better yes panko has his rooks on the
central files here he's got the extra
pawn as mentioned from the e through the
h file that can even go up to e5 if
black's not careful but you can't rush
that decision because e5 immediately
immediately allows excuse me knight d5
and that's something we've talked about
in several games today right like this
e5 immediately the knight comes to d5 so
as soon as a pawn leaves
the opponent will try to take advantage
of that square
so instead of that e5 which indeed looks
tempting at first sight but seems
premature andrei went knight f3 hitting
the black queen which instantly went to
g3 well it went there instantly because
it didn't have much too much of a choice
no it did not and the queen is actually
very annoying here because bishop takes
h3 becomes a threat the f4 pawn is in
some danger so i expect
the move knight e5 to be there he goes
there he goes uh it is a queen trade by
force and after the queen trade in here
everything is happening that once this
queen trade happens
we see a dynamic where this knight on e5
is happy the rook on d1 can maybe land
on d6 the c6 pawn is a bit of a target
black should be okay with best play
maybe rook e7 or something like that is
required but it's just uncomfortable
to have this position from karjakin's
point of view because his pawns are
weaker and even though he's holding
everything together for the moment it
could collapse
really with one inaccuracy as you
mentioned the other day though if there
is one man who's uh excellent oh and
sorry
but we've had a result the clash between
young kristoff duda and magnus carlsen
has ended in a draw
maybe we can go there we'll watch the
player uh have the brief post game
analysis and maybe we can quickly go
through the final moves there
we saw a trade of rooks
and then a queen trade was offered by
duda and
magnus said no because if that knight
comes to b5 you lose c7 so it was queen
c8 and it's a move we talked about a
long time ago fiona and it was the final
move that was necessary from magnus
because that's the move that led him to
a draw c6 d takes draw agreed i'm
actually okay with this one everybody
because after queen takes c6 the queens
come off i can see very clearly and also
explain quite easily why this game is
completely even it's a three on two
majority from the f3h files black has
this d-pawn it's a past pawn if you will
but it's not going anywhere so both
kings will come towards the center
there's no way to make progress the draw
agreed
i'm okay i'm fine with it
that's great to hear and i was actually
laughing because i don't know if you
watched magnus pull on his mask
but we're two years into a pandemic and
there's some excellent photos out there
one is by eric rosen from the world cup
and another by leonard oates i think
from the world rapid and blitz
with magnus having the mask all over his
face and i don't know if anyone caught
it but once again like it seems like he
puts it all over the face and then pulls
it down
and so an interesting and interesting
handling of that situation but back to
uh yes panko and karjakin
just for one final time to have a quick
look at that position where indeed uh
yes panko did play knight e5 and the
queens came off on e3
chess is frustrating because in moments
like this it looks like white is just so
much better every single piece more or
less looks better for white and yet the
uh engines like uh yeah
half a pawn better that's it that's all
you get i think from a practical point
of view the position is very promising
for yesopanko karjakin as you were just
mentioning he
really of anyone on this planet if i
want somebody to defend this position
he's very high up there
and he did great i mean a couple of days
ago against fabiano carrana he was on
the back foot
and did a tremendous job of that it is
not a fun position it is especially not
a front position with only
six minutes on the clock but he is the
man for the task so we'll come back here
in a bit for now let's go back to the
bird's eye view we have five games still
going i saw someone in the chat say
report is winning and oh my god look at
that
evaluation bar it is the most leaning
bar we have so let's go there because i
think that game is about to be over
yeah there could be a handshake any
second in this one and the reason why is
the last move played by report it's
nothing spectacular he moved his rook
from one side of the board to the other
and
now he's threatening a checkmate so as
we bring that up for you the queen is
coming to c3 you don't like this if
you're white seeing a bishop on a3
controlling the dark squares b2 is the
mating square and i actually don't see
any way for
niels to to deal with this thread and
queen e1 that takes away the c3 square
so at least there's no checkmate
immediately but fiona are you ready for
this let me know when you're ready
are you ready
i don't think everybody
won
an ancient
play by richard report work h1 is on the
board today is tactics extravaganza
and rook h1 what a move
if niels takes the queen on b4
rook takes d1 is checkmate
and
if
instead niels takes on h1 then once
again queen c3
will lead
to the same checkmate
yeah that's a distraction tactic i've
ever seen one
white's problems are endless there's a
king on b1 a bishop on a3 back rank
checkmate just because you pushed upon
doesn't mean that your king will find
any space in a forward rank so
brooke h1 show that again instant replay
bam rook h1 take that rook i dare you in
comes the queen this round has been
so so fun not for neils grandilius but
for me as a commentator and hopefully
for you as well fiona it's been
such a fun round i couldn't agree more i
mean we've been absolutely spoiled today
i think we're going to to stay here
because we will see a handshake within
within moments here there is simply no
defense work h1
a fantastic tactic by richard report was
about to score his second consecutive
win robert
impressive way to rebound after losing
the first game against duda he is now
going to win his second straight game
and that's the thing about rapport he
can win against anybody he can also
sometimes have some inconsistent chess
and then struggle in certain games but i
love the way he plays the game
always full of unique ideas as early as
the first few moves of the game and he
found rook h3
rook h1 to end this game it's just
amazing how all the focus was on the
queen side where the uh both kings are
and then the winning idea was bringing
that rook all the way to the king side
to distract the enemy queen and deliver
a checkmate and i cannot hear wait to
hear from richard report we see niels
try rook g1 but that's only going to
delay his fate because after rook takes
g1
white is faced with the exact same
problems we see richard take to work
reels neil's recapturing with the queen
and here it comes queen c3 and that
white king
is
done and we see the resignation by niels
glendalius who could not stop the
checkmate on b2 what a fantastic game by
richard report uh robert
i mean seriously that was well done by
him there was some initial pressure he
had to deal with he did take a pawn for
his troubles and then he was able to
convert with what seemed like relative
ease and unfortunately for nils
grandilius it doesn't seem like it's
been his tournament uh in round one he
lost that game in round two yesterday
against sam shanklin he was in trouble
and here in game three with the white
pieces he was on his back foot
throughout a report i mean that is such
a good showing by the hungarian super
grand master he is an awesome awesome
chess player absolutely and nietzsche as
well he was one of our early leaders
here
last year then the second half didn't go
so well for him let's hope that niels
can bounce back he is of course capable
of
beating any of these guys so we hope
that tomorrow there was
one final game before the first rest day
let's hope he can bounce back soon we
are back in the bird's eye view
robert uh what do you think about that
that game between uh duboff and vinnette
i i love that game but i'm actually
going to choose a different game because
i see the eval bar go sky high oh my god
andre yes panko and the reason why is i
think this is a blunder from afar i'm
pulling up the game here that karjakin
he made the move rook to b8 maybe this
was a commentator's curse fiona we said
if anyone can handle the pressure it is
karjakin i think what's about to happen
is a very forcing sequence knight d7
knight d7 rook d7 free piece thank you
very much not so free rook takes b2
hitting your bishop outside past pawn
with a rook behind it we love those but
here's the problem fiona bishop d3 after
a3 there's bishop c4 and after a2 i am
going to take your pawn but first i'm
going to steal your f7 pawn with check
so no matter where your king goes into
the corner over to f8 i will only then
take your pawn on a2 you bring your
second rook into the game and not lucky
but good for white is that rook g3
exists protecting attacking white's up
one pawn will win more and that's the
game if yes panko finds the sequence
and i think he will because if we go
back to the current position and this is
yet another yet another incredible game
we're witnessing here um
i think
you don't really
what are the alternatives what's the
alternative to defend upon on b2
you are always i think is right you're
always going to try and make knight d7
work and in fact the line that we were
showing i think is not so hard could it
be that from a distance sergey missed
that f7 would be hanging with jack i'm
not sure
but i think that's part of it fairly
certain that uh yes panko will figure
this out
i think that's exactly it that in this
continuation here a3 a2 you think of
bishop takes a2 but bishop f7 check
first is the issue and you can try to
pin
the bishop in one way or another but the
rooks will just move to safety and
you're not actually getting what you
want for example after rook two b3 here
uh i believe that the rook can just move
because this rook defends it right so
it's
not going to happen for karjakin a
shocking mistake from someone of his
caliber but it is a a mistake from a
distance not just oh he didn't see his
bishop was hanging of course he saw that
but what he i think
is forgetting about is the capturing of
seven with dave he goes robert sorry to
interrupt you but just as you're talking
we're at the close-up of the bishop on
d7 which was captured by andreas sipango
we're going down this line rook takes b2
has just appeared on the board
and well i think yes panko he's not
going to miss his chance here
how do you find cardiac's poker face
because to me this looks like somebody
who knows he just made a mistake but i
also know for a fact he made a mistake
right yeah it looks like my own poker
face in existence
oh yeah this is a situation where he's
not bluffing anybody bishop d3 to c4 not
difficult to see right now i think
unfortunately for sergey he was feeling
the pressure he knew his position was
worse and for andre it's a gift that he
was able to earn by putting that
pressure on karjakin it was a big
mistake one that we don't see from a
2750 player very often but it's because
karjakin was just feeling that
discomfort move after move he lacked
space his position had no counter play
and that's where he ended up making the
last mistake it seems with rook to b8
and here comes the bishop to c4 and we
talked about uh karjakin's face which is
sort of giving it all away but also
jesse panko i think he didn't need that
helping hand of seeing carriacking's
face he spotted this he will spot bishop
d3 i'm fairly certain we can see his
body language
this is the body language of a player
who smells he knows my opponent messed
up i have a chance here he is going to
get his first win i believe and what has
started it's been for a yes panko
and maybe we can keep karjakin on screen
for a bit but i have to bring up the
board between vitid and dubov i mean
look at this game here and he
oh
what
oh maybe this rook just comes back in
time and goes to a1 but oh
i mean maybe
maybe that's
also a solution i was about to change
games here but a3 rook to d1 a2 rook to
a1 and
this also looks good might just be
sufficient yeah
uh but i need to bring up this game here
i i can't help myself there is a king on
f5 because we saw all these checks
and here
f3 was played and immediately it's
losing for white
right this is the game
this is the game and oh my god i think
we have to go there on camera as well so
we have
daniel and visit
oh my goodness robert
yeah i mean this king is going to take
this pawn and unfortunately for dubov i
don't think he has enough checks the
king may in fact walk all the way to c1
take a walk on the wild side here hide
in enemy territory where it's actually
at its safest
and the checks run out and that means
the game is vetted
that i mean out of all the possible
scenarios
that is not one i had envisioned but
that goes to show what happens when you
put on resistance i think especially
when you play someone like duboff
someone like dubaf is likely sometimes
to overextend his hand take too many
risks want the full point too much and
that can backfire
vidit has held his nerve throughout and
it looks like he is going to score maybe
the first uh well no not the first black
win because that uh was reported just
now today looks like it's gonna be a
good day for the players with the black
pieces wow wow wow and i have to state
this very clearly that at this point in
time we see that the engine says it's
zeros and it's equal but that is i mean
where what is the move because rook
takes e5 queen takes e5 is check and
check to the queen the corner that means
the queen's come off black wins so i'm
actually not sure what the move is at
this point it's very tricky but i know
for certain it wasn't this because as
viz king comes to e4 white's king at the
end of this game is not going to go here
when they put the
kings in the center it's going to be a
black king on e5 a white king on d4
signaling a victory for gujarati who
started one after the two against the
american players now with the black
pieces going two and a half at a three
and i just wanna say that when you know
this whole uh growth of the game of
chess online content creators there's
been many fans for many people and
sometimes there are people who
mistake popularity for strength there's
no mistaking this for vida guzrati he is
reaching his highest rating ever if he
is able to put nerves aside his king is
on e4 and win this game he will be
ascending towards that 2740 territory he
is proving his worth as a player his
strength as a player and he's also a
fantastic person so that doesn't hurt
either
absolutely and i'm sure he has that
india number one spot uh in in his
sights he could
be dethroning vishyana and soon who's
been holding that spot for
god knows how long forever it feels like
um and with it well he's been given a
check from a8 but it's actually funny
this game started out with viditz king
being in such a precarious situation and
suddenly look at duboff's king on h2
as soon as the checks run out that king
in h2 is gonna be in a world of hurt
i mean i'm drawing the arrows of where
that king has gone like that that's what
just happened in this game is the king
with rook bishop queen staring at it the
king just walked up the board it will
continue king e3 queen f3 check only
legal move king d2 and there goes that
king to c1 where it finds shelter at
long last and it's over there's nothing
that dubois can do about it this king is
reaching the other side and you don't
get to promote your piece but that will
promote vidit the two half of the three
and he will be the leader that people
are chasing
yes because the other well the other
co-leaders drew their their game between
themselves so vetted uh it looks like a
couple more checks and he will take the
sole lead of the status deal chess
tournaments of course only three rounds
in
but what a start to the game for him
what a turnaround on the other hand
daniel duboff uh it will be a
devastating loss for him
oh my goodness and i i just am realizing
i think
where i mean i know when the mistake
happened but what the mistake was and
oh my gosh this game was just full of
tactics everywhere but if we go back to
the moment where he went f3 and ben
feingold would say never play f3 but
queen c8 check king takes e4 that is not
possible here because queen g4 check and
after the king goes to d5 only move
queen c4 check not queen takes d1 but
queen c4 check king d6 queen c6 is mate
i've been thinking about the position
trying to figure out what it could have
been because i mean f3 seemed necessary
there wouldn't seem to be other options
this is it that was the moment queen c8
queen g4 queen c4 queen c6 that queen
does a backwards zorro slicing through
the position and delivering a checkmate
what a checkmate two extra rooks for
black but the king
gets trapped on d6 i mean this game
robert
i have never seen as many
different tactical and checkmating
patterns in one game as this one but as
it happened the black king is safe
it is two squares away
i cannot believe it
oh my gosh i mean this game
makes people love and hate chess at the
same time
right like it was a game full of
beautiful tactical sequences and that's
why i always recommend you get a
notebook out you start looking through
the game moves you start writing your
notes your annotations what you think
could have or should have happened
because when we just see the engine off
the side and saying that move is correct
that move is correct that move is
correct we take for granted how
difficult those choices were that's why
we play the game that's why people sit
and think and spend
10
20 30 40 an hour on the clock just for a
single move because of all of these
possibilities did it for rook f6 way
back when to survive that attack and to
get his king out here wide open but for
the win i'm seriously so impressed with
vita gujarati what a player he is and
what a performance he's having in the
early stages of vikanze indeed and i see
in the chat drunken name is asking you
to please take a deep dive on this game
well i'm fairly certain
this will be our
rapid recap later for the game of the
day but robert it will be a tough job
for us to pack into 10 minutes what
happened in this game
nobody's going to hold me back i don't
care what time frame you give me this
game is wonderful i mean i'm just so
excited by
all the great chess we've seen and we've
talked about this a couple of times
blunders inaccuracies how to phrase
certain things and this game i i'm i'd
be wrong to use the word blunder
anywhere i think that vidit's defense
the wonderful defense that he showed in
this game has earned him
the point that he is going to obtain i
mean seriously to find rook f6 to make
duboff question his entire attack in the
way that he did and look at the
concentration on his face right now he
is locked in he knows that the win is
just a few moves away he is not going to
let this slip
i mean also bishop c6 so dubois not
giving a check the king was going to
hide but now it is wit its turn i was
just saying a minute ago that king on h2
and duboff
uh
he knows
that things have gotten out of control
and it will be really a tough day for
him he played
such an interesting game so many
exciting sacrifice ideas and um yeah
always sad to see him like this but
kudos to it it is his turn now robert so
how do we proceed as black do we start
giving some checks of our own
i think he should and the reason why the
bishop came to c6 is because without the
bishop there this queen would come to
score like d6 and there'd be a check on
the second rank and this king would be
in trouble but after g3 the bishop can
slide back to g2 to defend the white
king which is now in danger i just don't
see how
do well can follow things up let's say i
play queen e5 check
you have to play g3 because king h3 rook
to h1 is a quick checkmate so g3 has to
be played and i'm gonna try to find the
best way forward here i'm sure there are
many good moves like you could probably
even take pawns on c3 and start mopping
things up but i want to go for this king
and i'm looking across the board i'd
like to get my queen in here maybe g4
queen h5 queen h3 just checkmate you
this way that looks pretty promising as
well
i mean that's actually how you can't
stop that how do you stop that i mean if
you give checks to the black king that
black king i guess will once again
either run to to c1
where it seems to to be safe
if you give a check from f2 i guess i
just go to c1 and oh you just want to
swap queens
i mean kingston might be better i think
objectively that is probably the case
but
when a win is clear let's just get the
win right let's get the queens off i
agreed why not
um
and what was i saying i've lost the the
thread so if you don't give a check on
on a7
after g4
then you have to somehow cover the
square on h5
how do you do that bishop e8 there will
be another checkmate in coming here i
guess after rook d2 g3 is going to fall
and so yeah this looks like it's lights
out
yeah no it's uh any and even here if we
don't have checkmate we could trade
queens again so i can't complain for
vidit here there's just
too many many possibilities but i like
what he's doing he is spending his time
right now he knows he's
has the winning position that's not
in doubt whatsoever but you want to end
the game now because if the game
continues let's say white got to play
these two moves g3 and bishop g2
now it's like okay white's king is safer
black's king can always hide down in c1
but now you have to think you have to
calculate let's just end this game give
no hope to our opponent score
that full point the chat is reminding us
that we are only still on move
35 we are only seven minutes away from
the first time control uh maybe we stay
here with the camera and very quickly
just
look around see if we've have time
scrambles going on elsewhere i think
this is the big one but
it's just putting the finishing touches
on it
and let's check on the yestapanko uh
game really quickly just see how this is
developed black has pushed pawns up the
board the white king venturing over to
the queen side over here it would be
kind of funny if somehow there was like
a fortress here i mean like i i don't
think there is because the king just
runs over and that will do something
about this rook but if somehow karjakin
had seen
all the way down and it wasn't a depth
issue it was on us you know but i do
think
this is just winning for white and of
course bishop d3 to c4 which we
mentioned earlier was possible so uh yes
panko has this one under control also
only two moves to go here until the time
control so that's not a problem what
about fabiano against shankland i guess
they made the time control
or they just made the time control so
we'll we'll come back here in a second i
suggest we stay with duboff
and vidit
because i i expect this one to be over
very very soon
there it is
there it is
what a game
really ending it in style
you know i wouldn't be surprised after
that whole knight b8 knight d7
after those moves maybe that was a
mistake i'm not sure but i wouldn't be
surprised if vida played a perfect game
after that moment funnily enough uh john
rambo is just writing in a chat with it
found all the top engine uh moves
i okay yeah thank you uh john you know
i'm sure your name is john you know just
like everyone on the internet never lies
about their identity but
i i think that that was kind of clear
actually like when he found
every single move first taking on g3
playing e4 knight c5 rook f8 uh and then
rook f6 later in the game i really feel
like he played a perfect game
after the opening stage
yeah i mean i'm seeing comments in the
chat but it's immortal i'm very curious
to hear from him after the game and
there we see the handshake duboff
stopping the clock
in resignation and wow robert i think we
have an early candidate already it's
only round three but for game not only
of the round but of the tournament
early candidate for game of the year
that was so electric i mean throughout
the whole game it was dubob's position
rook takes b7 don't forget he sacrificed
a rook and he sacrificed a pawn early in
the game he put his knight on the rim
that was captured double pawns
everything about this game was special
and some would say it's unfortunate that
the game was spoiled by a mistake i
don't think it was spoiled i mean i
don't expect any result i don't expect
players to find perfect moves but this
game was so
so entertaining you can't ask for more
as a chess fan and i right now am a
chess fan i know i'm commentating i'm
doing my best to give you the best
analysis i can but i am a fan of both of
these players they just played their
hearts out
i mean absolutely incredible stuff here
we saw duboff after the handshake and
not too interested in a inner person in
discussing the ins and outs of this game
he will be very disappointed but what a
date is forbidden and his numerous uh
fans i hope we will be hearing for him i
think we're gonna go uh on a very quick
break catch our breath for a second and
hopefully we'll hear from vivid and
we'll catch up with all the other games
in just a minute
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
apologies about that we're having some
slight issues but we'll have the
interview later we'll play it once it's
been recorded i was outside when vidit
came out from um
from the playing hall of course he's
delighted his feeling was robert that he
was lost at some point in that middle
game
yeah i don't blame him for feeling that
way and that's when calculation
supersedes feelings because vidit he
just proved it he didn't just allow
himself to
resign he said i am going to dig deep
and make duboff show me why my position
should be bad and it turns out that he
played
as accurate a game as you could possibly
ask for especially under those
circumstances i'm still in shock i tip
my proverbial cap off to vidit in fact i
shot him a message just saying i was
wowed the whole way through
such impressive stuff from him
absolutely i mean
uh with it you could see the smile on
his face when he came i think especially
when you get to play such a game from
what you feel is a losing position
you're on the back foot from the entire
game
you have little time on the clock i
think just uh so so impressive and
robert he is our new tournament leader
on two and a half
out of three let's see how is the
chasing pack getting on we see sergey
karjak in there on the camera we have
the the board as well does he have any
hopes of saving uh this time game a
piece down
no
hoping unfortunately isn't going to get
him anywhere and
the reason why is the power of the
bishop bishops are great pieces and what
white is going to do is play e5 and
bishop to e4 and this bishop will then
guard g2 it also covers the b1 square
which is extremely important so the last
move played was king to d1 because had
white star with e5 i don't think it
changes oh i suppose i don't think it
changes
okay it didn't change much the the bar
is trying to figure things out but the
point is you want to play bishop e4 so
you can trade rooks playing bishop d1
which we can do from the start tries to
offer a rook trade but the issue is not
rook takes e2 even though that might be
fine it's rook takes g2 and if you trade
on b2 you lose the game by checkmate in
one that would be quite silly and if you
trade this way you now are in a position
where black has a fortress and probably
the best white has is a force trump
bishop c2 rook g1 check you have to
block
and then rook g2 back and you just have
no moves as white so the bishop coming
to e4 is really important to defend that
g2 pawn while opening up an exchange of
rooks
yes so essie panko we thought he was
going to go the other way earlier by
bringing the bishop to c4 but it looks
like
this is going to be good enough for the
full point we can show that one more
time
uh so it was
he went one way just to go back the
other
very funny
yeah he he got this though he's got this
and let's see um i'm happy
i think today i'm gonna win our little
prediction contest i already have we
have two decisive
uh results and i think yes panko is
gonna be the third one no
we have too many
too many decisive results
wait isn't this gonna be the third one
this is gonna be the third one you oh
then we have your panko and jordan
probably let's check in with jordan we
haven't been there in a while
no we have not we'll bring up that game
as karjakin digs deep tries to find
something but jordan he is he was able
to break through and his pawn is on the
way to promoting the rook can slide to
b3 that's really important because after
a takes a takes rook b4 almost gets that
pawn but there's rook to b3 and after
rook takes c2 you don't rush your
decision to play b7 because then you
actually lose the pawn instead you play
rook to b3 and it doesn't matter what
black does c4 the rook comes up and you
are not stopping me from promoting my
pawn and actually after c3 uh
b7 you want to give a check the king
moves oh i try to cheat we promote and
both sides promote but when one side
promotes first you know you're just
going to get checkmated and here queen
g8 check will lead to a very quick
checkmate
and i think we can stay here because
we're actually seeing some of these
lines being out on the board as we speak
um pragnanda has just taken on c2
and well i expect a jordan as you just
showed us to put his own rook behind his
pawn
in this game
uh shouldn't uh shouldn't take too much
longer
no and
perhaps there's a way to win with king
marching to c7 but rook b3 is pretty
straightforward and i don't think jordan
is really calculating for the first time
he's probably double triple checking
because you don't want to spoil this and
there he goes rook b3
is on the board and i think we could
even see a resignation here quite
shortly maybe c4 will be tried um but i
think we can see also from from prague's
face he knows this one
is over
yeah maybe actually c4 just put my rook
on the first rank and that way your pawn
is never going to promote but either way
it's clear that this is going in
jordan's favor
so it looks like there's two winds on
the near horizon i don't know maybe if
we keep these players on the camera
while we move on
because prague
looks to me like he's going through the
motions and we we might see a handshake
here
in a second so maybe we'll keep him on
the camera and
do you want to check check in with
fabiano and sam
let's go there sure and the last one we
played was f6 by
sam
and it seems like
they were repeating moves for a second
here the knight came to e7
and then to f5 and the king went up and
back and all that good stuff but finally
rookie one was played and sam plays the
move f6 and after a trade of pawns this
knight is very strong on e6 safe and
sound i would be a bit concerned about a
bishop rerouting to this diagonal but
maybe sam has this worked out where he's
like
your bishop gets there my king slides
back it's not the end of the world i
am a little nervous though
yeah and sam i mean so far his choice of
this berlin end game being rewarded
fabiano not quite finding a way to break
through although i agree with you uh and
fabiano has taken
on f6 after the bishop rerouting to the
long diagonal uh there will still be
some things to
watch out for
and uh maybe back to jordan and prague
sorry for a brief moment because i
thought i made a few quick moves i think
the game is coming coming to a
conclusion as jordan has just uh pushed
b7 and that pawn is going to be a queen
uh in the next couple of moves rook e2
jack
and i guess the the white king is going
to hide
behind the black pawn
yeah that pawn is promoting for white
and black spawn is not doing the same so
unfortunately for pranganda he probably
will play c2 the rook will move
somewhere like g1 with check and then
he'll promote and that will be the game
yeah so you're then i expect the king to
go to to d6 maybe it can also come back
to to d4
um but either way there is no stopping
and the b pawn here
what would you play where would you go
with this
uh i
i don't think it really matters at this
point and it looked like he dragged it
back yeah he did to d4
and now that's a look of i'm going to
resign
from prague
i think so
and pragnanda who had a great start
he is gonna go down here against the
jordan renfrewist who who played a
really interesting opening choice
pragnanda had these goalposts pawns and
maybe we can show them again in a minute
but uh jordan just kept
piling up the pressure throughout the
game and i think pragnanda
uh cracked when he played this move f3
at looking for active counter play but
in fact getting too many weaknesses
and you push c2
rook g1 check and i think that's that
yeah there it is clock stop
a great game from jordan honestly i
think jordan should only play in vikings
because if he does that he might be the
first player to 2900 i think he elevates
his game like no other
when he's on his home turf in the
netherlands
i mean he is uh
very impressive here and
i always have to say kudos bouncing back
from a lost straight away is not easy
and it's nice to see jordan and prague
there uh both discussing at the games
quite intently
yeah it's a good learning experience for
pragmata uh of course he didn't come
here just to learn he came here to score
some points
but this game was a good illustration of
fantastic preparation by jordan he
surprised prague pragmadonda he really
played a very nice game i think he
should be happy with the way he played
and then he made this move f3 a sign
that he was uncomfortable for a long
period of time and after that jordan was
able to take that pawn secure his
advantage and then win the game and
maybe we can keep the players on the cam
while they discuss the game and bring up
the the bird's eye view so so that we
can see what has been happening here
so far so uh four games i'm sorry five
games have ended
the ran for is still showing as uh
ongoing but i think they just hadn't put
the kings in the middle yet
so we have three decisive uh results so
far
vivid in what has been just a simply
stunning game i i don't have the words
to do this game justice beating duboff
with the black pieces a rapport beating
grand dalios with the black pieces and
then for race with the result they're
just showing up uh taking out pragnanda
and robert what a day of chess is it it
has been and it's not even over yet
i mean i feel like everybody is just so
tired in like that happy way like when
you eat a good meal you're tired you
have the itis you're sitting there like
wow that was delicious and now i'm ready
for a nap or for sleep and so
we have been treated to some delicious
games thus far three decisive ones two
still going it looks like andre sepenko
is going to score victory and then that
will leave the all-american derby
between caruana and shanklin and that
one will probably go on for a decent
while
yes and we see that jordan van forest
and
prague are still
sitting at their board discussing
uh
the game
and i think it's great especially in
these pandemic times usually in vikenzi
we had a lot of boards out in the back
room and you would see a lot of the
players sit down
uh for a proper postmortem where they
can move
the pieces unfortunately we can't do
that so much now but so nice to see
the players
staying at the board for a while to
discuss
for sure and it's program's first
event here in the master's group in tata
steel
you know this won't be his last i have a
feeling he is really
showing a good start he's a very
promising player and he'll only get
better from here so jordan
played a great game showed some
excellent opening ideas and both players
will have another day another round
tomorrow
indeed and uh on the camera we've
switched over to fabiano who as you
predicted uh well he didn't drop back to
bishop we were talking about d2 but the
idea is the same to bring the bishop
onto to b2
and on to that long diagonal which is a
threat right now in this position so the
question is how do we deal with it as
black
yeah i think
i was about to say something that i was
going to regret so let me say what i was
going to say and then walk it back i was
saying oh i'm not sure it really matters
the point was getting the bishop on the
diagonal but it always matters so i'm i
mean
this bishop on d2 coming to c3 that
covers the d2 square in the event of
rook d8 like we just saw so maybe that
is important in some positions i think
in terms of the evaluation it's not too
big of a deal but the bishop did come to
b2 with check the king
i think has to go back to f7 because
oh and he did it if knight to d4 you're
walking into a pin and that will allow
white potentially to win a pawn but the
way that bar is going fiona there is
definitely more and it's probably just
like a move like rookie seven going for
this material here i think that's what
would have put black in big trouble yeah
the pawn on c7 looking very hard to
defend also the black king looking in
like quite a quite the pickle so that's
why sam decided instead of knight d4 to
go king f7 and another quick move by
fabiano rookie 3 has been played already
interesting because knight h6 check
would have uh forced king to e7 because
that king needs to stay in line with
this knight
and i guess he's saving that check
because knight on e6 in the game
position it can't go anywhere because if
that knight were to move then your
rookie 7 would check that's devastating
so he's saving up knight h6 check it is
only a single check the king would have
gone to e7 and now we have to see how
shanklin will respond
yes in this game um
we thought a second ago when we came
from here that fabi had a little
something maybe with the bishop coming
onto the long diagonal and also will we
talked about it from the start there is
a pawn majority on the king side where
fabiano has two versus one on the other
hand
there is only one pair of bishops left
and they are
opposite colored bishops so robert do
you think there are really some chances
here still for fabiano or are we closer
to equality
we're definitely close equality but
black is going to have to prove it and
may have to prove it for a decent amount
of time
these positions can be a bit frustrating
as the knight on e6 is perfectly placed
and you have to just be happy with that
you say uh that knight is good i'm gonna
keep it here it covers g5 it stops any
sort of f4 ideas if white wanted to try
to spring free a past pawn we can't
forget that the pawn structure has been
this way since the opening the berlin
that black has double pawns even though
there's a three on two for black on the
queen side you're not making a pass pawn
whereas white has a two on one so if f4
were to happen then perhaps we could get
upon going but it seems very far away at
this point
yeah i expect this game to go on for a
long time with fabiano trying everything
that's left in this position before
agreeing to a draw and sam will have to
still find some precise defending moves
shall we check in with the other
remaining game and see if andre yes
penguin is making progress
let's do just that and andre was up a
bishop and that's because sergey
sacrificed that piece it's a sacrifice
that he will likely regret because the
way this position is going we talked
about e5
and i imagine the follow will be bishop
to e4 but perhaps i'm taking things for
granted here because after e5
maybe black will play h4 or some kind of
move like this and after bishop e4 i'm
curious now if there's
something that black can do because the
threat is rook takes b2 and rook takes
a2 the importance of the bishop being on
e4 is very clear it covers the promoting
square and the square the rook would
like to go to right now
yeah i mean i really
i'm not sure what sergey can do after um
after five the bishop looks like it
cannot be stopped
looks yeah it looks lost i mean
again just to show the point that after
rook takes b2 pawn takes p2 this would
normally be menace aha
well perhaps it is menacing after all
rook takes a2 there's rook takes g2
because the bishop is overloaded it
can't take on g2 because you promote so
you have to be careful if you're white
here i guess taking on a uh b2 and then
a2 too early will allow black to survive
yeah so as always you cannot let your
guard down
uh
too soon
okay how do we avoid this then um as
white we still i guess want to start
with e5
and
this should be four
so bishop b4 was was fine that wasn't
the issue right king g7 was just a
whatever move
oh maybe we just take the pawn a2.
i'm like it's been a long day robert
it's been an emotional day we've been
through a lot of emotional
rollercoasters
yeah no this is just uh clear the rooks
both
hit the a2 pawn the rook on e2 through
the rook on b2 and that's something that
actually
i feel like
i miss sometimes that like the rook is
still attacking something through
another piece because it doesn't seem
that way but like the rook on e2
protects a2 through the rook on b2 right
yes exactly and uh just as we say that
yes panko has played
the move e5 and i think this game here
will be over very soon we can also see
it from
from sega's body language
yeah he is probably extremely
frustrated with himself that he went
rook e8 to b8 giving up the minor piece
and
andre just played a straightforward
finish to this game he brought his king
to the queen side he now is bringing his
pawn up so his bishop can go to e4 and
the a2 pawn
that one looks like a goner
and sergey unfortunately
the pawns look like they are quite
advanced but there is just
nothing he can do he wishes those pawns
were at least connected but this way i
mean the bishop
uh the light's great bishop is just
keeping everything under control
controlling uh the pawn on g2
controlling the jack on b1
and
sergey will have no no other choice but
to resign very shortly
and
oh very shortly aka no
you spoke it into existence survey
karjakin resigns and yeah he looks like
somebody who's just i mean disgusted
with his play he was worse all game he's
they're talking about it uh yes a panko
he played a nice one he had an open
advantage and
yeah you could tell that kayak's like
how did i just miss all that
yeah an unki uncharacteristic blunder
from karjakin who we hailed so many
times as
the minister of defense says he's been
dubbed
by many people before but today a very
uncharacteristic lapse by sergey kerry
and the players just
talking about the game
i do like to see the players analyze at
the board i i think
we
look to the engines as the solution but
for the process working through our
thoughts it's always nice to have uh
discussion with your opponent because
you say i was thinking of move 18 about
this choice and
then they agree with you and then you
start going down these variations and
it's a lot of fun
yes indeed and it's good to see karjakin
i think it's a tough loss because uh you
never want to you never want to lose a
game of just full stop of course but
especially not against the next
generation from your own country there's
always
slightly particular battles and
wasn't it uh actually
haryakin that he has sipenko beat in one
of these very early upset games
at some world rapid and blitz where
jesse panko took out some big names
yeah i mean yesterpanko despite his
young age he's been around for a little
while now we talk about his win over
magnus but he's taken down karjakin
before
it's not the first time it won't be the
last time unless they just don't play
each other uh that much but i it's great
to see
this young generation coming through and
for karjakin if we're being honest he
definitely cares about every event he
plays in but the big event
is this summer
absolutely when the candidates
tournament
will be coming up karyakin he has been a
challenger to magnus carlson before and
he will be looking to repeat
that feat robert of course the
candidates tournament you will be able
to follow it on chess.com and here we
see six of the players that have
qualified so far
six out of eight the grand prix coming
up
gujarati one of the players taking part
in the grand prix along with hikar and
nakamura dingley wren many big names
it'll be interesting to see that series
of tournaments come to a close so we
know who rounds out those eight players
but sir karjakin i don't care what his
rating is at the end of the event or
going into the candidates he always has
a shot in in any event he plays in he
has a style that allows him to go from
tournament to tournament and he can
withstand punches he's not always the
most aggressive player and that's been a
point of criticism of his in the past
even in his match against magnus carlsen
that he tied in classical chess before
losing in rapid but he can really roll
with the punches he can take a worse
position and neutralize his opponent's
advantage so when the candidates rolls
around duda carwana farouja rajab of
napomnishi and whoever else joins them
they all will be serious contenders
indeed there was some talk
about people being upset yes panko did
not get one of the wild cards
into the grand prix but i am sure he
will be a contender at some point and we
will be seeing him
in a candidate's tournament in the
future
i agree i think we will see him compete
you never know because the candidates
are so difficult to qualify for in the
first place let alone win
to play for the world championship but
here uh yes panko he's showing good
results and well fabiana caruana he will
be playing in the candidates that is
the big event of 2022 they're this event
they're the olympiad supposed to happen
the grand chess tour as always so we are
spoiled in terms of events but this
particular event fiona in round one
carwana had quite an advantage against
karjakin before letting it dissipate
then in round two
against vidit he had no difficulties
with black and you have to expect with
the white pieces against sam shanklin
who's off to a bit of a slow start that
fabiano wanted to win this game the more
i look at this position the more i think
that samsung is holding without too much
difficulty
yes because it is difficult to make
things happen i i guess as white without
opening up yourself too much because
there is a pawn on b3 you can never drop
that if you play
f4 at any moment which is what you want
to do to create a past pawn you will be
opening up your own king so maybe there
is just no safe way for fabiano to
really try and make progress here
yeah i could see this game petering out
very shortly
the last few movies just to show them is
the bishop went to c8 making sure that
nice the knight is
safe and sound bishop to e5 and i like
this move bishop e5 because if this rook
after rook d2 say that rook went
somewhere like this so i'm going to try
to figure out a way to make that happen
um
i don't know i don't want to make a bad
move though but let's say this rook went
to a2 then there's this tactic with
bishop takes c7 that's why you see the
bar go up so high because bishop c7
knight c7 knight d6 check
is a nasty fork that's why the rook
staying on the d file for black is so
important
yes indeed and um while we see fabiano
in the playing hall we saw that the
camera over overview the playing hall by
now is quite empty i was wondering who
was still walking around
but of course the challengers tournament
for those of you are not aware it's not
just the 14
masters playing here but also
their challengers so there's still a
couple of games going on with me fabiano
sipping
um
[Music]
sipping a cup of tea and
our producer bigfoot wants to play a
game
what drink is sam shankland having
is this actually a game that i'm
supposed to play or
yes robert you're you're cordially
invited
um what drink is sam shanklin
i think the game is we're gonna zoom in
little by little
that looks like a tea bag
and it also looks like a bottle of water
but why is that bottle of water so small
also i'm not a fan of
water bottles like this in general
because
waste of plastic and this is bad for the
environment but that definitely looks
like a bag of tea
it does i think the bag of tea is
fabiano's choice of drink while sam
shankland
is on the water so robert you are the
winner of our game congratulations
what's what's my grand prize
vic
you get to keep the mouse
and talk us through the remainder of the
game very well done
what an honor it is i just want to thank
everybody of course everybody in chat
because you know how much you all mean
to me and it would not have been
possible to win that game without you
all so give yourself a pat on the back
let's get some pogs and some what are
other things that we need to get here
i don't know i actually i'm also
an absolute boomer when it comes to
to uh to the memes but i'm sure we'll
find out in a second some pog champs i
see some
lulz i see some hearts i see some claps
uh
so yeah
the full range
this one i never even know ah that is
the pog oh my goodness
showing my ignorance
oh look what i did as soon as i say it
the chat goes wild huh
this game uh the players are still
trying to figure out if there's a way
forward um particularly fabiano his pawn
structure is better his both of his
minor pieces are extremely active here
but the knight on e6 hold the entire
position together and if you're not
careful here's how mistakes are made
let's say
white made this really bad move bishop
to h8
and the problem wait it's not bad
somehow it's not bad i was thinking that
knight f4 led to checkmate because the
king is in a bad spot and yet rookie
seven check maybe the
there's like some kind of draw here wow
and the thing cannot escape incredible
so here king to h7 and then knight e3
okay there's oh there's no perpetual the
knight just comes back to defend
there is a fun one i think that this is
a oh
it's not even a draw it's a win
and the discovery on c3
wow
chess can be fun sometimes
robert
you know what time it is
time to
take a break
you are correct once again i think we've
earned it
what do i win this time though i was
correct again i've won two games so
i think you you win
you win do you have any chocolate
some chocolate on your break
the chocolate that i already own that's
not winning something that's just eating
what's already in my plans to eat it now
oh thank you for the permission fiona i
really really appreciate it
robert enjoy the chocolate
we'll take a quick break we'll be back
in just a few minutes with the lancer
reigning game here
at karana against jankland season
bobby
yeah robert
can you read devretsky's end game manual
to us one more time yeah now we got to
get
he's different
that's what i said
i told you
let's do it all right
you know what they say though what
happens in salt lake
stays in salt lake yeah that's
cheers to my super gm friends it's been
good the world championship
on chess.com
let's do this
[Music]
yeah that was that was i was
yeah i'm great
round two bobby
yes robert
can you read devoretsky's end game
manual to us one more time yeah
you guys have to go
okay okay
i just actually didn't expect you to do
it that time but you made it funnier
like i thought he was a one-time
yeah yeah please okay okay i'm just
trying to add live with what feels
natural yeah
of course it feels natural wait so we
should expect that next yeah
just so i'm mentally prepared
what is this
it's eggs
i want an omelet with brie just [ __ ]
eat it
you eat it
we could turn a little bit on the
shoulder there
um the uh
faster card and unibrow i just want to
thank my sponsors uh very much for all
they do to to promote chess
um sounds like a great future credit
card faster card yeah wasn't it fast or
hard
[Laughter]
no no
y'all are respecting the wood a little
too much
not fast or hard bobby oh boy i i can't
be with you two anymore
oh
okay mean i think it's i think it's
hilarious and don't you think people
would would buy this
no i don't think anyone's gonna buy that
hey that's the stupidest person in my
life
well okay
i guess that's it
all right that's it that was great
keep it wrong okay
same thing
yeah and we are denny
who is that guy who's that
he didn't come in with you guys
no
we're gonna be right back
bobby yes robert
can you read deboratsky's end game
manual to us one more time yeah yeah
i'm sorry i just can't
[Music]
it's so funny
isn't it cool when i predict the moves
you're gonna say because we all see
things in the same way in the same speed
on this show
isn't that cool when we do that
it doesn't make me very happy
and let's bring up the analysis board as
we do that so if one can give us her
thoughts on the uh
on the pet shop go ahead he fun
uh well yeah actually that's a very good
question because i was firstly trying to
yeah danny
my throat's still dry
oh
you're like you've already you've had
five glasses of water okay you remember
what happened last time
my throat's still dry
you've already had five glasses of water
and you remember what happened last time
it was an accident you paid your bed
[Laughter]
you're looking fresh man all six of them
again dude your haircut just looks great
wait did we start the bit
[Laughter]
you're not supposed to say that
you're not supposed to say this if you
start the bet if black's a6 pawn was
transported let's say
goodnight guys
good night dad i've been fabi
[Laughter]
said i said it should i not said it
i think it's funny if people say good
night dad i mean bobby but we need to be
in sync
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
feed it you just beat daniel duboff in a
crazy game uh a fascinating game
let's let's start at the beginning um i
know you're a very sensible guy who me
you okay yes
why don't you castle why do you keep
your king on e8
well that's modern chess you know
but i was forced to keep my king on
eight if i would like i would love to
castle either side short or long but um
i didn't really get a chance
but now you know after i checked the
game i thought like i was pretty lost
and that's what my
feeling was but now when i checked the
game with the weak engine it said that i
played all the best moves so i'm like
very happy with about that
yeah
um
we will remember this game for a long
time because of the
the winning uh
king walk
i would say like have you ever played a
king walk like that before
well i think um the king walk was good
but i don't think that's the highlight
of the game i think um the highlight was
that he played first of all knight e3
which was a new idea
and then i did not react in the best way
but at some point i played
this f5 completely opening up my king
and then e4 knight c5 rook f8 i think
it's all the only moves according to the
weak engine and also i'm very proud of
this move
he played rook b7 gave up a rook
and it looks pretty lost because he has
so many checks but i found this rook f6
move which keeps the game going
and surprisingly it just says it's equal
and even after that then the king walk
becomes the highlight but i think
previous moves were much tougher the
king work was slightly easier
comparatively how would you rate this
game in your best games collection
um i'm a bit of a perfectionist so
if
i played good moves if this king walk
and
all this rook f6 and then rook d1 check
rookie five taking on b7 all these moves
if they were good then i would
definitely say it's one of my most
memorable games but if they are not good
then i'll pick something else
and for all the viewers out there who
might get inspired by your game can you
just give like a rule of thumb
on case on king safety
well i would say castling is better for
the heart
[Laughter]
so try to do that
thank you
thanks
[Music]
some sound advice there uh from vedic
robert who is clearly uh delighted with
his win over duboff i think we will come
back to that game towards the end of our
broadcast
uh we we have to there simply is no
choice but to do that but i also want a
t-shirt can vidit make one and sends me
with his face on it saying you know
castling is good for the heart because
i would gladly wear that shirt
i am completely seconding that maybe
i'm sure chess.com is watching and we
could do with some new uh we could get
some new vidit merch
um but no i mean what a game i also like
what he said about being a perfectionist
how he's yet to decide if this game is
going to be one of his memorable ones
once he has checked it with a non-weak
engine
yeah i mean the engines that are in
relatively low depth if you just go to a
laptop and check very quickly it won't
give you the full scope of the game so
he'll definitely dive into that game in
much more detail
probably not during the tournament or at
least not yet i i think he needs to
focus on the games ahead but i think he
was grounded he was humble and he's
hungry he wants to keep going in this
tournament and he's got those jitters
from playing such an adrenaline-filled
game but i really like the way he played
it was fantastic and he is now the
leader of vikings
absolutely and what a day it has been
uh for him
the pity of course we are in a lockdown
and in a pandemic i'm sure he would love
to to celebrate this victory in some way
but maybe tomorrow evening there was a
rest day coming up into two days at the
moment
not too much to do here in vikranza get
some dinner go for a walk but kudos to
fitted and let's take a look now at the
last remaining game karana against
chankland where
fabiano has
pushed f4 and now has this g passer
yeah it was the only way to play for a
win and he put his bishop back on e5
because the bishop was under attack from
the knight and white
if anyone is better here it's probably
white the game is level at this point
the bishop on e5 is better than the
bishop on c8 because the bishop attacks
the c7 pawn it covers the length of
diagonals it just has more squares to go
to so sam needs to be a bit careful but
with accurate play here he should be
able to hold the balance without too
much difficulty and they both have
plenty of time they're going to be
sitting and thinking and there's
numerous options even in this moment
here like you sit and do nothing you
make them like bishop d7 you get a
little adventurous and try to bring your
knight to d4 at some point
these
decisions are not easy i mean knight d4
actually i think tactically is all right
for
oh
wait yes okay
it's actually is okay for black the you
leave the c7 pawn but you open up an
attack on the f5 knight and if the
knight takes on uh d4 pawn takes d4 rook
f3 check so i saw this far and i was
giving away the c7 pawn i'm actually not
sure where to bring the king um
i'm not
certain where but let's bring it to the
center and if i lose the pawn i thought
my d-pawn is so fast that it makes up
for the sacrifice of this pawn on c7
that's just watching
white could also take on b6 but i guess
that's a pawn you don't want to take
you might want to take it you just might
also regret capturing it although it
really needs to be worked out in advance
because if you just give up two pawns
and it's not holding which it apparently
is then you just gave away material and
will likely lose the game so that's why
the nice things about taking on b6 is
that it covers the square on on g1
so at least you don't have that
discovery with jack to promote the pawn
very true
i would not
want to do this if i were shanklin so
knight the move knight to d4 was not
played instead he just moved his king
back to f8 because he has what looks
like a kind of fortress at this point so
why should he do anything too drastic
although
nah it doesn't work i was like what if i
do i'm inspired by vidit's king march
i'm like
what if this king jumped to g6 then that
king on f8 would be in trouble but
that's very far away ph4 there's always
rook h1 check for example
yeah so
i expect fabiano to take a bit of
some time here to figure out is there a
way forward if yes what is it and maybe
we can uh while fabiano is thinking uh
look at the the interview with jordan
van fereced after his victory over
pragnanda
in a game that is being classified by
two double pawns by your opponents
yeah um he definitely didn't have a good
pawn structure basically actually that's
the point of the line i'm playing that
he gets a pawn extra but he's always
playing with this
or this
very bad pawn structure basically um
and
it's it's a little bit better or easier
to play for white it's maybe not all
that much but um definitely long-term
white has very good prospects of finally
like taking all the pawns um basically
that's kind of what happened i got
coordinated and
his position became really unpleasant um
finally he played
f3 to give back a pawn for some activity
but it was not quite enough
but still it took you quite some time to
actually confer to the win
yeah it probably my technique was
actually not so good like
uh like in the rook and game i could
have done better but uh um the position
was so good i think it was probably
never really in doubt i hope at least
and um
yeah i mean the yeah the position is
just too good but
of course he's defending tough and uh it
was never easy
you said that like um this pawn
structure was like the point of the
whole line
to me like you played three bishop c4 in
the sicilian like how much of a theory
or preparations do you have i've been
planning to play this live for a long
long time already but
especially in classical chess but i
never got the chance um so well my my
opponent said he played one of the uh
the the most critical lines so then you
basically get this uh pawn structure but
of course there are a lot of other uh
variations i just mean in general the
position like after he took 95 and then
how the game went
um your brother recently played queen g4
against a sicilian
um
are you guys looking for like new new
ways um like
not super theoretical i don't think
queen g4 is
should be taken as a should be
considered a new way of playing at least
uh don't try it at home i guess
um but yeah the theory is evolving
rapidly so you're trying to sometimes
catch your opponent off guard
and
these days
it seems people try to do
that as soon as possible basically
tomorrow you will play your boss
yeah yeah that's going to be an
interesting game at least i hope um
we'll see how it goes it's the first
time i'm going to be playing with black
against him so extra
extra hard of course but
it's a challenge and i like it's for me
always very special to play with him so
i'm looking forward as well yeah just to
clarify you you will play magnus closing
tomorrow um do you guys have some kind
of agreement that like you cannot use
the prep against him
um
i'm
i'm
maybe there's some line of that but i
don't think uh
uh
that would be really strange so i'm i
think we'll find a way to
get a position uh we haven't discussed
basically gives him a big edge he can
play whatever he wants and you're you're
restrained
i don't know i have to think about it i
haven't
put any thought into the game yet
but i don't think anything gives him a
big edge so
it's just going to be a a game as we'll
see i guess
you're defending your title is magnus
your biggest competitor
i think everyone is my biggest
competitor so
um
yeah
oh i mean i'm hopefully just playing
well myself but definitely nothing of
tournament victory right now
okay thank you okay thank you leonard
leonard with some hard hitting questions
there for jordan and robert uh i guess
magnus carlsen against urine inventories
tomorrow is one of our standout pairings
it certainly is he said he's playing his
boss but he's not too concerned because
everybody you know is trying to rest
that title from him it's going to be a
tough pairing i see that fabiano gets a
second white in a row tomorrow he will
need to make use of that he's playing
daniel dubov who probably is quite upset
and will have a rough night of sleep
after losing the game to vito guzrati
and speaking of bitter gujurati he plays
andrey sapanko two players who won
games today they should be thrilled and
that should be another good matchup
tomorrow
absolutely once again um
i think every day anyway it's always
like oh this is a good matchup but i
mean let's not fool ourselves there's
going to be some great matchups here
every single day
today we've been treated to so much
uh
entertaining decisive bloody
chess and we have four decisive results
already fabiano is still trying to win
here with the white pieces against sam
shankland but it looks like sam
is doing a great uh defensive job so far
sam certainly is he's holding his
hand towards his head
so
it looks like he's going for his rook
that's he's stretching a bit that rook
is very far away from the rest of his
pieces
so he's probably going to move his rook
hey
at first i thought my tv was bugging
oh and there's fabiano in the middle of
it all
having some fun here in the fifth hour
of play
yeah and rook h1 play that is a
necessary move though by shanklin
because the point of king to f2 is not
just bringing the king towards the
center but if you get rook h3 and they
get to bring that rook up to h8 or h7
black is in some big trouble so that's
why h1 was played sam reaches across the
board grabs that rook puts it in the
corner and now for fabiano it's
what's the next idea you
you're working
yeah i'm not sure either
i'm wondering if there's a way to just
like
sort of
wait a turn and try to put the opponent
in zouzong but
i don't think so there's always going to
be moves for black to just sit on the
position
bishop d7 back to c8 for example so just
trying to figure out a way for white to
create some
tricky
it just seems very difficult to create
some possibilities if you cannot
activate
the king and i think
the the black pieces although only three
pieces remain they do a great job of
working together
to keep the king out
and this rook on e3 it just doesn't have
anywhere to go h3 is covered it would
like to perhaps go to a3 but you can't
go through your pawn and if you retreat
off the third rank then your pawn on b3
is loose so you don't really have time
to just do whatever you want if you are
caruana
yes absolutely and um
well fabiano is thinking you know
fabiano very well robert what do you
think his approach here
uh will be
will he keep
trying for another hour to
or if he understands that sam has
defended perfectly and he cannot find a
way forward do you think we might see a
draw offer
well he's not somebody who offers draws
early and this is not early this is
quite late into the round late into the
game and if he did offer draw it's
because no progress can be made and
that's actually how the situation looks
he will try his best he's not going to
do anything
wild he's not the type of player who
just sacrifices upon
speculatively he doesn't like
speculation he prefers to
calculate through and um you know i
think in general fabiano he looks at
this tournament he knows that every
player he's going to face is tough
he wants to make the the most of his
first move advantage when he has the
white pieces but at this stage of the
game there's only
so much to be done although rook to d3
suggests that there's a little something
watch out for your back rank i mean
bishop takes c7 is a tactical threat so
he has no risk he should play on and
that's what he'll do
absolutely i mean this is a threat in
the position uh here bishop d7 and maybe
we can show that with a pass move
um
maybe a rook move somewhere
that's a
an interesting pass move there robert
that's what you call a mouse slip like i
was trying to drag the rook and it got
stuck on f1 so
let's bring it to say c1 just a kind of
random move here
then well i didn't want to move it this
way because rook h3 also scares me but
bishop takes c7 was the point and then
rook d8 check
and
down goes the bishop
so that is
one thread in the position
and i think er leslie also just
explained we don't really want to move
the work array from
h1 or at least we don't want to move it
along the the first rank
because then fabiano would be pouncing
uh on the opportunity to get his own
rook to the age file
guess what
we're gonna ask the same question no
what what is the waiting move what's the
decision to be made here i was going to
ask you you're going to ask me
but sam is about to answer it for us i
think but he was reaching for the rook
which
um
surprises me he's reached back for his
head
maybe rook h7 i mean it's a very
defensive move but at least it covers
the immediate threat
i mean i'm always
surprised that the bar just coolly says
and yeah he does go for work h7 zero
zeros i would not be feeling comfortable
defending this uh as black i have to say
but sam shanklin i guess he feels
reasonably comfortable at this stage
though i wonder
if black can just wait forever so say
rook d1 is played
now the rook has much more flexibility
because it can also go to the a file
that said this bishop can go to b7 at
some point so it's not like black has
nothing to do especially with the rook
on h7 it covers the point of entry the
d7 square so that means the bishop is
free to go to the long diagonal if
shanklin so chooses
and i'm i was wondering um
if rook d1
can i try and get active
by
bringing the rook to h3 or is the tactic
with bishop c7 still there
or does it matter that i'm attacking the
pawn on b3 what's going on
it matters for sure and you can see that
the
engine says
looks like a good move you have to
calculate it probably pretty deeply
because after your bishop takes a c7
rook takes b3 and you don't have to
move your knight it still covers the
square but even this position with the
bishop coming back to e5 and a rook
coming to d6 things like that or knight
to d6 it to be really careful at this
stage of the game so i think the players
they see the options but now it's about
whose evaluation function is operating
better as they've already been playing
for five hours
also they prepared for the game uh
that's what time is it by you like seven
seven pm yeah yeah it's getting later
they haven't eaten in a while all we've
seen is the tea
and the water that they're you know
drinking so these things add up and
[Music]
also sam played some very long games i
mean we remember his marathon game uh
against vidit
uh from the first round and then
yesterday sam played the time i think he
played twice the the longest game or the
first day definitely but yesterday his
game against nils uh was maybe not the
longest but also very fighting so
although it's only round three these
tournaments really take it out of you
yeah he's three for three in terms of
long games and
he's a player who he fights and
so far he's had to fight because game
one against vidit that it just had a
better position and was pressing here in
the third round fabiano's been trying to
make some inroads but sam is defending
very well and then yesterday sam
actually had some great chances to win
against niels grendelius and he was not
able to do that right around the time
control nearing mu 40 was where sam went
wrong and niels was able to stabilize
his position and as we see sam here he's
still thinking he's still working he's
calculating and he does not want to let
this game slip as we're 51 moves in
it's uh quite late
into the round here to make a mistake
he'll he will not do that and he'll not
want to do that that's for sure yeah and
let's look at the time control
again the longest
out of any tournaments we have 100
minutes for 40 moves then an extra 50
minutes for the next 20
then another finally 15 minutes after
move 60 with a 30 second increment from
movemon right now the players are on
move 51 so
they have
nine more moves to make in their
allocated time and then they will get an
extra
15 minutes so fabiano is still thinking
is it gonna be rook d1 if not rook t1
what other options are there for fabiano
i think the big question is where do the
pieces belong
is the king on f2 is that where you want
to be or does the king want to be on a3
and i think you have the time to just
walk your king over unless black has
some quick way to punish that decision
but this rook on h7 needs to stay on the
h file i think that's pretty clear
because if you offer a trade with rook
to d7 or something like that then this
rook slides to h3 and you have some
serious problems to deal with
revolving around rook to h8 so i think
that black
is in the perfect defensive stance and
then that
leads me to wonder okay so what can
white do here black
kind of stuck but also very stable now
for white is there something i can
threaten by maneuvering a piece should
this knight come back to e3 and maybe to
d5 try to go to f6 or attack the c7 pawn
something like that is certainly
available to
caruana here
yeah so a lot of things
to consider and i think the position
uh is definitely not as simple as i
thought at first sight or not as simply
to to keep equal for sam who i think has
done a tremendous job so far uh parrying
every attempt
of fabiano i see there's quite a lot of
discussion in the chat about fabiano's
face mask actually that's the mask
that was handed out to the players here
last year at the tata steel
chess tournament and i noticed actually
robert that it's been a favorite of
fabiano's wherever i've seen him for the
for the past year
he was very often wearing this tata mask
which the players were handed out plenty
from of course it's a cloth mask so you
can wash it anyway but i think last year
we were given about
uh 15 of them or something
so maybe that specific one isn't his
favorite maybe it's one of his 15
favorites you
know that you know it was free 99 it
came with the tournament entry so uh you
know he's happy to
sport that mask and
oh gosh
as someone who wears glasses
i'm pretty impressed that i haven't seen
his glasses fog up too much because i
know from experience that when you wear
a mask like my glasses are always
fogging so
he still has clear vision in his game is
i've been thinking that i think this
mask maybe there's something special
about it maybe that's why he keeps
wearing that one uh because indeed we
haven't seen the glasses
fogging up so uh shout out to the tata
steel mask makers
indeed and we see fabiano focus both
players trying to
assess this position and it's fabiano on
the clock there are nine moves until the
next time control as you pointed out
fiona move 60 gives the players more
time and
they have plenty of remaining in this
segment as well but i'm trying to really
try to dive in and see where fabiano can
even hope
to make inroads like
what's the square what's the piece
where can we make improvements i would
like to
threaten to push my palm i know it's
going to be difficult the knight on e6
is so good
but that's what i want to accomplish if
i could push my pawn to g5 safely now
black is in some serious danger with
that pawn advancing but g5 is not a good
move here
as we can see that the knight can't
afford to take this pawn i don't think
because there's a rook d8 check getting
the bishop but now the pawn has gone
quite far so
actually i'm not sure
like i said it was not a good move and
now i'm looking like maybe it's not
that unreasonable and fabiano has just
made his move it isn't g5 but king g3
okay which makes a lot of sense as well
yes it just covers many squares here on
the h file um and sort of passes the
baton back to shanklin you come up with
a move i just
found one at long last
and
yeah i mean it's a more advanced square
so you probably pretty happy about that
but i still let's say black plays bishop
b7 right that kind of waiting move
what is white going to do where is the
winning attempt going to come from
i was wondering when we were looking at
the previous position can we ever put
the bishop our bishop on f6 or are we
giving up the defense of some squares
like even after like i like king g3 and
while you were saying what after bishop
b7 can i go bishop f6 there
all right sorry
i'll go back i said you're saying the
game so you were saying bishop b7 and i
was wondering can i put my bishop
there might be rook h3 check
king takes and then knight f4 and
we
liquidate into a in ending of opposite
colored bishop still not the end of the
story because white has this pawn that
black needs to deal with
but it seems at least by the bar
not wavering that black is doing well
enough to survive this position so
g5 bishop d8 comes to mind as well but
black has knight c1 going after b3 so it
looks like the queen side pawns are
going to fall
yeah
so okay we will see if
sam
is um
sam is still still thinking after
rook g3 our producer bigfoot is being
triggered by the open door uh in the
background of uh of the players here the
playing hall it always looks so stunning
but in fact this is just a gymnasium a
sports hall which is every year in uh
january being transformed into the
beautiful blue playing hall uh for a few
weeks
and the players you know they're always
treated very well in vicenza it's a
fantastic event
because the organization is phenomenal
and the atmosphere is great and of
course the competition
is also stellar and right now it's just
fabiano it's and sam shanklin those two
players are duking it out you know that
fabiano wants to win this game he could
offer a draw that would be accepted at
any moment so you know fiona that he
really really really wants this one and
the
move number 52. shanklin has plenty of
time he's doing well in the clock but
you get that feeling that if this goes
into that third time control and then
both players are getting low on the
clock that's where those mistakes happen
and it looks like a position where white
can't go wrong and black has to be
careful here not to
make a mistake yeah and well we're going
to come back to this one we're going to
quickly uh go to a video and hear what
magnus carlsen had to say after his draw
against duda today
[Music]
magnus you just played a draw against
young christoph duda
you continued your theoretical battle in
the anti-marshal and were you ever in
trouble in this game
no i would uh i wouldn't say i continued
the um
the theoretical battle i kind of
conceded the theoretical battle by going
h6 instead of um
instead of d5
and
i basically yeah
just
wanted to play um
some some relatively quiet position and
gradually equalize um
but
yeah i think he played it
very cleverly with uh queen c2 and d4
which i'd kind of underestimated i
always thought i could meet d4 with um
with d5 and be fine but then
as it happened i was not so sure
and uh he got a little more pressure
than um
uh than i had hoped that he he would
um but
i think maybe his only chance was to
refuse the rook exchange uh with rupee
two uh go queen c4 instead
i think after
he took the rook which looks very
promising um because he can sort of kick
my pieces away after i can kind of
consolidate and he has to reckon with
with night jumps and also
also these ideas of
c6 and f5 all the time
and i think i gradually
equalize or at least get in uh get the
position to something i can hold
comfortably
um is it surprising to you that your
opponents keep on playing the
anti-martial and not letting you
playing the martial attack itself
uh no
is it because the martial attack is dead
or is it like a death draw or
no
if not a good a dead draw it's at least
a good opening that has been thoroughly
analyzed and it's it's kind of hard to
um yeah it's kind of hard to to get
something there
tomorrow you will play jordan von
forrest the title holder and also your
second in the
for the recent match is it uh special
for you to play a second
yeah i can't wait to see what he's got
up his sleeve
i'm sure it's gonna be something crazy
okay good luck thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
magnus carlsen conceding the theoretical
battle
to do that today and he also said robert
he cannot wait to see what jordan has up
his leave tomorrow which should be a
great game but before we look at the the
pairings for tomorrow uh let's see what
happened here in round three today
yeah we have four decisive results thus
far five and our caruana trying to make
it five but sam shanklin saying no sir
you're not getting that victory but
anishkiri mama jarov they drew their
game we heard from magnus carlson or his
draw with duda and then you see the
results the first wins for the players
of the black pieces report quickly
followed by vita gujarati and they beat
grendelius and dubo respectively and
then of course yesapanko and von forrest
they won with the white pieces so a very
combative day
indeed and well before we come back to
fabiano's uh
fight face he's pressing against them
here are the pairings for tomorrow we've
talked a couple of times already against
about the clash between magnus carlson
and his second jordan van ferece but
there's plenty more action to look
forward to fabiano carrana he will be
right against danny lubov so he will get
another chance with the white pieces
regardless of what happens today we'll
see how daniel
recovers from a
tough loss too
very today and well speaking of vidit he
is the new tournament leader and he will
be playing against the essie pankl with
the white pieces
should be a great day again tomorrow but
right now we just saw a
pretty funny repetition uh while we were
away the rook went to h7 king g3 we saw
that and then look at this rook d7
rook d1
rook h1 so
and then rook h7 so if if this looks
familiar it's because you have in fact
seen this position before the king just
went to g3 the rook went to d7 to d1 to
h1 to h7 so
we have seen a repetition and that's
clear that shanklin knows what he's
doing he has this defensive task in the
bag and if fabiano is going to continue
to try and win this game to prolong it
he needs to do something new otherwise
we'll have a draw by repetition
yeah and fabiano well he has 12 minutes
remaining on the clock but only five
moves to go
until move 60 when they will get an
additional
15 minutes so this attempt with king g3
has been
uh
i was going to say dismantled by
by sam but maybe that's not quite the
right word but here comes the new
attempt rook d1 a move which we were
looking at just earlier robert
and it came with a walk away he he made
the move got up from the board and he'll
leave sam to think about how he wants to
respond and i'm trying to figure out the
major differences here so now the king
is on f2 rather than g3 so if rook to d7
which is what
sam went for before
when the king was on g3 and the rook on
d3 the rook couldn't go through the
white king so rook d7 will allow rook to
h1 and that is not what you want to see
if you're sam shanklin right rook d7
rook h1
and now the rook infiltrates and you see
the evaluation bar go up in white's
favor so there have been small
differences that often go unnoticed but
not by players of this caliber they see
that fabiano retreated the rook he wants
to take over the h file i will not allow
him to do that
yeah and now sam once again he's already
found so many accurate moves but once
again what is the correct move here he
is
been facing this passive defensive task
for pretty much the whole game but he's
done his job marvelously we saw him
reach out and then take the hand back
and he's going to give it another
thought but i thought he was reaching
for the bishop
and bishop b7
is an option
bishop d7 also
is an option though the rook being on d1
that is a bit of a cause for concern
here that rook not only could go to h1
but it'd go to a1 so you want to be
really careful here if you're sam that
rook can enter the game via a7 or a8
it's not like black has much of a choice
if fabiano wants to play rook a1 there's
nothing that sam can do to stop it
so you need to figure out where your
pieces should be
for black
and we see sam reaching again and bishop
b7
it is so the the light squared bishop
wants us again back along the long
uh
diagonal
oh no it doesn't work so i was gonna try
to be cheeky here and i was thinking if
i go rook e1
how is black going to respond to this
because your knight is in the same line
as my rook and
my idea is if you play king f7
protecting the knight then i had bishop
takes c7 here i believe because i have
this knight d6 check and
i guess even getting this this isn't
that great for
white but i did steal a pawn in the
process
rook d7 will trap my knight so
not the ideal scenario it appears
not ideal but
another example of tactics to look out
for
in this position it's never too late i
mean even with such reduced material you
always have to be
on the lookout especially when there's a
an opponent
a night nearby your king
exactly and
uh another variation uh rookie one you
know rook h1 this is the type of move
that black wants to play to exchange
rooks that might honestly just be a good
decision and white can try to avoid the
trade with rookie three
and then i think we're back to where we
came from the bishop can go back to c8
to protect the knight and we've been
here before
yes
uh indeed it seems like we keep going
around uh in circles here
but
still
fabiano of course he is continuing
trying to find
uh ways
to to create problems after bishop b7
are there any squares that are loose
that the bishop was defending from c8 do
we have any new possibilities
d7 covered by the rook which is why
bishop b7 is possible
is there a waiting move like rook to d2
but then the bishop can probably just go
back to c8
where is
the chance
and rook a1 comes to mind funnily enough
that question just appeared in the chat
by anesopterix what about rook a1 so
let's have a look at that
yeah rook a1 very reasonable let's go
onto the open file
and rook a7 is annoying but the knight
and the rook both defend the pawn so
you're not even threatening anything
with rook a7 if i move my bishop i could
actually start moving my bishop and i'm
attacking your knight i'm threatening
bishop c2 ideas that you need to be on
the lookout for
uh so that's
not the most comfortable situation
although if we take this just one step
further can i almost uh sorry say oh
king e3 and you go bishop c2 i'm
wondering if i can trap your bishop like
bishop takes b3 and then king c3 and
something like this and rotation
now it's gonna block but now that i see
it you have knight d4 and you survive
because this knight needs protection and
it is pinned and this knight defends
here
oh justin
by the way uh just uh pondering in the
chat to get back to your question about
would we please review vidit versus
duboff if you want to see the review of
that game stay tuned until the end of
the stream because it will be our rapid
recap game as soon as the fabiano game
is over for now we see once again the
bird's eye view with only one live game
remaining four of them have ended
decisively if you want to replay
any of the games that have been played
so far you can head to chess.com
events to play through all the games and
see all the results
yes we will be breaking down what
happened in that
wonderful game between dubai and vidit
and fabiano caruana he doesn't care
about that game he might care later but
right now all he is thinking about is
his moves his position and sam
shanklin's stubborn defense and you have
to give sam credit uh some players would
have been broken by now he's just
committing to the task at hand and he's
doing a wonderful job at that
indeed and fabiano we saw there a slight
shake of the the head
it is a frustrating uh a frustrating one
for fabiano i think it's the story uh
very often of the the berlin end game
your opponent from the start says okay
i'll play this super solid opening and
white
uh tries you know white only has these
small small
things to play for but they are
fabiano has been trying to play for that
small edge for the whole game
them doing a perfect job of defending so
far
so it can be frustrating but he keeps
trying and so he should the bishop has
just gone back to g3
and i'm trying to figure out why the
bishop is placed here it does cover the
h4 square in case you want to go to a
new diagonal the knight wants to jump
there it still covers h2 while putting
pressure on c7
what is i mean
i don't really see the huge benefit of
the bishop there besides putting in a
new square so there's no repetition
can we have any
okay this is gonna be can my idea be to
play knight
h4
and knight although i don't know where
i'm going robert
hey sometimes that's how you find the
right move is you just look and like
okay night night night oh that's e5 that
looks right uh it's not entirely clear
where the pieces are going he is opening
up the e-file so maybe rook e1
is a bit of a threat that black needs to
take into account
um
in fact if rookie one is to be played
that asks an uncomfortable question of
this knight although maybe it will try
to go to d4 so
robert
yes bigfoot wants to hear the thoughts
of our viewers on this all-important
topic of the open door can we please get
a poll in chat make our producer big
happy can we please hear your thoughts
should the door be open or should it be
captioning not
bothering
available
i think we should leave the door open
you should always leave leave the door
open and leave a light on
um
robert
is it time for a final
quick
break what do you think
uh for the players
uh to reach move 60 and then we'll be
back with the final stages of this game
here
sure if you say so i'm not going to say
otherwise i'm oh bishop e4 was played
though the players have a different idea
in mind
hey he makes the move bishop to e4 he's
trying to take that knight and f5 who
knows where that will lead us but i will
follow your lead fiona
we'll be back in just a few minutes so
don't go anywhere
i just want to say i know it's early
it's early for all of us but fabi you're
looking fresh no thanks danny
chad likes it man looking good
what what about me
all right guys let's go run a show back
here we go
and fabi this video series was great by
the way people love it
really do
by the way again dude you're
you're just looking fresh man i love
your new haircut it makes me good
[Music]
hey how's it going
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i don't even recognize myself
it's a whole new me
[Music]
hey fabi dan how's it going hey robert
hey man
you know just trying out a few new
things here and there the day's
beautiful sun is out
cool
hey danny yeah
forgot to mention that haircut's looking
real fresh on you yeah thanks man
cool
appreciate it
serious what does a guy guy do around
here to get noticed
what are you talking about
i
seems a little out of line a little
uncalled for
you know you already can't spell chess
without him what more does he want
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
fabiano caruana will he win his second
tata
chess tournament at the moment he is
still looking
for his first win in this year's
event robert but today there were a lot
of other players who got what they were
looking for which was the full point
yeah really decisive day it doesn't look
like fabiano caron is going to join
those ranks and actually with the last
few moves sam shanklin has turned this
game from one that he was holding to
perhaps if fabinho is not careful that
sam can even try to
win the game i mean right now we can see
that the evaluation says level but look
at this it's so different there's a
knight beautifully placed on d4
attacking this pawn on b3 the last move
was f6 is that a pawn that's wandered
too far or is actually that going to be
a thorn in black side so to go back to
where we came from bishop e4 played rook
to e1 forcing black's hand here bishop
takes knight pawn takes bishop the
knight moved and then f6 so i think the
first thing that everyone is thinking
about is is that not just a free pawn
and it is a pawn that can be captured
white can immediately force a draw with
the move rook to e7 because once the
trade of rooks happens here and you are
up two pawns for black white takes one
white takes two white takes three all in
a row it's uh like pac-man and you just
grab them all and it's just a draw so
that would end the game peacefully but
also i mean with the pawn f6 perhaps
fabiano can try to put his bishop on e5
and use that pawn
to
try and promote it's asking a lot and
you could lose because black now has
extra pawns over on the queen side and
the knight can come to a5 and hit this
other pawn
but it also is a winning attempt
yeah so let's see um
if fabiano tries to win from here so if
he doesn't go with e7
let's have a look at uh was it bishop e5
you were suggesting
yeah and
the knight can come to a5 to
attack a pawn the rook i think should
likely go up the board to defend it and
a situation like this where those pawns
are not moving just yet for black
i get that black's up upon that the
queen side majority looks good but one
pawn is more advanced than the rest and
it's that pawn on f6 and how are you
going to make progress you're going to
try and bring the king forward
i would love to if you give me a few
free moves my king is going to
walk not that way up this way somewhere
and try to get all the g6 this knight
can go right back into the game and
yeah there's no
hope really for white to win unless
black
does something ridiculous because you're
already situated right in front of the
pawn so it seems like black can just
bring the knight back and there's
nothing i would try to force the draw
from fabian at this point i don't really
see
too much in the way of winning chances
time decided not to take the pawn on b3
instead playing rook h6 attacking the
pawn on f6
okay so he wants that pawn which would
also defend the b6 pawn
which means that the knight would then
be free to start taking things but
bishop e5
hmm i don't love the rook on h6
it is a weird square so bishop e5 can i
still go and take on b3
um okay and then i was going to try to
bring my rook to an open oh okay one it
just drops the rook it's been a long day
can't do that so i can play rook d1 but
then you're probably just gonna bring
your knight back to d4 and
all right the game continues like this
king is walking up the board my rook
nope still can't go to a1 after it
because there's a check here or maybe
can try somewhere else nah this is
nothing this is just totally equal
there's no way to win for a while i mean
honestly if anything black is the one
who's gonna have some winning chances so
fabiano needs to be careful
yeah and well fabiano is the one
who's thinking now rook h6 by the way
was move 60
so both players we don't see the times
being added yet because i think it will
be added uh once the the three minutes
and that fabiano has remaining are gone
but they will get an extra 15 minutes
now and that's the final
time control but
i agree with you robert i i think we
will see a share of the point here
yeah it's
you taking mindset into account when
you've had a better position for a while
sometimes you don't make that
switch to i need to calm down i need to
actually just make sure i have the draw
immediately because if i don't then i
may never make that draw so for fabiano
who was the one pressing now he's the
one that's probably on the defensive so
i think that he should if he sees a way
that just says
game's done let's do it let's make a
draw for example if bishop takes c7
brook takes f6 is check the king just
walks away somewhere like g2 and if the
knight takes on b3
at this point just go rook b1 you win
this pawn here and then you're gonna
take this one just call it a day that's
what i would probably do
yeah i think fabiano will do that if he
doesn't see
any way to to press any further which
there doesn't seem to be
um i think he's never really the kind to
to overpress too often i think he's
very
what's the word i'm looking for
uh when you see things the way they are
you know
he's very practical yeah i think he's
very practical there's another word i'm
sure he'll come back to me but he's very
objective also about his evaluations of
the
of the position
uh so a player who is quite unlikely to
to overextend and um yeah i'm curious if
we're going to maybe even just see that
line that you just showed
pragmatic is another good word actually
yeah
we're playing the thesaurus game now i i
like that game can we do that one um but
he is going to drop the b3 pawn and then
he will have to prove that his bishop
his pawn here
that that
is worth playing for because he could
have just taken on c7 and made the draw
right away he's choosing to play on his
king would love to get up somewhere like
g5 or f5 but that's
a ways away
wait he took on c7
c7 rook f6 is on the board and king g2
and i think after knight takes b3 for a
second i thought what's going on but it
was a jadoop
can you even say jadoop if you're
wearing a face mask robert what if your
phone doesn't hear it
you know it's extremely important that
when it's just one player against
another that you say jadoob i adjust
however you say it in your native tongue
extremely loudly for everyone to hear
because if you clearly adjust the piece
but don't say it out loud the entire
internet is going to take you by storm
and be like how could you that's
cheating and then it's going to be the
talk of the town so
i don't know that's maybe just my
opinion but i think that uh both players
will be okay whether or not it's said
out loud
and yeah i think well
we looked at this and indeed it looks
like if anyone can play now uh it is sam
seems to be the only one
because i think that line we showed
which knight b3 rook b1 would just be an
immediate draw
right because you give up b3 you get b6
once b6 falls then c5 will fall and
white will lose c4 so it's just a mass
exchange of material
and
sam might be looking for something
better if he could play rook c6 for
example and kick the bishop back then he
would be able to win that pawn on b3
without losing b6 so this is a good
moment
for shanklin to really dive into the
position and not just accept that the
result will be a draw and there's rook
c6 exactly and
it's a it's an interesting moment
because throughout the whole game we
felt sam would be take
uh
except a draw for at any time he was
always the one slightly on the back foot
but suddenly
he gets the slightest of chances and he
is not happy any longer to just shake
hands and go home and fabiano is the one
now who's going to
to have to find a few precise moves to
not get
to not get into any trouble
yeah and where is this bishop even going
i think if it goes to d8 it's not going
to stay in contact with this pawn for
very long because bishop d8
after the move knight takes b3 even like
let's say we get this position the rook
comes to b1 if the knight were to move
then b6 falls but black has this great
move king to e8 you see the evaluation
bar sinking and it's because
black is kicking this bishop
off of d8 if rook takes b3 i take the
bishop i'm up a pawn and my king is
closer to where the action is taking
place and if your bishop has to move
away somewhere then the knight will just
move away and attack the c4 pawn so this
would be a big problem for fabiano if he
doesn't play with care
indeed and well let's very quickly uh
while we wait for fabiana to make his
next move go back one more time to show
you the results of today because it's
been such an exciting game we had four
decisive
uh four decisive games we had our first
black wins of the tournament one for
richard to report against nato's
granddaddy's and the other undoubtedly
the game of the day we shall come back
to that in our rapid recap video
gujarati uh winning an absolute uh
phenomenal game against daniel duboff
and then two of our younger players
andreas panko took out karjakin and
jordan van ferece bouncing back to beat
pragnanda
the main clash of the day duda against
magnus carlsen was well fought but ended
peacefully
so many interesting games we are spoiled
of course tomorrow will be another great
day at the office and this day is not
done yet the players do not want to go
home no rest for the weary and for
fabiano in particular he needs to be
careful he has spent the majority of
this game trying to nurse the tiniest of
edges and make it into a win and right
now he's the one who's worse sam
shanklin is probably sitting there
thinking all right if
fabiano makes one inaccuracy now i can
take advantage and play for a win so
fabiano's sitting there still pondering
his turn
and it's not comfortable if you know
we've been there as players when we're
better all game and now we're worse to
sit there and just try to take it in
stride we often
become self-critical
yeah it's a it's a weird one for fabiano
because he just just a couple of moves
ago had the chance to to force a draw if
we go back
uh to that moment after um
after
was it after knight d4
or am i imagining things
did he not have
no it was a different variation where um
he
if
for example
knight takes b3 was played then we were
looking at correct
where it could be a forcing situation
but instead
sam
wisely played rook h6 and now rooks c6
and it's up to fabiano to find precise
moves
yeah maybe this whole uh
pushing f6 do you think pushing f6 is
the moment that started giving some
some chances or where do you think the
turning point was
i think fabiano might have overlooked
bishop e4
right here
uh he went bishop to g3 which was a
retreating move that we were kind of
wondering what the real purpose was and
then bishop e4 happened and it's black
who's seizing the initiative this
capture we saw in the game otherwise the
bishop was coming to c2 to hit the rook
in the pawn and once we saw these trades
here the rest of the
moves are
kind of forced in a sense and now we're
at a point where fabiano is
exercising caution he will gain more
time in the clock once the player hits
zero they go under if you you know zoom
into the clock we'll see he has time
he is going to use much of his remaining
time to figure out how to play here i do
think that bishop d8 will still maintain
the balance um other moves like
retreating don't really look appetizing
they don't look appealing knight takes
b3 is there
i say appetizing because i'm hungry
we'd love some lunch eventually but it
really doesn't look appealing to retreat
and bishop d8 he is just trying to
figure out this situation when rook b1
is met by king de e8
yeah and
rook
sorry after bishop
d8 knight takes b3 the question is what
do we do unfortunately as you you said
rook b1
fails to to king yate but what are the
alternatives here
i think rook e5 sacrifice your bishop
take the last pawn because rook and
knight versus rook is quite an easy
theoretical draw for players
at this level so if this knight were to
move you say okay i'm about to go or
even
kind of better looking is knight d2
there's no rook e4 i'm going to take
your pawn c4 which white cannot afford
he is just in time to play bishop takes
b6 give up the bishop take that final
pawn and then make a draw yes a knight
down but a draw is a draw and what if i
don't move my knight away what if i um
so yeah in this position what if i try
and bring my king let's say king f7
and i'll give you another turn what's
your next move
okay but yeah you're just gonna bring
your own
you i'm trying to set some trust okay
king f7 i'll pass the move to you
okay i'm gonna keep giving you moves you
know black's turn
okay
um
[Music]
okay
right the thing is this bishop
and the rook okay you're cutting me off
everywhere
exactly and as soon as you move your
knight then i will take the pawn and
then i'll get your last pawn so that's
going to be a drawing mechanism we just
saw the move
bishop f4 played
by fabiano so he retreats the bishop
giving up this pawn on
b3
hmm
i don't love this decision by him
what's the
what's the idea if some takes on v3
that he's just going to try and hold
this position down upon
fiona
we we've had a long day already full of
excitement
this one
might go
a whole lot longer
yay
[Laughter]
and it is getting interesting though
because fabiano has to prove that he's
up to the challenge and he perhaps can
sit his rook on e4 and then as soon as
the rook for black moves away go back to
bishop c7 and this pawn is a
permanent target that you have to deal
with and the king will be cut off
i don't have a good feeling about this
one if you're a fabiano caruana fan this
is not going in direction that you can
be happy about
i still have faith in fabiano i
i don't still see exactly how is black
if i just bring my king now is right to
like c3 over to the the queen side
um but i agree with you of course i mean
for fabiano this is not gonna be
this is not going to be any fun
uh he was the one pressing throughout
the whole game and all of the sudden he
is the one
doing the defending
damn he could have just ended the game
at several moments he played bishop e5
back to g3 and let sam play bishop e4 so
that's what's uncomfortable is he could
have concluded he could have offered a
draw sam would have readily accepted now
sam's up upon and if a draw were to be
offered
sam would obviously say no why would you
agree to a draw here even though it's
completely even he can play it out for a
while and make fabiano prove it
yeah and well there will be i know you
said it
jokingly of course there would be no no
uh draw offer here i think some would
maybe even find some some words of
choice
he would feel quite would you feel quite
disrespected here robert if your
opponent offered you a drawer is right
i mean it's just not
he's not polite to do that
the etiquette of chess says the side
that has the advantage is the side that
can offer a draw i mean blacks up a pawn
it's not like white has an attack or
anything to speak of as compensation for
it it is still objectively a level game
but there's no reason why fabinho should
ever offer a draw here it would actually
be a bit rude
and the clock situation does uh sam
actually still have 26 minutes
he gained that 15 minutes at the time
patrol
okay so i didn't realize he still had so
much uh time left
leading up to move 50. so i think one of
the things that fabiano is going to have
to be very mindful about
is not to take down uh too low on the
clock because fabiano only has 11
minutes at this position we think should
be a draw
but you don't want to be defending it
with only a minute on the clock
and the 30 second increment will always
come in handy so if you make a couple
quick moves you can
gain a minute or two but here rook f6
played very clear please
play king to f3 why don't you play king
to f3 that's how you lose games in the
spot
the bishop is pinned so knight d2 check
that you see the bar go down and it's
going to stay down
you can't take the knight it's bishop is
pinned to the king so that would allow
black to win the game obviously fabiano
not going to make that move he took his
king g3 and he's going to walk his king
up the board fiona something you
advocated for a long time ago and he is
going to just hold the balance by being
extremely active and thus limiting black
from getting everything that he wants
going after the c4 pawn because black's
king while it's tucked away in the last
rank if the white king goes up to g5 and
even into g6 then there could be a a
kind of mating yet
yeah and it's one of the problems for
sam in this position that the king is
cut off on the f file you would love to
bring your king
over
over to the queen side maybe via a6 a5
b4 infiltrate at the white camp but
fabiano isn't gonna let you do that so
easily
certainly not
and if you trade rooks
then white immediately trades and plays
bishop c7 takes takes so that's another
issue that black needs to deal with is
that if the rooks get traded this knight
needs to be somewhere where it defends
the b6 pawn and then you're in a passive
position anyway and not going for
white's remaining pawn on c4 and on the
big camera there we see the two arbiters
in the background who are also
waiting for the final day
final game of the day to conclude in the
challengers section everything is over
so this is uh these are the last two
players in the playing hall there we see
one more time the results
of the day with uh of course the
magnificent with it victory
jordan went for is beating pragnanda
rapport beating grendelius and yesipanko
deciding at the russian clash in his
favor the other two games were drawn and
we see the two arbiters also with the
clock it is
1959 here in the netherlands uh so
in just a minute we will hit six hours
of play uh robert which is quite a long
game
it's only six uh it feels like it's been
26. wow it's a
been a fun day but also these players
they must be really tired uh chess when
you're going through all the variations
in your head you're calculating
assessing starting all over again with
every single move it's a really tiring
uh adventure and so for
sam shanklin he after five plus hours
now has the edge so he's going to try to
maximize that but there really isn't
anything he can do
to
get a win here the position is balanced
and fabiano knows it and he plays king
of g4 and if there's ever a rook trade
as mentioned we swap we play bishop c7
thank you very much i get your pawns so
if i'm sam i maybe move knight to a5 to
start with just try to figure out a way
to
get after white's pawns a bishop can go
back to c7 at any moment
yes indeed and well robert you talked
about how grueling the tournament is
maybe we can take a quick look at the
tournament schedule see one is the first
rest day coming up i think the players
will be looking forward to it eagerly so
we have one more game tomorrow tomorrow
is round four um and after that on
january the 19th we have our first rest
day after that there will be another
four rounds so i think the this first
stretch of the first eight rounds uh is
quite intense but after that there was
another rest day
on january 24th and only two games
before the third and final rest day on
january 27th
and then the final weekend of the
tournament where everything will be
decided so
a long tournament and so important we
haven't talked about it so much but i
think it's so important for the players
to arrive here
in good physical shape
certainly because when you're sitting at
the board for this long and working
through the complexities of the game
that takes a lot out of you so if you're
not in
your best physical shape you're not
going to be able to play your best chest
and that's been talked about much more
recently than it was in the past and i
think we've seen
exercise and uh physical well-being that
has become increasingly important
whereas you know back in the day used to
be like a kind of a running joke players
were smoking at the board and uh
drinking at the board and doing all that
kind of stuff of course some players
smoke some players drink but they also
put more of an emphasis on the physical
aspects of their entire being
indeed and i think you and i can say
well it's such a a small town but very
often if you
are in the village either in the
mornings before the round or in the
evenings
you will bump quite a lot into the
players who are going for works
it is a small village so there are no
gyms there are no gyms at the hotels
there are no swimming pools so
you will see um the players going for
for long walks it is very scenic for
for that though uh with some some green
fields at the beaches of course right
here
so uh that's how the the players try and
balance the many hours uh spent
at the board
and sam he is still in the tank
trying to figure out how he can
potentially
make progress but it looks like fabiano
has found a good defensive setup
he certainly has because his king is up
the board which all which means that
black can't bring his king up too much
uh more either so we sit here we think
what can we do what trades do we want
honestly black doesn't really want to
trade but if black doesn't trade
anything then there's no way to make
progress and that's why this game
remains even despite the extra material
for
black
and robert i think we're gonna go on
another
short break
as
sam has just given a check but we'll
come back to this game in just a couple
of minutes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i remember coming here uh first time was
2015 i was playing the b section i had a
fantastic result i made plus five but
wei yi was an absolute terminator
i played him with white in round one and
it was a draw and it was just i never
had a chance again if i had known that
he was going to go nuts maybe i would
have pushed a little harder
i remember at first it was chorus chess
before it was thought to steal and i
always remembered this was like the the
most important tournament of the year
the biggest best one
tata still chess room and you know they
call it the wimbledon of chess and i
think they've earned that name it's just
the best term in the world
obviously you know with magnus in the
field and i'm in the bottom half
the odds are against me but you know if
the best player always won chess will be
a very boring game i'm just going to
play my best and if the points come that
way they will
so i use technology for opening
preparation for sure but that's more or
less the only thing i use it for i think
i'm more scared in terms of the future
of trust if computers just processing
faster and then if they've become a
little bit stronger i worry that one day
chess can be weakly solved
luckily i still think that day is very
very far away and i think it will be
after i'm retired many many years in the
future
it was a very memorable tournament for
me both with positive and negative
attributes last time but i'm really
looking forward to playing again this
year
[Music]
and good to hear from sam there who has
a good memories from vikenzi today
well we see him
deeply focused
so trying to see if there is any way
here to break fabiano's defenses
fabiano who may be overpriced just a
little bit and now has to defend upon
down but robert we think he found a good
setup
he certainly did he just put his bishop
on g5 to block the check against his
king and a pin piece can still protect
the square so rook e7 check that bishop
still defends the e7 square he'll try to
push the king back and then this rook
can perhaps go to b7 the king's gonna
try to infiltrate via f5
black is trying to win it really doesn't
look like he's going to be able to
because of white's activity and
well-placed pieces
yeah and sometimes you even have to be
careful again to not suddenly overpress
as black here you don't want as only the
white king to come in the uh the white
rook to appear on e7 to being pushed
back
so i think we will see a draw here but
uh i don't think it will be immediate
no yeah although it's kind of funny
because if you look at the players
fabiano looks kind of
i'm ready for this game to be done and
sam looked a little distressed even
though for the most part he was the one
who had the slightly worse position now
he's i really want to find something
anyway to
go for a win there just isn't anything
happening here the rook coming e7 if
knight to d4 oh this and he just made a
move and what is it knight to a5
but i was going to say that had he
chosen knight to d4 and white played
rook to e7 check that you have to be
careful because now rook takes g5 is a
threat removing the guard of this rook
and if the rook moves away somewhere you
have to watch out for 96 type of ideas
you're fortunate in a position like this
that's after rook to b7 knight e6
there's king f5 hitting the rook and if
the rook takes the bishop then you lose
your knight so white
gets into a pin a bit of a pickle but
king f5 would solve all the problems
yes so
very nice for fabiano i'm sure he had
seen this from a distance but a very
nice resource king f5 with the double
attack against the black uh wicked
knight so knight d4 wasn't played
instead the sam is trying knight
a5
so putting some pressure on the pawn on
c4
and i wonder can we bring out king
closer
the move i'm looking at is king f5
rookie 7 of course is also tempting what
do you think
yeah if king f5 perhaps this knight will
come back to c6 which covers the e7
square and then knight d4 check in the
future
the knight could have been on d4 right
away i think that rook e7 check
the king has to go back and then maybe
rook d7
is possible i understand i'm giving away
a second pawn and some of you may be
nervous about that or think i'm just
blundering i did it intentionally it may
end up being bad but i'm trying to do
something here by going king f5 we
talked about how the mating nets can be
a bit scary uh here i don't think that
white is in any danger of losing because
even in the event of a rook trade the
white king is so close and the bishop
will sacrifice itself at the very least
for these two pawns here so there's no
real risk in this position for fabiano
that's why the bar just remains around
zero it's why fabinho doesn't seem
bothered by anything that's going on
even in the event he's done two full
pawns he'll be able to hold the ensuing
end game
yes but fabiano down to
seven minutes
so um one thing maybe the only thing to
to keep an eye out for he's gonna have
another sip oh no it's water by now the
tea
is a gun
and
yeah i i like what you demonstrated that
even losing another pawn which look
would look very scary uh to most of us
uh if the pieces are active uh it should
all be good for fabiano do you think
he's gonna go rookie seven
i think he's gonna spend
a couple more minutes here although he
is getting pretty low on the clock and
the position is simplified in a way that
there aren't too many pieces remaining
but the decisions aren't that simple so
he needs to be careful here there is the
30 second increment but there's no more
time to be had except for that increment
and you don't want to be on your waning
seconds and then have a critical moment
we saw what happened yesterday right
with report against von forrest where
jordan actually blundered in time
trouble i actually you know regret even
calling it a blunder it was a very
tricky ending but he made a losing move
with his night retreat because he
thought that if the knights got traded
he would lose the king and pawn end game
so um
it's these moments that can be the
difference between a
half point and a loss and for fabiano
he's getting lower and lower on the
clock
yes but he is so hugely experienced i
wonder what about my move king f5 i
still want to to bring
the king closer
is that also an option or am i
running into into any trouble here no
it's a fine move the knight will come
back to c6 just to stop your check maybe
i'll bring my knight to d4
with check if i can make it work and my
rook is now free so the move itself is
fine i think many of the moves that
we'll see are going to be about
equivalent or just totally fine what's
more so about how the trajectory of the
game is going to go because if you allow
black's king you made this point earlier
which is a great point that king can
somehow work its way to the queen side
they need to be really concerned and so
if that rook were to move from e4 the
king was able to start walking that's
when people start fretting about
different variations and right now
everything is under control did he play
rookie seven no it's my analysis we're
still waiting to see what fabinho does
five minutes on the clock at which point
do you start getting nervous
if it were yourself
probably move one uh but uh besides
besides that
uh five minutes is plenty of time here
i i would think because it doesn't seem
like there's a losing
move that will happen that quickly even
if the c4 pawn is taken which you don't
want to happen i still think that it is
closer
for a to a white draw than it is a white
a draw draws between both players than a
win for black
and we see the close up there uh on to
the clock
uh so just under six minutes for fabiano
17 minutes and 20 seconds for sam
shankland
fabiano has gone for rookie seven jack
kicking back the king to f8 and then
putting his rook onto d7
and it's a line we were talking about
just before you give up this c4 pawn and
then you bring your king in and either
the black king gets in trouble if you
leave the rooks on the board or if you
trade the rooks let's say knight c4 king
f5 rook d6 we
swap rooks the king can go into the e6
square and then this bishop is going to
quickly attack these pawns the white
king is also
around to start attacking them and this
is just still a draw so
two pawns ahead
not enough material to work with to win
this game and i think we're getting
closer to the conclusion of the game
because
if you're sam shankland and you've done
all this work bringing the knight to the
rim to a5
just to attack the pawn on c4
if you're not gonna take it what is the
there is not really any other way to to
make uh progress here i believe can you
try
king e8
king it is rook d8 check so i can
just kick your king back to f7 i think
you have to take the pawn but it's very
clear that fabiano has no issues
with that resulting position and he
shouldn't
the king for white is just so much more
active than the black king
yes and well sam i think
he is taking his time now
[Music]
not laughing at him you know he really
is trying to win this game so you have
to give him credit he's a really hard
worker and he's working hard at the
board right now but it is kind of funny
you know he just seemed
stressed like
i need to find something there just
isn't anything to find
this dress followed by not like this
akram the first to start the not like
this is
in the chat and yeah
sam well he had a frustrating draw
against nils yesterday
and today i think again both players
likely to walk away
feeling not completely happy with the
draw if it happens
well we know what happens in vidic
schemes when he does the not like this
so i think sam's just trying to take one
out of his book he's like that guy's
winning his games
making these uh motions i'm gonna do the
same but no
he should be happy with the draw he's
played a good game
he was solid throughout and he's playing
against fabio caruana so drawing him
with black is a good result and the play
was good
indeed
a great game by sam who
i think will
soon
give up his attempts
to to win this game as fabiano
after
maybe
pressing
slightly
slightly too much finding himself
upon down he didn't lose his school
he regrouped and
found this nice
active
defense here you can go two pawns down
but as you said the king
is just simply too close and the black
pawns will drop eventually
i'm just wondering which move sam will
play will he play knight takes c4
and then
we'll see the king come to f5 or will he
do something else because there's
actually a
force draw sequence
that we were talking about rook d6 and
the reason i was mentioning uh the move
rook to d6 here
uh rather than anything else because if
rook c6 is played rook d8 rook d7 is a
draw on the spot like
you just can't do it nowhere to hide
that's it right the king on f5 is taking
away these forward squares the bishop
and the rook do the rest and the king
will just have to go to the back rank
and then back to a square like f7 so
that's why rook d6
was
my recommendation and bishop e7 check
the king comes to e8
this is also going to be a draw because
after rook takes d6 if you take the
bishop takes i don't even think about
bishop e7 initially but now that we're
here we can make a draw in a bunch of
different ways and i guess that is
really why
sam is thinking because rook d6 allows
bishop e7 check which means there's
nothing else to consider after that and
the game is a force draw
yeah i think he will
have to eventually uh admit that there
isn't any anything else
of course we can only commend him for
trying uh he is such a fighting player
but there he goes the close-up just in
time of the night capturing the pawn on
c4
and there goes fabiano's king to f5
and sam
there it is the drawer he looks at him
the hands
they shake him and that is that fiona
round three officially in the books that
was a really long round incredible and
we see
them getting up there very fast from the
board
uh he's probably not happy with how the
game concluded in the end but uh i think
very often that's the case right after
the game but then if you go back to the
hotel and and you look at the game as a
whole i think all in all sam i did great
and of course uh a draw against fabiano
with the black pieces especially when
you were on the back foot for
for ninety percent of the game is a
great result and um
and yeah what a round it has been robert
indeed and we are not
done just yet first of all here are uh
the complete results of round three we
had three draws between dudak carlson
between giri and mahmoud and the one we
just saw uh between caruana and sam
shank but robert we also had four
decisive results
we most certainly did
shanklin he tried so hard he got so far
in the end it didn't even matter
the game concluded as the draw we
thought it would be but four other games
did end decisively we see report yes
apenko vidit and jordan von forrest all
taking down their opponents so we had a
very exciting day
i mean i loved it
yes i mean
we were really treated to to
one of the early candidates for game of
the year which in case you have missed
it don't go anywhere because we are
going to go on a final quick break of
the day to get set up and we'll be back
with the rapid recap of the day in which
we'll be looking of course at the game
between daniel dubov and vidit gujarati
so don't go anywhere and we'll see you
in a second
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it was a brilliant day in vik and
without further ado we bring you the
round three rapid recap fiona we could
make no other choice than a game between
daniel dubov and vita gujarati indeed an
early front runner four game of the year
not just game of the tournament and
let's see it started off quietly with an
italian game daniel dubov he can play
anything he will play anything but he
soon sprung the first surprise
right here he played bishop g5 which is
not the most common move instead
castling for white or other variations
but instead bishop g5 and after h6 he
retreats his bishop and fiona right
around here knight a3 what an odd choice
and vidit talked about it after the game
knight a3 was the first real surprise of
the game for him after some thought he
decided to take the knight on a3 always
a double-edged decision
yes white gets the bishop hair but also
a ruined pawn structure here on the
queen side but the game started heating
up where did it he was a bit
self-critical about the move knight to
b8 but it worked out in his favor as he
rewrites the knight to d7 and here fiona
this is where it gets spicy
in the g5 kicking back the white bishop
and witted now deciding to take the pawn
on e4 which is going to of course open
up all the lines in front of that
uncastle king on e8
as vivid said this is modern chess for
you he takes this pawn on e4 it attacks
the bishop and attacks the pawn on c3 so
duval plays queen c2 we see another
brilliant choice pawn to f5 if my king's
going to be in danger let's put in all
the danger it can handle and after de5
we saw a trade rook to e1 knight takes
bishop pawn takes e4 and fiona we saw g4
things are heating up and how did vitta
handle this vidit handled things
incredibly well he was already the time
was ticking down but village just
started playing perfect chess he now uh
just ignored this g-fun
g4 push jumped with the knight into c5
and
dubois doing the same bringing his own
knight forward via
d4 and rook f8 admitting i'm never going
to castle kingside that was off the
table for a while already but that rook
on f8 robert soon uh played started
playing a very important role because
what was zubov about to uncork here
it was a heroic piece indeed we saw a
gf5 bishop f5 and now this was the first
humongous shot of the game rook takes b7
the point being that after knight takes
b7 bishop b5 is check to the miserable
king if you go king to d8 you walk into
a fork knight c6 check is a problem you
lose your queen if the bishop returns to
d7 rook takes e4 guess what white wins
your queen again that leaves you with
one other option king f7 white snaps off
this bishop on f5 hits the queen hits e4
the bishop can come back to c4 h6 is
under attack e4 as mentioned is
threatened this would have been a bad
news for vidit so fiona instead of
capturing a rook we don't have to
immediately recapture pieces just
because they took hours what a move did
it played here he took some time we were
incredibly worried you don't want to
find yourself
in this position against danny lurov
who's just sacrificed a piece but a
village gujarati he played the
incredibly calm and cool rook f6 which
turns out to be the only move in the
position
i wish i could give that like three
exclamation points and as we were just
seeing in the previous variation that
when this bishop came to b5 with check
the king got in the rook's path but with
the rook here now knight takes b7 is in
fact a threat and dubois said
threat what are you talking about let's
play queen to b1 the knight took the
rook the queen swooped into b7 and
here's where everything broke loose rook
d8 knight f5 rook f5 and fiona from a
distance perhaps dubop didn't see vivid
saving grace here indeed it looks like
the black king is in a lot of trouble
all the pieces are swooping in
we are screwing the queen and the king
rookie five the move you want to play
immediately it doesn't work robert
no it does not you'll see that
evaluation bar goes sky high because
queen c6 check ends the story here if
the king were going to go to f8 queen
takes h6 with check the queen can go to
h8 with check pick up a rook in the
center of the board he had the rook
blocked on d7 queen g6 check if king f8
we just told you what would happen queen
h6 queen h8 actually queen g8 is mating
one what am i talking about i can't see
the obvious but instead king d8 the
point is queen g8 check queen blocks no
we don't trade queens we do it on our
own terms because the bishop defends the
queen on g8 we stole a rook in the
center that means white would have been
a piece ahead
and maybe the move that vetted played
and
that duboff might have missed from a
distance the saving grace rook d1 check
freeing up that all-important d8 square
for the king uh duboff here stepped out
of the jack and now rookie 5 is a
different story
completely different story as you
mentioned the d8 square is vacated king
f8 would have run to the same exact
problem with the check and queen h8
winning this rook in the center so king
d8 and the fireworks just really started
continuing queen eight check king to d7
bishop b5 check that king goes up to e6
we'll give it another check why don't we
the king steps to f6 and now after queen
h a check it's not losing because of the
move king to f5 fiona
incredible stuff what a king run
by
vidid gujarati and here uh is it the
moment where daniel dubois finally took
the wrong step robert it was he made the
move f3 which i can understand because
rook takes e5 queen takes e5 is a check
to the king a check to the queen that
would force the queen trade and black is
up a rook for a bishop so instead of
these moves the only move was queen ca
check i can forgive daniel for missing
this because king takes e4 is not
possible queen g4 checked you see the
bar go up king to d5 it is not queen
takes rook that's the move that we were
all thinking no it is queen c4 check the
king has only one square and this is
sort of a smothered mate the rook and
the queen they block the king's access
to free squares that is check and mate
on the board so that is what daniel
dubois missed and vidit was missing
nothing after that was not played yeah
f3 daniel duboff taking a wrong step and
vidit was just clinical from here on out
with the king that has been all over the
board already now running for a safe
haven all the way in the white camp it's
heading for c1 that's why daniel he
didn't try to give another check because
the king would go to d1 and finally two
c1 when there is no more checks in the
position
and so instead daniel tried bishop c6
but now all that was left to do
for vidit was to put the finishing
touches on this position and he made it
look easy he pushes his pawn to g4 one
last check king d2 and that is where the
game concludes because queen f2 check
even queen e2 forcing the queens off the
board because the white queen is pinned
to the king that would end any debate
because black is up that rook for the
bishop and we're going to end our game
here that was your round three rapid
recap
an absolutely stunning game we hope you
all enjoyed this recap and not only did
vidit win this brilliant game it also
proposed him to the lead of the
tournament he is now in the so lead on
two and a half out of three followed by
a pack of five players on two out of
three among them uh world champion
magnus carlsen world cup winner ian
kristof duda and the fantastic um
hungarian attacking player richard
report andreas panko who beat his fellow
countrymen um sergey karjakin today and
of course the defending champion jordan
van furies who will be playing against
his boss magnus carlsen tomorrow robert
yeah he's gonna say tomorrow you're not
the boss of me that was a one-time deal
only for the world championship but
jordan said it's always a pleasure to
play against the world champion i'm sure
they did some sparring some training
games as part of the preparation for the
match against yonder palmishi but there
are six other games that look equally
fascinating fiona i'm in particular
gujarati white pieces he's the
determined leader he takes on andre yes
apenko who now has two out of three
after beating his compatriot sergey
koryakin indeed both of them will be
coming fresh of a win and they will be
eager uh to keep the run going and i
think tomorrow is also an interesting
day because it is the last
day before the rest day which is coming
up in just two days so it's always
curious to see how much are the players
willing
to risk so
a lot of new story lines to follow
tomorrow we will be back same place same
time it starts at 2 p.m central european
time that's 5 a.m pacific
robert what a day it has been thank you
so much to you thank you so much to the
chat thank you for watching us
and robert i'll leave you the final
words
well it felt like three days in one and
there were four decisive games so we had
a treat vikanze brings out the best in
many players and it's just such a fun
tournament filled with the who's who of
chess the top rated players in the world
some youngsters like pragmata it was not
his day today but tomorrow the sun still
shines he gets to come back to the board
and try his and best and try to get
another win or not another he hasn't had
one yet but another in his illustrious
career already at just 16. so fiona
thank you so much for joining me i know
it's been a long long day but day four
should just be even better than the
great day three we just had i'm
certainly looking forward to it i'll see
you then i'll see you all in the chat
tomorrow have a good one we'll see you
then take care bye bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you